ALL RIGHT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AT THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE. COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER WE ARE GRATEFUL
EACH OF YOU ARE HERE FOR OUR
JULY EIGHTH EDITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WHO ARE HERE IN
PERSON AND HEARING THE STREAM
ONLINE. WE'VE GOT TO BE TO TAKE
CARE AT SOME HOUSEKEEPING FIRST
AND FOREMOST- FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO BE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
TODAY- AN ACCESS CODE. IS AS
FOLLOWS ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT ONE EIGHT
NINE THE CODE IS TWO EIGHT
SEVEN SIX ZERO FIVE NINE. AGAIN.
877-226-8189 WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING. YOUR QUESTIONS YOUR
COMMENTS ON THE BILLS THAT ARE
IN FRONT OF US HERE TODAY.
FIRST AND FOREMOST IS CENTER
SKINNER WILL BE TEMPORARILY
REPLACING CENTER WIENER FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. WE'RE GOING TO
WELCOME THAT THE GOOD SENATOR
TO COMMITTEE HERE IN JUST A
BIT. WE HAVE SIXTEEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THIRTEEN WITH
THE AUTHOR PRESENTING RIGHT
HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. THREE ARE PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT. BEFORE WE GET INTO OUR
CONSENT COUNTER WE'RE GOING TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WE'RE GONNA
SAY GOOD AFTERNOON I TO MR
CANAL MISTER NOW CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND THAT'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SENATOR
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE PRESIDENT
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN
PRESIDENT SENATOR DORADO. DRAWS.
PRESIDENT SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR SKINNER. YOU HAVE A
QUORUM THE QUORUM IS BEEN
ESTABLISHED THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER GRINNELL- WE'RE GOING TO
ASK A TO SEE IF THERE IS A
MOTION BY COMMITTEE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE- TWO
THREE ITEMS WHAT DID IT LOOK AT
THAT WE GOT THAT CENTER DRAWS
WITH THE MOTION. THREE ITEMS ON
TODAY'S CONTENT CONTENT
CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER ONE ITEM
NUMBER THREE IN ITEM FOR ITEM
ONE THREE AND FOUR AND MOTION
IS ON THE FLOOR AT BY CENTER
DRIVES OKAY. MR CANAL CAN YOU
UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO ADOPT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE
MCGUIRE- A SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN A SENATOR DORADO
THEY'RE ALSO- IS SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR SKINNER.
IT'S A CURRENTLY A THREE ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE CONTENT COUNTER
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MEMBERS WE
DO HAVE QUITE A FEW ITEMS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THAT ARE GONNA
GENERATE MOST LIKELY A LOT OF
DISCUSSION- WE WANT TO REMIND
FOLKS THAT WILL HAVE A MAXIMUM
OF TWO WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT.
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THESE ARE GONNA BE OUR MAXIMUM
LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. EACH LEAD WITNESS
IN SUPPORT AND OR IN OPPOSITION
WILL BE GIVEN TWO MINUTES EACH.
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS IN
CLEANING PROTOCOLS AND LEAVE
ENOUGH TIME FOR MEMBERS TO. BE
ABLE TO DEBATE IMPROPERLY
DISCUSSED THE BILL'S. THERE IS
A SLIGHT POSSIBILITY THAT WE
MAY NEED TO LIMIT TESTIMONY ON
SOME BILLS. IT LIMITATIONS ARE
NECESSARY THESE LIMITS WILL BE
EQUALLY APPLIED. TO THE SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION FOR EACH BILL
AGAIN LET ME JUST REPEAT THAT
WE WILL HAVE EQUAL TIME FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION- WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU CAN
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR. SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION WE ASK IF IT'S
ALRIGHT WITH EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
TODAY TO BE A TO MEET YOUR
DEVICE. OTHERWISE IT MAY SOUND
LIKE A CAT FIGHT VIA A SQUEAL
ON YOUR TELEPHONE COMING INTO
THE COMMITTEE. IN THE UNLIKELY
EVENT IN AN INTIMATE AN
INDIVIDUAL BECOMES UNRULY
EITHER ONLINE OR HERE IN PERSON
THAT INDIVIDUAL- MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
AT THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE ALL
RIGHT WITH THAT HOUSEKEEPING
DONE AGAIN THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING US. WE DO HAVE AUTHORS
HERE WE WANT TO SAY. THANK YOU
TO MR CHIU MISTER GRAYSON WE'RE
GOING TO START OUT WITH MR
QUIRK. A SIMILAR RECORD ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT TODAY THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN I WANNA TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO MR
QUIRK WE'VE BEEN IN- THAT
COLLABORATIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH
THIS. IS IN THE RECORD COMES
THE TABLE. ALWAYS TO BE TO WORK
THINGS OUT I JUST WANTED TAKE
YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER COURT.
I FOR THAT CLUB. THAT WE DO
HAVE A- PENDING AND ALTER THE
FLOOR OVER TO YOU SIR. BOB
CERTAINLY SIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IN SENATORS FOR. TAKING
THE- YOUR DUTIES HERE TODAY
VERY SERIOUSLY. NO GOOD BILL
GOES ON CHANGED. THAT'S JUST
HOW THINGS ARE AROUND HERE AND
SHOULD BE OUR FIRST THING WE
DID WAS NEGOTIATE WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES WITH THE RURAL
COUNTIES AND WE GOT THEM TO GO
NEUTRAL BY TAKING AMENDMENTS
DEALING WITH SAFETY- THE WE
STILL HAVE OPPOSITION FROM FEW
LOCAL CITIES. AS WELL AS THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA A COMMUNICATION WORKERS
OF AMERICA HAVE RAISED OF THE
SAME ISSUES IS THE CITY'S ARM
WE'VE ASKED HIM TO MEET WITH US
THEY HAVE NOT AGREED TO ME- WE
SATISFIED THE CITY'S- CONCERNS
ABOUT SAFETY AND WE ARE NOW-
GOING ON TO CHECK OTHER THINGS
THAT THE COMMITTEE IS WORRIED
ABOUT. THERE WERE SEVERAL
ISSUES MENTIONED IN THE
ANALYSIS- IN THE LAST DAY WE'VE
AGREED TO- WE FIVE. I THINK
FIFTH OUR- IN PRINCIPLE WE'VE
AGREED TO SOME LANGUAGE. EITHER
THE COMMITTEE OR THE OTHERS MAY
TALK ABOUT SOME ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL TWEAKS BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL SORT OF IN THE MIDDLE OF
IT I PROMISE NOT TO BRING THIS
UP ON THE FLOOR AND TO YOUR
COMMITTEE IS ABSOLUTELY. YOUR
STAFF IN YOURSELF MISTER CHAIRS
REPRESENT OF THE COMMITTEE ARE
ABSOLUTELY FINISHED WITH ALL
THE TWEAKS BUT I THINK IN
PRINCIPLE WHERE THERE- SO- AB
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN MODIFIES THE
STATE'S BROADBAND PERMITTING
PROCESS TO ENSURE IT ALIGNS
WITH UPDATED FEDERAL RULES
SHOULD MAKE SURE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MAKE DECISIONS
WITHIN FEDERALLY MANDATED
TIMELINES AND AGAIN THEY CAN
REJECT OR ACCEPT WE'RE JUST
ASKING THEM TO DO IT WITHIN A
CERTAIN TIMELINE AND WE'VE MADE
SURE ALTHOUGH WE THOUGHT THIS
WAS INHERENT BUT BECAUSE OF
CONCERNS BOTH BY THIS COMMITTEE
AND- ENERGY ON THE
COMMUNICATIONS. ARE THAT CITIES
HAVE PLENTY OF TIME TO BRING
THIS TO COURT- IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN I AUTHORED LEGISLATION
THAT ESTABLISHED A SHOT CLOCK
REMEDY FOR PERMITS- THERE WERE
NOT ACTED UPON BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITHIN FEDERAL
TIMELINES IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE- FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS.
COMMISSION ADOPTED NEW RULES
REGARDING THE SHOT CLOCK AB
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. PROVIDES
CLARITY ALSO AROUND THE
STARTING POINT FOR THE SHOT
CLOCK AS WELL AS CLARITY FOR
THE EXISTING DEEMED APPROVED
PROCESS. AT THE CONCLUSION OF
THE SHOT CLOCK. NOW TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN I HAVE ROCHELLE SWANSON
ON BEHALF OF CROWN CASTLE
AMERICA HOFFMAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION. I ASKED MY
WITNESSES TO BE BRIEF- PERHAPS
TWO MINUTES EACH- BECAUSE THERE
ARE SO MANY BILLS UP TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
JENNIFER ANISTON EVERY YEAR AND
TAKE THOSE AND THEN IT'S
CORRECT YEAH I'M TAKING THE
MEMORIES YOU ABSOLUTELY YEAH
IT'S JUST I THINK YOU OR WE MAY
TWEAK WHERE WORD OR TWO. AND
BUT I WANT TO SWEAR THAT I WILL
NOT GO FORWARD. UNLESS YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR WHAT WE WORK IT
OUT NO I AM WORK IT OUT YEAH
AND JUST WANT TO SAY AGAIN- TWO
IS IN THE RECORD HOW GRATEFUL
WE ARE I TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT RELATIONSHIP THAT MEANS A
LOT TO US IN I KNOW THAT I IT
WILL GET EVERYTHING SMOOTHED
OVER SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ASSEMBLY RECORD VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHT SO WE DO HAVE TWO MINUTES
AT FOR EACH INDIVIDUAL WE'RE
GONNA START WITH ROCHELLE
SWANSON FROM COUN CASTLE THEN
WE'LL GO TO MISS HOFFMAN FROM
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION EACH OF OUR
WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
AT TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. MISS ONCE IN THE FLOOR
IS YOURS YOU ARE NOW IN
COMMITTEE. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU A SELF. GOV AFFAIR MANAGER
FOR CROWN CASTLE. I REALLY WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
IN NEW CHAIR MCGUIRE IN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FIGURES A
COMMITMENT TO EXCELLENCE BONTA
AND EXPANSION. INCLUDING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IN CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING ALL THE HARD WORK
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS.
WE SHARE YOUR GOAL ENOUGH OVER
PROUD TO SPONSOR EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN. BECAUSE ALLOW
HIGH SPEED INTERNET PROJECT. TO
BE COMPLETED IN THE MONTH. OF
THE YEAR. CALIFORNIA ALREADY
PASSED FROM THE TOP PART IN
PLACE. FOR BROADBAND PROJECTS
THINGS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARDS
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND FROM
TWENTY FIFTEEN. THIS LIVE IN
WORKING WELL AND IT'S. HELP
PREVENT PERMIT DELAYS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. THE BILL SIMPLY AT
THE CALIFORNIA'S LOTTERY THE
NEW STRUGGLE TO. THAT WERE
RECENT ADOPT FOR SHOT BLOCKS
ARE TO SYSTEM. IT ALSO PROVIDES
CLARITY AROUND ONE SHOT CLOCK
START IN THE PROCESS WITH THE
CONCLUSION OF THE SHOT CLOCK.
AB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN STRIKES
THE RIGHT BALANCE. IT PRESERVES
LOCAL CONTROLLED BY ALLOWING
CITIES TO USE WHATEVER PROCESS
THEY WANT TO EVALUATE BROADBAND
COMMIT. AND ALLOWS THEM TO
APPROVE OR DENY THE BROADBAND
COMMIT. IT ALSO HAS ENHANCED
PROTECTION FOR PROJECT IN THE
RIGHT OF WAY. THIS IS MY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT GROUPS LIKE THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES.
THE SECOND RC RC ARE NEUTRAL.
ALL THE BILL DOESN'T MAKE SURE
THAT CITIES MAKE A DECISION TO
APPROVE OR DENY. ABROAD
EMPLOYMENT WITHIN FEDERALLY
MANDATED TIMELINES WHICH ARE
TYPICALLY TWO TO THREE MONTHS
DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF
PROJECT. THIS BILL WILL MAKE A
REAL DIFFERENCE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO DESPERATELY
NEED IMPROVED INTERNET ACCESS
FOR SCHOOL. TELEHEALTH REMOTE
WORK AND COMMERCE THIRTY SECOND
WILL HELP PROTECT YOUR DEVICE.
BY BUILDING THE BROADBAND
PROJECT MORE QUICKLY
COMMUNITIES FOR CONTROL I THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR WORK IN A DENTAL
BROADBAND IN THE STATE AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR EYES
OUT. THANK YOU SO MUCH RESPOND
TO ME VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO ME
TALKING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES WE'LL GIVE YOU
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT. MISHAP IN
THE FLOOR. IS YOURS WELCOME THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOODBYE JERRY
MEMBERS- NAME IS ERICA HOW. AND
LEGISLATIVE. WITH THE CAL.
SCHOOL OF SOUTH. HE FTA IS
COMMITTEE TO PRIVATE EXPANSION
IN CALIFORNIA TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. AND IMPROVE
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
STUDENTS. AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THE LAST YEAR SHOWED THAT NOW
MORE THAN EVER THAT THE ADDAMS
THEY EACH DO ALL IT CAN. TO
CONNECT OUR SCHOOLS AND
STUDENTS HIGH SPEED INTERNET.
WE SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN BECAUSE INSURANCE THAT
THE SOME OF THE BEST COMMON
PRACTICES. WILL BE UTILIZED BY
CITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS CALIFORNIANS
NEED FOR RELIABLE HIGH SPEED
INTERNET IS CRITICAL- COVET
NINETEEN INCREASE THE NEED FOR
INTERNET ACCESS FOR STUDENTS TO
ADDRESS. BOTH DISTANCE LEARNING
ISSUES. BUT ALSO FOR HOMEWORK-
ISSUES AND RESEARCH ON THE
DIGITAL PLATFORM FOR STUDENTS-
UNFORTUNATELY MANY THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
THE INTERNET. OR NEED IMPROVE
SERVICES. AB FIVE SEVEN WELL
HOW CLOSE PROJECTED TO DIVIDE
BY SPEEDING UP BECAUSE OF
BROADBAND PROJECT. THE QUICKER
THE BROADBAND PERMIT CAN BE
APPROVED AND CONSTRUCTED ONE
COMMUNITY THE QUICKER
CONSTRUCTION BEGIN CAN BEGIN IN
ANOTHER COMMUNITY THE BILL
MAINTAINS LOCAL CONTROL.
ALLOWING CITIES TO APPROVE OR
DENY PERMITS IT JUST MAKE SURE
THAT THEY MAKE A DECISION
WITHIN THE FEDERAL TIME LINES.
THAT ARE ALLOWED CFTA SUPPORT
STREAMLINING TO HELP ACCELERATE
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT THIS BILL
MAKE SURE THAT STATE AND
FEDERAL BROADBAND FUNDING WILL
BENEFIT LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THIRTY
SECOND THESE REASONS WE ARE
HERE AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY THAT WRAPS UP OUR TO LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES TWO MINUTES
EACH WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
OR TO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR BOTH WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH AND CHERYL
SURE. WE'RE GONNA WALK AND- THE
GOOD DOCTOR TO BE ABLE TO COME
FORWARD AT TO THE PODIUM WE
WELCOME YOU THEN WE'RE GONNA GO
TO ALEX CROWN- MAKE SURE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
TODAY YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
IT'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU HONORING MIKE MCGUIRE. AND
THE STATE MEMBERS. IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS PLEASE ASK AFTER MY
TESTIMONY OUR TEST AND AFFIRM
THAT THESE STATEMENTS ARE TRUE
ACKERMAN WITHIN MY PERSONAL
KNOWLEDGE. I'M DOCTOR CHERYL
SHARE MY PHD IS IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION. FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT. AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING THROUGH THE MARINE- TV
WITH MY TV SHOW IN PODCAST FOR
NINE YEARS TO PROMOTE. SAFETY
OF LIFE AND PROPERTY. THE EGGS
PURPOSE OF THE TWO. ACT UNDER
AB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN FALLS
WHICH BUT WHICH AB THIRTY THREE
FOUR FIVE SKEWS ME FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN VIOLATES. AS A FOURTH
GENERATION CALIFORNIAN AND A
DIRECT DESCENDANT OF CHARLES
COATES WERE THINKING A ONE OF
THE SIGNATORIES OF THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION I ALSO INTEND TO
ENSURE THAT OUR FEDERAL AND
STATE CONSTITUTIONS REMAIN
INTACT HOWEVER SB FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN IS CLEARLY. IN VIOLATION
OF BOTH IN OFFERING AN OPEN
ENDED CONTRACT FOR FCC TO DO
WHATEVER IT MAY WANT IN
PERPETUITY AB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
SB FIVE FIVE SIX SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT AND RELATED BILLS
ARE NOT JUST AN AFFRONT ON
CONTRACT LAW THERE ALSO.
SABOTAGING THE LOCAL CONTROL
GUARANTEED BY THE US CONGRESS
THESE BILLS WHEN HARM OUR
CITIES THREATEN. THREATENING
RESIDENTS PUBLIC SAFETY PRIVACY
AND FREEDOM FROM WARRANTLESS
SURVEILLANCE THE SENATE KNOWS
THESE BILLS ARE NOT OF BY AND
FOR THE PEOPLE BUT RATHER BILLS
WRITTEN BY ALEC. AND INDUSTRY
LAWYERS THIRTY SECONDS RUSHED
FORWARD TO AVOID PUBLIC
SCRUTINY WE THE PEOPLE WANT
WIRED BROADBAND SERVICE FIBER
OPTICS TO THE PREMISES. FOR
WHICH WE'VE ALREADY PAID FOR.
IN OUR PHONE BILLS FROM
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE. TO THE
PRESENT NOT HAZARDOUS WRELESS
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT FAR TOO
CLOSE TO HOMES USING EXCESSIVE
POWER YOU MUST ABIDE BY THE
TITLE FOUR SEVEN USC. THREE
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCHDOCTOR. SORRY THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GONNA HAVE YOU CONCLUDE
PLEASE- THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
I CERTAINLY HAVE MORE TO SAY
BUT THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME REALLY
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TESTIMONY.
ALTHOUGH THE OPPRESSION ABOUT
THREE MINUTES. YEAH IT'S TWO
MINUTES SIR SO WE WELCOME YOU
TO COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE OKAY. WE'RE
GOING TO WELCOME. MR CROWN HERE
AT TWO COMMITTEE. WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE SIR
WE LOOK FOR YOUR TESTIMONY YOU
HAVE. TWO MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE
YOU THIRTY SECOND PROMPTED
WELCOME SEARCH COMMITTEE THANK
YOU TERM ACQUIRES THE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
MY NAME IS ALEX CRONIN A
LICENSED PHYSICAL THERAPIST A
GRADUAL FRESNO STATE WERE ALSO
PLAYED FOUR YEARS SINCE AS A
STARTER ON THE TENNIS TEAM. I'M
ALSO THE FOUNDER OF SAFE
TECHNOLOGY FOR SANTA ROSA AND
AFTER YEARS OF HARD WORKING
COMMUNITY SUPPORT JUST LAST
WEEK SANTA ROSA PASSED TO
PROTECT THE SMALL CELL
ORDINANCE. WIRELESS OF ANY G.
IS THIRD RATE. CHEAP BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE FAR INFERIOR TO
FIBER OPTIC OR CABLE SERVICES.
DIRECTLY TO HOMES. WIRELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT RELIABLY
FAST ENOUGH AND NOT SYMMETRIC
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
CONCEPT TO UNDERSTAND. IT MUST
HAVE THE SAME SPEED UP AND DOWN
WHO SAYS THAT. THE DEPARTMENT
OF TREASURY IN THE JUNE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE FUNDING
REQUIREMENTS FOR BROADBAND
CORONAVIRUS RECOVERY FUNDS.
WIRELESS BROADBAND CAN'T MEET
THIS STANDARD ACCORDING TO
OKALOOSA BE CHECKED IN PC
MAGAZINE IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE FIVE G. IS NO FASTER THAN
FOUR G. IT'S A SYMMETRIC UPLOAD
SPEEDS ARE A SMALL FRACTION OF
ITS DOWNLOAD SPEEDS. WHAT IS
NEEDED FOR FEDERAL BROADBAND
FUNDING IS A HUNDRED MEGABITS
DOWN AS WHICH WHAT I RECEIVE.
AND A HUNDRED UP IS WHEN I SEND
OUT. ONLY CABLE OR FIBER TO THE
HOME CAN DO THIS WIRELESS CAN'T
RELY WE DO THIS IT IS NOT
FUTURE PROOF. AS WE CONTINUE TO
REQUIRE MORE MORE BANDWIDTH FOR
ECONOMY AND EDUCATION IT WILL
BE IMPOSSIBLE FOR WIRELESS TO
KEEP UP WITH THIS DEMAND.
WIRELESS USES MICROWAVE
RADIATION A PROVEN CARCINOGEN
IN THEIR- TALKS IN IMMUNO
SUPPRESSOR. THROUGH THE AIR TO
SEND AND RECEIVE DATA ABOUT
FIBER OPTICS USES VISIBLE LIGHT
THREE CABLE TO SEND AND RECEIVE
DATA DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
WIRELESS AND FIBER OPTIC
FREQUENCIES ARE A MILLION
TIMES. THIS MEANS FIBER CAN
CARRY A MILLION TIMES MORE DATA
THAN WIRELESS CAN'T. AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN IS A DEEMED
APPROVED NIGHTMARE FOR
LOCALITIES IT WILL PUT MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS AGAINST OUR
CITIES AND LOCALITIES. AND
COUNTIES. LOCAL BERMAN CENTER
OBLIGATE TO DELIVER ACTUAL
PUBLIC SAY. AND ENJOYED
MINISTRIES CAL. DO NOT WANT NAY.
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS FLOODED
WITH CELL TOWERS OUTSIDE THEIR
BEDROOM WINDOWS DO YOU SENATORS.
SENATORS PLEASE UNDERSTAND SEC
SHOT CLOCKS FOR SO CALLED SMALL
CELLS ARE RULED BY THE NINTH
CIRCUIT TO BE PRESUMPTIVE ONLY
THAT MEANS THEY'RE NOT THEIR
STATEMENTS OF FCC PREFERENCES
THEY ARE NOT FEDERAL LAW. DON'T
LET THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY
BAMBOOZLE YOU HERE AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN IS ATTEMPTING TO
TURN WEEK FCC PREFERENCES INTO
CONCRETE STATE LAW TRUSTING THE
SPONSORS OF THESE BILLS THE
WIRELESS COMPANIES TO MAKE GOOD
ON CONTRACTUALLY. FORCIBLE
PROMISES IS SIMPLY PUTTING THE
BROKEN PROMISES OF THE PAST. IS
COMPARABLE YOU CAME HERE TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
ALONG WITH ALL WHO ARE JOINING
AND WE HEARD FROM ACT TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO NOW IS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT- AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO. END IT WITH THOSE WHO ARE
IN OPPOSITION- BEFORE WE DO
THAT THOUGH WE WILL OF COURSE
BE CHECKING WHETHER OVERFLOW
ROOM AND ANYONE HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. SO IF
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU TO PLEASE
RISE NOW- IN WE'RE GONNA REMIND
FOLKS. FIRST AND LAST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. AFTERNOON HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS RUDY RAY S. TIME WITH
VERIZON AND I'M HERE TO
REGISTER OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
A BI THIRTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
AND ALSO THE SUPPORT OF OVER
TWO THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS HAVE
SIGNED AN ONLINE PETITION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA
DO WE'RE GONNA SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE THREE SEVEN TO PLEASE RISE
NOW. KERN SCENE NO ONE WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE AND GOING
TO BE CHECKING IN WITH FOLKS
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT. THEN WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THOSE WHO WERE
IN OPPOSITION. SO LET'S CHECK
IN WITH A TELECONFERENCE LINE.
ANOTHER MODERATOR GOOD
AFTERNOON IF YOU CAN PLEASE
QUEUE UP ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THREE
SEVEN. NOW GOOD AFTERNOON I'D
BE GLAD TO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE THREE SEVEN. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE WANT TO REMIND FOLKS
IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE A
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING
VIA. LIVE TELECONFERENCE PLEASE
DIAL EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE EIGHT NINE THE
CODE IS TWO EIGHT SEVEN. SIX
ZERO FIVE NINE NOT A MODERATOR
WILL TURN IT OVER TO YOU FOR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN. THANK YOU AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE EIGHT IN Q. ONE
ONE SEVENTY WILL START WITH
YOUR LINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
ROCKSTAND GOLD REPRESENTING.
THE WIRELESS INFRASTRUCTURE
ASSOCIATION INC REPORTED EIGHTY
FIVE THREE SEVEN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTER NEARLY ANY TALK AT ON
BEHALF OF TECH THAT IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUSTIN HI ON
BEHALF OF THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL OF ALL
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE PHONE
CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN ACRE LINE IF
NEEDED. YES HELLO HI MY NAME
CORRECTLY. AND I READ PROJECT
ENDED UP ORANGE COUNTY. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIVE THREE
SEVEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH MA'AM
INDEPTH WE MAY HAVE SOME FOLKS
WHO BEING BEING OPPOSITION
DURING SUPPORT SOME FOLKS IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION WE
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S PATIENCE
BUT WE TAKE ALL INDIVIDUALS
HERE SO THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
PHONE CALL MA'AM LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER MINIMUM ORDER.
ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS
MICHAEL GUNNING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRKS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH MICHAEL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. ONE OH SIX YOUR
pCHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS JONATHAN
HERE BELL ON BEHALF OF C. T. I.
A TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT TIME
PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THEIR LITTLE WITH THE BAY AREA
COUNSEL AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BEFORE
WE OPEN LINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
AS A REINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OF THE PORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
THREE SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON- DAVID NELSON YOU'RE
A DIRECTOR PUBLIC POLICY FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASIA-PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE CALLING IN
STRONG. SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALL. AND NO ONE ELSE'S
SUPPORTER MAKING MINIMUM RATE
WILL BE BACK WITH YOU WE'RE NOT
GOING TO LOOK FOR THOSE WHO MAY
BE IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. IF YOU COULD
PLEASE RISE WE'RE GONNA LOOK
FOR A FIRST AND LAST NAME
ORGANIZATION. IN YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL PLEASE PRETTY. GOOD
TO SEE SIR WELCOME TO COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SHERMAN WIRE MY NAME
IS PAUL MCGOVERN I'M WITH
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE SUPPORT.
ELECTROMAGNETIC SENSITIVE
CALIFORNIANS WHO KNOW THAT PHD
ISN'T. AS X. HAVE NO
CREDENTIALS TO MAKE ANY
STATEMENTS A SAFETY. WITH
REGARDS TO MICROWAVE RADIATION
EXPOSURE AND WE OPPOSE. AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR TESTIFYING TODAY
SIR. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
INDIVIDUAL IF ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE ME TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
IF YOU COULD PLEASE RISE INCOME
FOR THE PODIUM. ALL RIGHT C.
KNOWN OUT TO RISE RE NOT GONNA
BE GOING TOWARD TELECONFERENCE
LINE WE'RE GONNA WELCOME ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE ME TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN. NOT A MODERATOR
THAT'S A QUEUE UP THOSE COLORS
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE THREE
SEVEN NOW. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FIVE THREE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE SEVEN Q. ONE ONE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NICOLE GORMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF ONTARIO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ACT
CURRENTLY IN PRINT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY THAT'S GOING
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. ONE SIXTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BURKE
CRYSTAL KIT OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS AND
RESPECTFUL. YEAH THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOU
TOOK YOURSELF OUT OF Q. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO WILL OPEN UP
YOUR LINE ONE FORTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO- GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S STEPHANIE
THOMAS- MEMBER OF WIRELESS.
RADIATION EDUCATION AND DEFENSE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY THAT'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS ELLIE MARC I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA BRAIN
TUMOR ASSOCIATION I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED. TO AB FIVE THREE SEVEN
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOU
CALLING IN TODAY THAT'S GOT OUR
NEXT CALLER. ONE EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL GOOD CARE
OF ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS CATHERINE DODD WITH THE
ALLIANCE OF NURSES FOR A
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT WITH STRONG
OPPOSITION AB FIVE THREE SEVEN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE EIGHTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE EIGHTY FOUR
YEAR AND COMMITTEE LINE ONE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PROCEED. AYE
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
HELLO. YES PLEASE HELLO WE
WELCOME YOU I'M SEATED. THANK
YOU THIS IS PHOEBE SORGHUM WITH
THE BERKELEY FELLOWSHIP OF YOU
USE SOCIAL JUSTICE COMMITTEE
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIVE
THREE THREE SEVEN THANK THANK
YOU BABY ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ONE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS VICKY
SIEVERS REPRESENTING THE EMF
SAFETY NETWORK ELECTROMAGNETIC
FIELD SAFETY NETWORK IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
LET'S CHECK IN WITH HER NEXT
TIME PLEASE. WHEN EIGHTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
JENNY MILLER I REPRESENT.
TOWARDS AN INTERNET OF LIVING
BEINGS AND THIS BILL IS A TOTAL
CATASTROPHE FOR CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL LET'S CHECK IN WITH
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND
BEFORE YOU OPEN LIKE ONE NINETY
FOUR AS A REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN YOU CAN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY FIVE THREE SEVEN YOU
MADE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE NINETY FOR YOUR LINE
IS NOW. THEREMIN OFF. OF UNITED
EDUCATORS OF SAN FRANCISCO
CALLING PRIVATE CAPACITY.
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE
CALL TODAY. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE IN JUPITER CURRENTLY
WITH ANOTHER ONE MOMENT PLEASE
SOUNDS GOOD. PREHEATER BASE
PATIENTS WERE GOING TO BE
BRINGING IN OUR LAST CALLER FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION.
OF AB FIVE THREE SEVEN AND THEN
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MET A MODERATOR WE'RE
GOING TO TURN IT BACK OVER TO
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WILL NOT OPEN MY
NUMBER ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOT AFFECTED. CHARLOTTE
IS KIRTI ARTS. COUNTY ARE. TO
OSLO. ONE WE HAVE NO ONE COULD
NOT. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE LAYS IN GENERAL OKAY
AND ALL WHO JOINING US AS BRING
IT TO- THAT COMMITTEE TO BE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THIS IN THE
RECORD- INDOOR MOTION WE'RE
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO ITS
SENATOR TO RAZA FLOOR'S YOURS.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- HAVE
A FEW. QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR- AND I WORKED. IN THE
PAST A WITH THE AUTHOR SO I
APPRECIATE. THE DEPTH WITH
WHICH TO GO INTO THESE ISSUES-
ONE IS ABOUT THE FIRST ISSUE IS
ABOUT- OF THE SHOT CLOCK IN THE
TIMING- ONE IS. IF THE
PARAMETERS FOR THE SHOT CLOCK
HAVE BEEN SET. WHY PURSUE
LEGISLATION- ON THE SAME ISSUE.
WELL THIS ALL STARTED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHEN I WAS SITTING IN
THE AND- A MEETING. ACTUALLY
WEAPON ARE DONE BY THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES. AND THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT YOU HAVE TO
DO IN THE RECENT SHOT CLOCK THE
WITH STEP BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND WHAT THE PERSON
DID THE BRIEFING CARE WAS. ARM
YEAH THIS IS A SHOT CLOCK BUT
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT THEY HAVE
TO SUE YOU. TO ENFORCE IT AND
THEY'RE NEVER GOING TO SUE YOU
SO IT'S NOT SOMETHING TO WORRY
ABOUT THERE WAS IN FACT POINT
THAT I DECIDED WE SHOULD HAVE A
REMEDY- AND IT WAS MY IDEA THAT
IT WOULD BE DEEMED APPROVED%
THAT WAS ME. AND WENT ON FROM
THERE AND IT DID BECOME LAW.
OKAY- YOU MENTIONED OR A
MENTION WAS MADE OF THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS WHO HAVE
RAISED ISSUES OF SAFETY- AND SO
HOW DO YOU HOW ARE YOU
ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE ARE
REGARDING THE SAFETY RISKS THAT
THE- THAT MIGHT BE IMPOSED OR
MIGHT BE YEAH- THAT WORKERS AT
THE PUBLIC- WHAT WOULD HAVE TO
FACE- AND IT SEEMS TO BE THAT
WE'RE GOING EVEN FURTHER THAN
THAT- WELL. LET ME JUST LEAVE
IT AT THAT SO- THE THING WHEN
WE WORKED WITH THE AND I'M VERY
PROUD AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES AND RURAL
COUNTIES WORKING WITH THAT.
BECAUSE IN THE BEGINNING. ARE
CONCERNED WATCHING IN FACT
SAFETY AND BY THE WAY REMEMBER
C. W. WAY- LOCAL NINE ONE ONE
NINE- THE- THE CONCERT IS BOTH
WORKERS WHO WOULD BE OUT TO THE
RIGHT OF WAY AND OF COURSE-
DISRUPTION OF TRAFFIC FLOW AT
CETERA. SO WHAT WE'VE SAID IS
THAT WE WANT THE CITIES TO COME
UP WITH THE FLAM WE'VE ASKED
THEM TO DO IT- WITHOUT DELAY
BUT YOU KNOW. WE ABSOLUTELY
WANT TO PLAN I WANT TO PLAN I
KNOW THE COMPANIES WANT TO PLAN
THE WORKERS WE NEED A PLAN FOR
THEIR SAFETY AND THAT'S WHAT'S
IN THE BILL AND THAT'S WHEN THE
CITIES AND THE RURAL COUNTIES
DROPPED THEIR OPPOSITION AND
BECAME NEUTRAL SO I THINK WE'VE
ADDRESSED THAT IF ANYONE
FRANKLY BETWEEN NOW AND WHEN IT
GOES TO THE SENATE FLOOR IT
SAYS THAT- THERE'S ONE OF THESE
TRAFFIC SAFETY ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
MATTER FACT. I BELIEVE IN THE
MEMBERS WE SUGGESTED WE ALSO
GOT SOME ADDITIONAL WORDING IN
THERE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY SAFE WITH REGARD TO
RIGHT OF WAY AND TRAFFIC AND
ALL THAT OKAY WELL I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I UNDERSTAND THERE MAY
HAVE BEEN SOME AMENDMENTS OR
LANGUAGE PROPOSED BY ACWA
SOUGHT PRE SHEET IF YOU WOULD
YEAH LET THAT THEY SENT. TO US
YESTERDAY YEAH WE HAVE BEEN. WE
CONTACT THEM WITH SAME TIME WE
DID THE LEAGUE OF CITIES IN THE
WORLD COUNTY THEY'VE NEVER
AGREED TO MEET WITH US WE'VE
ASKED THEM. YESTERDAY THEY
THREW A BUNCH OF AMENDMENTS
THAT IS FRANKLY THAT'S NOT
SERIOUS. IF THEY'RE SERIOUS
COME AND TALK TO US THERE'S
TIME BETWEEN NOW AND WHEN IT
GOES TO THE SENATE FLOOR. OKAY
WONDERFUL THANK YOU YES AND THE
LAST ISSUE- I BROUGHT THIS UP
ON WITH OTHER BILLS- AND THAT
IS THE- THE ISSUE OF EQUITY-
MANY TIMES THESE BILLS-
INCLUDING YOURS MAKE REFERENCE
TO- COMMUNITIES OUT IN
CALIFORNIA THAT. JUST HAVE BEEN
LEFT OUT ON MEANT. YOU KNOW
HAVE NOT BEEN AT PAR WITH OTHER
COMMUNITIES AS FAR AS
ACCESSIBILITY- AND RELIABILITY
ON THIS WAS OF COURSE- BROUGHT
UP EVEN MORE DURING THE
PANDEMIC- WHICH AFFECTED THEIR
LEARNING. OF OUR CHILDREN SO.
IT KEEPS COMING UP BUT THERE
IS- NOT ALWAYS IS THERE AN
EXLICIT REFERENCE ON HOW WE'RE
GOING TO ADDRESS- OR HOW THIS.
IN FOR EXAMPLE IN THIS BILL
THAT IT WOULD ADDRESS THE DID
DIGITAL DIVIDE FOR THE MOST
UNDERSERVED SELF COULD YOU
ADDRESS THAT BECAUSE AGAIN.
THIS ISN'T THE FIRST TIME YOU
KNOW I'VE ASKED ABOUT THIS
QUESTION OF DONE IT ON OTHER
BILLS AND THE AUTHORS HAVE-
THEN TURNED AROUND AND MADE AN
EFFORT TO BE MORE EXPLICIT SO
SHALL WE HAVE A TELEVISION
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE AVENUE. ON
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE RIGHT NOW.
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET. ARM IT'S FOUR BILLION
FOR WHAT THEY CALL MIDDLE MILE
WHICH WOULD BE PREDOMINANTLY
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE OUT TO
THE RURAL AREAS VETS. HAVE
PROBLEM IN THE CITY'S FANS TO
BE. THERE IS A SIGNAL IT'S JUST
TOO EXPENSIVE. AND FOR THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT LIFELINE FOR
YOUR CELL PHONE ONCE YOU HAVE
YOUR CELL PHONE ON A LIFELINE
YOU CAN THEN ATTACH A
CONTRIBUTOR SO WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE IN THE URBAN
AREAS THAT'S THE LIFELINE IS
THERE. I'VE ALSO WORKED IN THE
PAST AS WE NEEDED MORE AND
MORE- THE CONNECTION FOR
STUDENTS DURING THIS LAST YEAR
AND A HALF. TO GET HOT SPOTS
SET UP BY A. T. AND T. COMCAST
AT CETERA SO- WE NEED TO. WE
HAVE A FAILED TO DO THIS IS
CELIA. ARE IN THE- CECILIA
AGUILAR CURRY IS THE AUTHOR IN
THE ASSEMBLY. LENA GONZALEZ IS
THE AUTHOR IN THE SENATE- THESE
WILL ADDRESS THE DIGITAL BOUGHT
DIVIDE BY GETTING- BOTH. OUT TO
THE RURAL AREAS WHERE THERE MAY
BE NO INTERNET AT ALL AND THEN
ALSO IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
AREAS WHERE YOU'VE GOT FIVE
FAMILIES TO OUR- TO OUR HOUSE.
AND THE BUDGETS ARE LOW AND
THEY NEED THAT LIFELINE RATE.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON IN
THOSE BILLS AND- FOUGHT OVER IT
MEETING TODAY AND MATTER OF
FACT AT ONE O'CLOCK WITH THE
GOVERNOR. OF GOVERNOR'S OFFICE-
TO WORK OUT FURTHER DETAILS ON
THIS SO IT'S ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE. WELL I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE IT- TO LOOK AND SEE
IF THERE'S- LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
BE EXPLICIT ABOUT IT- BUT MORE
POORLY IF YOU WOULD CONTINUE TO
RAISE THIS BECAUSE- THERE'S A
LOT OF PIECES I KNOW TO THE
BROADBAND DISCUSSION. ON THIS
FUNDING INVOLVED IS A LOT OF
PIECES BUT SOMEHOW THE
SERIOUSNESS TO ADDRESS THE
INEQUITIES IS NOT THERE AND
THERE'S A LOT OF FLUFF
LANGUAGE. LEFT LANGUAGE DOESN'T
HELP OUR COMMUNITY SO I'M JUST
RAISING IT TO YOU AND I ARE NAY
SHAKE YOU TAKING US SURE WE
HARD LINE ON IT YEAH WE HAVE A
SUMMARY OF WHERE THE ASSEMBLY
POSITIONS ARE RIGHT NOW. AND
I'LL HAVE MY STAFF SEND IT TO
YOUR STAFF AND YOU CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE DOING THAT'S
THE VEHICLE FOR ADDRESSING THIS
THROUGH THE BUDGET THROUGH THAT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. AND
THROUGH WORKING THIS THE SYSTEM
FRANKLY. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SENATOR
AND THANK YOU SOME NUMBER-
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT IS A
ADDITIONAL. OR HE HEARING TINA
THERE A MOTION TO APPROVE. SO
WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
DRAWS ON THE FLOOR. FINAL CALL
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS. HEARING
TINA FROM COMMITTEE SUPPORT
PROJECT CLOSE PLEASE ARM ARE
WELL I WANT TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I REALLY APPRECIATE. YOUR
COMMENTS WE SPENT AN HOUR
DISCUSSING THIS YESTERDAY WERE
MEETING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TODAY WE TAKE THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY BOTH SATURDAY
GONZALEZ AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER ID
ARE VERY. AND WE AIM TO DO
SOMETHING WE WANT 98% OF EVERY
COUNTY IN THIS STATE TO BE
SERVED BY INTERNET WE WANT
LIFELINE RATES FOR PEOPLE WHO
CANNOT AFFORD INTERNET SERVICE
OTHERWISE. THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER
ALL RIGHTS WITH A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY SENATOR REID SO.
HEARING SEEN NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS WERE GOING TO GO TO
MISTER NOW WHO'S GOING TO CALL
THE MOTION AND THEN CALL THE
VOTE. THE MOTION IS PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
AYE MCGUIRE AYE SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE SENATOR
DORADO. DORADO A SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR SKINNER
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA GET THAT BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
THANK YOU ARE HERE THANK YOU
MASON GENERAL COMMITTEE WOULD
LIKE TO BE A TO GO OVER NEXT
ORDER SO HERE'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE DOING BECAUSE- WE
KNOW OF SOME FOLKS HAVE SOME.
CONSTRAINTS ARE GONNA GO TO A
SIMILAR VIRTUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON WHO WAS HERE EARLIER-
AND THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER PERKS
SILVA SO WE'RE GONNA WORK
THROUGH THESE IN JUST REALLY
GRATEFUL- TO- CHIU MR CHIU
GRAYSON IS QUICK SILVA- FOR
THEIR PATIENTS AND DO APOLOGIZE
IS A MEMBER CHU AT FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE ON A BEFORE ANYONE
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SIX. ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THAT WE'VE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
DECEMBER CHIU ON A VARIETY OF
ISSUES- AND GRATEFUL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP SIR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS ON ALL ISSUES OF AB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I APPRECIATE OUR
OUR COLLEAGUES OF PATIENTS
TODAY KNOW THAT WE'VE GOT A LOT
OF THINGS GOING ON. LET ME
FIRST START BY THANKING THE
CHEERING YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
OR YOUR IMPRTANT AND
SIGNIFICANT WORK ON THIS BILL-
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO STREAMLINE. USE
POLICY REPORTING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CLARIFY THAT
MILITARY EQUIPMENT DOES NOT
INCLUDE GENERAL COMMENT THAT'S
NOT PROHIBITED BY THE DEFENSE
LOGISTICS AGENCY. THIS BILL
WOULD ESTABLISH TRANSPARENCY
BETWEEN LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN
THEIR POLICE DEPARTMENTS
REGARDING USE OF MILITARY
EQUIPMENT AS A FORMER
PROSECUTOR I KNOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN OUR STATE OUR
OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY. BUT IN A POST
GEORGE FORD WORLD WE DO NEED TO
CONSIDER HOW EQUIPMENT AND
TACTICS IMPACT THEIR
PARTNERSHIP. OUR STATE IS LED
THE NATION IN THE AMOUNT OF
MILITARY WEAPONRY OUR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS PROCURED TO THE
TUNE OF HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. AND STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
A SIGNIFICANT LINK BETWEEN THE
LEVEL OF SURPLUS MILITARY
EQUIPMENT AND WEAPONS OBTAINED
BY POLICE DEPARTMENT AND THE
NUMBER OF POLICE SHOOTINGS.
THIS PAST YEAR OUR STATE SAW AN
ALARMING RANGE OF EQUIPMENT IN
ACTION DURING PEACEFUL PROTESTS
WHEN POLICE SPRAY TEAR. GAS
FROM MILITARY GRENADE LAUNCHER
IS AND SHOT ROBERT. FROM
VEHICLES. THE DECISION OF HOW
TO. THE SENSE OF EQUIPMENT.
WERE LEFT UP TO IN. OFFICERS AT
THE SCENE WITHOUT UNIFORM
PROTOCOLS. THIS BILL ASKED
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO WORK
WITH THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
GOVERNING BOARDS TO COME UP
WITH APPROPRIATE MILITARY
EQUIPMENT USE POLICIES THAT CAN
BE DELIBERATED AND APPROVED IN
PUBLIC SETTINGS. THE PUBLIC HAS
A RIGHT TO KNOW WHEN AND WHY
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT BELIEVE
THEY NEED MILITARY CALIBER
EQUIPMENT ESPECIALLY WHEN
PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE AT STAKE IN
AT THIS TIME I LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER. TO OUR WITNESSES THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER CHU SO
LACING GENTLEMEN HEARING
COMMITTEE- AND- WATCHING ONLINE
WE HAVE TO LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES WHO WOULD BE PROVIDED
TWO MINUTES EACH AT FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE'RE GONNA GO TO
BRIANNA SO I FULLER- AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA TURN THE FLOOR OVER
TO CASEY SHORT. THAT WE WELCOME
BRIANNA TO COMMITTEE AT YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES MA'AM THANK
YOU SO MUCH TWO MINUTES IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR EIGHTY ONE.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CHAIRED
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO FOR INVITING
ME HERE TODAY. MY NAME IS
BRANDON PLACE WHERE I AM AN
ATTORNEY WITH FIVE NOBODY ELSE
YOU KNOW. AND I AM HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF WOMEN'S FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA. THE CROWD
COSPONSORED ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
EIGHT ONE. CALIFORNIA POLICE
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN MILITARIZING
FOR DECADES WITH LITTLE TO NO
OVERSIGHT. THROUGH ONE PROGRAM
THE TEN THIRTY THREE PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA POLICE HAVE REQUIRED
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS SURPLUS
MILITARY EQUIPMENT. INCLUDING
MINE RESISTANT AMBUSH PROTECTED
VEHICLES. UNMANNED GROUND
VEHICLES ASSAULT RIFLES AND
NIGHT VISION SNIPER SCOPE.
OTHER FEDERAL PROGRAMS THAT
REQUIRE ANY REPORTING BUT A
CATALOG LIST EVERYTHING FROM
ARMORED VEHICLES TO NIGHT
VISION GOGGLES. ALL THIS ALL
THIS EQUIPMENT BEG THE QUESTION
WHO IS THE ENEMY POLICE ARE
TRYING TO COMBAT. A TWENTY
EIGHTEEN STUDY FOUND
MILITARIZED POLICE FORCES WERE
MOST OFTEN DEPLOYED IN BLACK
COMMUNITIES EVEN AFTER
CONTROLLING FOR CRIME RATES.
AND SEVERAL STUDIES FOUND
SIGNIFICANT CORRELATION BETWEEN
INCREASED POLICE MILITARIZATION
AND INCREASED POLICE KILLING.
FOR ALL OF THAT HARM THERE IS
NO BENEFIT. STUDY SHOWED POLICE
MILITARIZATION FAILED TO REDUCE
CRIME SALES TO ENHANCE OFFICER
SAFETY AND FAILED TO SUPPORT A
PUBLIC TRUST IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS BILL PREVENTING EASY SEX
POLICE AGENCIES ALREADY REPORT
INFORMATION ABOUT PLANNED
PURCHASES DURING THE ANNUAL
BUDGET REVIEW PROCESS. THIS
BILL SIMPLY REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
DETAIL ABOUT THE EQUIPMENT
FOUGHT FOR THE USE POLICY
BEFORE POLICE CAN BRING IN THE
MOST EXTREME WAR LIKE EQUIPMENT
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES. THIS IS A
MINIMAL ASK OUR PUBLIC
SERVANTS. PLEASE MAKE CLEAN THE
NEED DISAPPOINTMENT WE ARE JUST
SAYING THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND THE PUBLIC SHOULD HAVE A
VOICE. AB FOUR EIGHT ONE IS A
COMMON SENSE SOLUTION TO
ADVANCE RACIAL JUSTICE REDUCE
POLICE VIOLENCE AND INSERT
BASIC TRANSPARENCY MEASURES.
ALL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
INCLUDING THOSE HEADED BY
ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE SUBJECT
TO OVERSIGHT THIS BASIC
PRINCIPLE OF GOVERNMENT MUST BE
IMPLEMENTED WITH REGARD TO A
QUICK MEANT ORIGINALLY MEANT
ABOUT PEDOPHILES THIRTY SECONDS
EVERY SEXUALLY ARE YOUR EYES
OUT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HIM THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY APPRECIATE PLACING
CHEN ON THE COMMITTEE WERE NOT
TO BE GOING TO CASEY SHORT
CASEY SHORT HAS TWO MINUTES TO
BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB. FOUR EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CASEY. THANK YOU- TODAY
INTRODUCED YOU GUYS AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE EVERYONE. HI
MY NAME IS KATIE SHORT I AM THE
FOUNDER OF BEATING UNITED CAN
BE A GIRL. AND I'M ALSO A
TWELVE YEAR. VETERAN I DEPLOYED
TO AFGHANISTAN IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE. TO TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. AND I UNDERSTAND
HEART AND MIND IT ALSO WON'T
NEED TO WORK ON TO GET.
AFFECTED BE PASSED FOR EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHT ONE. AND REQUIRING
THING THIS IS BECAUSE I ALSO BE
PROTECT AND I'M IN THE STREETS
WITH THE PEOPLE I AM A
COMMUNITY MEMBER. I AM A BLACK
MALE- I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
USING MILITARY WEAPONS
AUTOCOCKERS DON'T WANT MENTAL.
ABILITY YOU COULD BE IN
QUESTION BECAUSE LIKE THEY'RE
ALREADY THE ENEMY. WHO A POLICE
REPORT. SO IN ORDER TO CREATE
CHANGE TO CRUELLY CREATE
CHANGE. I'D SAY GIVE YOU TO
PLEASE PAT. AB FOUR EIGHT ONE
IN ORDER TO CREATE A GAP
BETWEEN THE PEOPLE. AND THE
POLICE. IF YOU WERE OUT OUTSIDE
TO ASK PEOPLE TO DATE THEY DO
NOT BELIEVE IN THE POLICE
REPORT AT ALL. AND WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT POLICE ARE OFF TO
TREAT AGGRESSIVE TOWARD.
PROTESTERS IN GENERAL. THE
PASSING A BIG BILL WOULD BE
ABLE TO CREATE THAT GREAT. THAT
WE NEED FOR YOU NEED. TO MOVE
FORWARD AND THEIR PUBLIC
APOCALYPTIC. AT THAT HAPPENED
TO MISTER GEORGE BLAKE BLIND.
YOU AT THE AMERICAN VETERAN TO
TAKE HIS BILL. THANK YOU TO THE
NEXT. SO THAT WHEN ARE ABLE TO
CREATE CHANGE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR KIND OF THE WAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH IT'S A SHORT WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY. FACING GENERAL COMMITTEE
THAT WRAPS UP OUR RIGHT TO LEAD
TO SUPPORT WITNESSES. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS. THAT WE
WELCOME MISTER COREY SAYS HELLO
TO COMMITTEE. COREY REPRESENTS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. IT'S A SUBZERO
WELCOME THE COMMITTEE'S HERE
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES I'LL. GIVE
YOU THIRTY SECOND PROMPT PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER.
REYES CHORUS ALONG BEHALF OF A-
STATE SHERIFFS IS- ORDER AND
I'LL- TO THE BEACH. IN AS A
PRACTICAL THE ARE. OF MILITARY
SURPLUS. AUCTION REQUIRES TO
RISK QUICK. WITHOUT THE- TO
ENGAGE. BODY RIG. PURCHASE EVEN
IF THE BILL UP. ONLY TO THE
FIRST TIME AGENCY SEEKS. TO
ACQUIRE CERTAIN EQUIPMENT. AB
FORTY ONE WOULD STILL SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGE CALIFORNIA
AGENCIES. IN THEIR ATTEMPT TO
PARTICIPATION. ADDITIONALLY AB
FORTY ONE A FIGURE INTERFERES
WITH THE ABILITY OF INDEPENDENT
ELECTED CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS
TO ACQUIRE EQUIPMENT AT A COST
SAVINGS. FOR DEPLOYMENT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES. TO
ELECTED SHERIFFS ARE CERTAINLY
CAPABLE OF RESPONDING TO THE
CONCERNS OF THEIR CONSTITUENTS
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PURCHASING
AND DEPLOYMENT. OF APPROPRIATE
EQUIPMENT SHOULD THEY ARISE AND
JUST AS A REMINDER IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTION ABOUT OVERSIGHT.
ASIDE FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
STATE AND FEDERAL COURTS BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND OTHER
ENTITIES INCLUDING THE COUNTY
GRAND JURY SURE STAND FOR
ELECTION. IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
EVERY FOUR YEARS. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED
SB THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE A
SIMILAR BILL. THAT DID NOT GO
SO FAR AS TO REQUIRE GOVERNING
BODY APPROVAL FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF MILITARY
EQUIPMENT. IN HIS VETO MESSAGE
ON THAT BILL. HE STATED THE
CURRENT LIST NOT ONLY INCLUDES
ITEMS ARE CLEARLY MILITARISTIC
AND STYLE BUT MANY THAT ARE
COMMONLY USED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND DO NOT MERIT
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO THEIR
ACQUISITION. MY VIEW THIS BILL
CREATES UNNECESSARY
BUREAUCRATIC HURDLE WITHOUT
COMMENSURATE PUBLIC OWNERSHIP
AND I CANNOT FIND. WE
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO NARROW
THE SCOPE OF THE EQUIPMENT
THAT'S AFFECTED BY THIS BILL-
BUT FOR THE REASONS WE ARE
NOTIZIE SMS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSING BEFORE ANYONE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND SO. CREATIVE AND SHE
YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE ARE NOW
GOING TO OPEN IT UP TO ANY
INDIVIDUAL WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL HERE IN COMMITTEE
NOW. IF YOU ARE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY
ONE IN ROOM. THIRTY ONE ANYONE
CAN YOU PLEASE PROCEED TO THE
PODIUM. SEEMS NO ONE RIGHT. AT
WE ARE NOW. HANG ON LET ME
ANSWER THAT PHONE- WE ARE NOW
GOING TO BE GOING TO THOSE
PHONE LINES- AND WE'RE GOING TO
CHECK IN WITH OUR MODERATOR
MADAME MODERATOR IF WE CAN AT
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOR ANYONE.
CAN WE PLEASE DO SO NOW. THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK AT THE PORT OF AB
FOUR EIGHT ONE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO APPETITE. THE
RECURRENTLY HAVE NINE IN Q.
WILL START WITH LINE TWO OH
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO OR
THREE YOUR LINE IS NEEDED
RIGHT. TO A THREE- BUT I WANTED
TO SPEAK ON FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
ALL RIGHT NOW. AND I'M OPPOSE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH ME
APOLOGIZE ABOUT THAT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND THAT WE
APOLOGIZE ABOUT THE MIX UP.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY
ONE NOW. TO OH ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ELLIE- I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE WOMAN POLICIES AND THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION- BOTH
STRONG SUPPORTER OF. BOTH-
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND I BEFORE
AN ALSO HOW LIST OF-
ORGANIZATIONS ARE IN- THEY ARE-
READ NOBODY KNEW LAW TAKE YOUR
JACKET. BEING INITIATE JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED THE ANSWER.
START OVER. ELEVATOR AND I
CALIFORNIANS UP INTERESTED
YOUTH ALIVE- ARE LOOKING TO
BAKER HE AND HE TALKING- PUBLIC
GOOD LOS COUNTY ON AMERICAN THE-
IN AMERICA JUSTICE REFORM THE
W. K. FIVE TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WE WILL AND WE FOUND A LINE FOR
THE MEDICAL. ASIAN AND
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA-
WARM WINTER. AND WE THOUGHT-
I'M CENTER. SO GREAT ALLIANCE
THE FRENCH COMMITTEE I JUST.
AND- WE THE PEOPLE BE ABLE OF
THE COMMUNE AND YOU MUCH HOW.
THANK YOU ARE VERY GRATEFUL
WE'RE GONNA MISTER REPEAT THAT
LAYS- AND HE COMES BACK SO- DO
GIVEN TIME YOU SO ELLIE WE YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY THANK YOU
FOR IN. THE AT TO NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. SURE MEMBERS WITH THEIR
PARENTS WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FORTY ONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER TURN NUMBER OF THE
ESCALATE THE SHOT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE
CALL LET'S GO TO THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ERIC MARTIN
CALLING ON BEHALF OF POSSIBLY
CAN BE ALIGNED PUBLIC BECAUSE
WE ARE COSPONSORED AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR EIGHT ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT SORRY ABOUT
SEVEN TIMES SIR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR OF PHONE CALL. LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. TWO OH NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MICHAEL RATTIGAN TO BE
AFTER THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU READ AGAIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH SIR LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TO ALLOW
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS JOHN LINDSAY POLAND ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN FRIENDS
SERVICE COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OF
THE OVERSIGHT AND COMMUNITY
TRANSPARENCY ASPECTS OF AB
FORTY ONE THANK YOU THANKS
JOHN. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND BEFORE WE
OPEN NINE TO TWELVE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR EIGHT ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO. ONE TO TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU
ON YOUR CALL. EIGHT BILLION
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN FOUR EIGHT
EIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT ONE PLEASE.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE ON THEIR
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT NOT A
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
IN JUST A MOMENT WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE LOOKING TO THOSE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSED TO IT BEFORE
ANYONE WE'RE GONNA START HERE
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO FORTY ONE CAN
YOU PLEASE STAND AND MAKE YOUR
WAY TO THE PODIUM NOW. SEE NO
ONE STANDING. WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO THE MODERATOR MADAM
MODERATOR WE'RE COMING BACK
QUICK SO. WE'RE GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO YOU YOU. PLEASE
QUEUE UP ALL INDIVIDUALS. WHO
MAY BE. OPPOSED TO AB FORTY ONE
NOW. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO DERAIL AFTER TIME.
AND WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q. THEIR
CURRENT WEAPON OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE I'M GOOD WHAT
REMIND FOLKS IF YOU'D LIKE TO
BE TO PARTICIPATE VIA THE LIVE
TELECONFERENCE TODAY ON ANY
BALLOTS ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE'S AGENDA
PLEASE DIAL EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
468-189-8772 TWO SIX EIGHT ONE
EIGHT NINE I'M NOT A MODERATOR
THAT'S I HEAD BACK TO YOU. AND
THANK YOU ONE ONE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEMBERS WHO
ENDED UP ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CALLING IN TODAY WE
APPRECIATE THE PHONE CALL LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE SHOULD KOW WHEN I PULLED
INTO THE AUTHOR. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE I'D
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS AND AS A MEMBER CHORE
JUST WANNA CONFIRM BY TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS AS WELL SIR.
CORRECT YES AS I SAID IN MY
PSYCHOLOGY THAT'S MY SHEET ARE
ENGAGEMENT ON THAT THAT'S MY
DAD I APOLOGIZE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE. AND
OR- MOTION. MOVED WE HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER ADDRESSES
ADDRESS I DOING TODAY. RIGHT
ALL RIGHT IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
HEY DON'T HE'S DOING GOOD
DIDN'T SLEEP VERY WELL LAST
NIGHT THOUGH LET ME TELL YOU.
THAT'S VERY. MY GOODNESS- WERE
THREE. TO THREE HALF OF THE AT
HOME SO- IT'S GOOD TIMES. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT
IT'S A NUMBER TWO- YOU HAVE NO.
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THERE IS A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
BY CENTER DRIVE SO. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS TO BE A CLOSE. I JUST
AGAIN APPRECIATE ENGAGEMENT AND
THIS IS A BILL ABOUT BUILDING
TRUST BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY CENTER
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER ALL
RIGHT MOTION THE FOR MY CENTER
DRAWS OF. MR NOW CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE MOTION AND THEN CALL
THE VOTE. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR MCGUIRE
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO SENATOR
DORADO. DORADO SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR SKINNER. TWO
ONE THAT IS EIGHT TO ONE VOTE
AT WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THAT
THEY'LL OPEN AND ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS TO BE ABLE TO ADD
ON THAT WE'RE GOING TO NOW
BRING FORTY SO MEMBER GRAYSON I
WANT TO APOLOGIZE FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS A MEMBER GRAYSON
FOR HAVING TO WAIT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS A MEMBER OUT FOR YOUR
PATIENCE YOUR TODAY THE SOMEONE
NEVER ACTUALLY HAS IT IS LIKE
COULD BE- SOME NUMBER GRAYSON
SHOW HERE SENATOR ALSO HE HAS
THREE BILLS IN FRONT OF US
TODAY- TO OUR CONTENT AND NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR. WE DO HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS
THIS SUMMER GRAYSON AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR IS RECEIVING
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SO IF IT'S
OKAY WITH YOU WE'RE GONNA ASK
FOR A TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
STATEMENT THE FLOOR IS YOURS
STERN AS ALWAYS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND NO
APOLOGIES NEEDED AND TO THE
SENATORS OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AB ELEVEN SEVEN FOUR WILL- PAUL
FIGHT HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS EFFECTIVELY
STREAMLINED HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
AS INTENDED UNDER CURRENT LAW
IT WILL CLARIFY THREE YOUR SHOT
CLOCK FOR DEVELOPMENT
MODIFICATIONS APPROVAL IS
PAUSED WHEN THE CITY SUES IT
SPECIFIES THAT A PROJECT MUST
ONLY COMPLY WITH OBJECTIVE
STANDARDS THAT WERE IN PLACE
WHEN THE PROJECT WAS INITIALLY
APPROVED AND IT SPECIFIES THE
CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITY ON SITE
MUST HAVE BEEN GONE FOR A
PROJECT APPROVAL TO REMAIN
VALID WITH THAT I DO HAVE A
WITNESS THAT I WAS ASKED TO BE
VERY BRIEF- MISTER MICHAEL LANG
FROM SUPPORT. THAT'S RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
GRAYSON AYE MR LANE IS VERY
POPULAR HERE IN COMMITTEE INTO
PRE SHE DOES PARTICIPATION OVER
THESE PAST MANY WEEKS LET'S GO
TO MISTER LANE MISTER LANE DO
ONE REMIND YOU YOU'RE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR A
TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
STATEMENT IT'S REALLY REPRESENT
SPURRED. THE FLOORS YOU'RE
CERTAINLY WELCOME TO COMMITTEE.
ABSOLUTELY YOU MISTER. COME
WORDS. TO MEMBERS MICHAEL AND
THE TEMPS. PLAN URBAN. SO
PUBLIC POWER THANK TANK KNOWN
AS- SB FIVE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS BOON TO
THE PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THE STREAMLINED
APPROVALS AB HELPED TO BRING
MANY NEW HOMES ONLINE WORK
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY.
HOWEVER AS WITH ALL MAJOR
LANDMARK LEGISLATION THERE IS A
NEED FOR CLARIFICATION THE
TECHNICAL THING UP. TO
IMPLEMENT THE LAW AN ADVANCE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE. THE
CLARIFICATION IN AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR ONE SURE THAT HOW
YOU APPROVAL STREAMLINING
FUNCTIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE
INTENDED. AND WE URGE MICHAEL
THANK OU VERY MUCH OKAY THAT
MISTER LANE IS COMING IN I LIKE
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MICHAEL. GOOD TO HEAR YOUR
VOICE THAT LAYS IN GERMAN OF
COMMITTEE. WE TYPICALLY WOULD
GO TO OUR LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS BUT WE DO NOT HAVE ONE
ON RECORD HERE TODAY. SO WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO IS THAT WE
ARE GOING TO NOW. TURN IT OVER
TO ANY INDIVIDUAL HERE IN ROM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. AT TO BE
ABLE TO STAND AND IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF. AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
STAND NOW. C. KNOWN STAND NOT
GOING TO GO TO OUR TELL. LINE
THAT WE'RE GONNA CHECK WITH THE
MOD. MATT MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO WOULD LIKE TO. SPEAK AT AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR NOW. I'D BE
GLAD TO THEIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OF THE COURT OF AB ELEVEN FIFTY
FOUR. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
AT THE TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE THREE IN Q. LIKE ONE
THIRTY THREE WE'LL START WITH
YOU YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH CAN
YOU IMAGINE TRYING MEMBERS THIS
IS THE ONLY AFRICAN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH IS COVERED PRETTY ****
THAT THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE NINE IN ATLANTA PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF.
DANIEL PROPERTIES CALIFORNIA
YIMBY AND BECAUSE BAY AREA
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION AND A GREENBELT
ALLIANCE ALLEN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU LOOK AT THAT COMING
IN STRONG SHAPE THAT THAT'S GOT
OUR NEXT CALLER. WHY DO
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALLEN CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
DAIRY SIMPLE AND AS A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. ONE ONE
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT OFTEN NOT A BACKPACK ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF AB. ONE
ONE SEVEN FOUR THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
TO NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
KIMBERLY DOWN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION INC THE COURT THE
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY THAT'S
GOT A NICE COLOR. TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ALL. GERMAN.
PLEASE PROCEED MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'M SORRY THIS. IS BOB NAYLOR I
HAD THE MUTE MY- THE TV- I REP.
HILLS DOESN'T AND ARE IN THIS
SO OF THE B. ELEVEN FOUR THANKS
MUCH BOB THE FOR CALL TODAY GO
TO OUR NEXT CALL. MY TWENTY ONE
YEAR LIGHTED OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS ARE NOT
ON COOPER YOU BURKE FROM HACKER
THE COLOR. CALIFORNIA AND-
ADDITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR FEEDBACK PRETTY THAT THAT'S
GOING TOWARD CALLER. AND THAT
WAS OUR FINAL PERSON IT'S PORT
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
MODERATOR WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
CHECKING IN WITH THOSE WHO MAY
BE IN. OPPOSITION THE BILL
WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME YOU TO
THE PODIUM IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TURN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. SCENE NO ONE CHARGE
DIPODIUM WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
GOING TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN WITH
THE MODERATOR NOT A MODERATOR
HERE WE GO LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
PLEASE. QUEUE UP FOLKS NOW.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. ALL RIGHT
WHEN THERE'S NO ONE. SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR OKAY THAT ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH AND A
MODERATOR APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR- CONCERNS
BY COMMITTEE. OKAY THAT. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
MISTER VICE CHAIR- GOEBEL DOGS
MY RIGHT. HEY THERE WE GO
FRESNO STATE- SO WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE WE HAVE A- MOTION BY THE
VICE YOU'RE RIGHT NOW MR
GRAYSON THE FLOOR IS YOURS FOR
YOUR CLOTHES THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER TRYING TO WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON AMENDMENTS I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THOSE AMENDMENTS
TODAY. RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONOMICAL VERY GRATEFUL
MISTER MASON AGAIN YOU WERE
ALWAYS SUCH A GERMAN BEER TO
WORK WITHIN DO APPRECIATE ALL
THE PARTNERSHIP OVER THESE PAST
MANY YEARS WE HAVE A MOTION BY
THE VICE CHAIR- ON THE FLOOR
FOR INTERNET OVER TO MR NOW TO
CALL THE MOTION. IN THE CALL OF
A- THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI MCGUIRE AYE SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN A SENATOR DORADO.
DORADO A SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR SKINNER. THREE DESERT
OKAY THAT WE GOT A THREE ZERO
VOTE THREE ZERO VOTE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THAT ON CALL LADIES
IN GERMAN WHAT MISS QUIRKY
SILVA IS NEXT IN LINE THIS MAY
BE HER ENTERING RIGHT NOW LET'S
CHECK IT OUT. SHE IS HERE. IN
THE NEXT TIME THIS IS ALL ABOUT
TIMING LAYS IN GERMAN. SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GO
THROUGH OUR ORDER HERE
SWEETNESS QUICK SILVA AND THEN
MISTER GRAY- IN I AND THEN
MISTER WARD IS HERE AS WELL AND
THEN MR FRAZIER ALRIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH AGAIN I APOLOGIZE.
THANK YOU- AND WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS IN THE
FOR THEIR PATIENTS ARE GONNA GO
MISS CLARK SILVA AND WE'RE
GONNA GO TO MISTER BRING. THIS
WORKS ABOUT WELCOME- YOU SHE-
IS CAN BE PRESENTING ON ALL
ISSUES OF AB TEN SEVENTEEN. AND
I JUST WANT TO SAY HANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS WITH US.
TRULY GRATEFUL FOR THAT WANT TO
CONFIRM THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
TAKING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TODAY YES OF COURSE AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR- TEAM AND YOUR
SUPPORT. OF GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TO PRESENT AB
TEN SEVENTEEN. PUBLIC RESTROOMS
RIGHT TO RESTROOMS AT. I THE
TOPIC THAT WE ALL- DON'T TO
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT AND YET IT'S
SOMETHING WE DO ALL EVERY DAY
AND FOR MANY OF US MANY TIMES
AND WE DON'T HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT IT IN THE BUILDING WE
AT OUR HOMES WE JUST GO. RIGHT
USING OUR RESTROOMS IT NOT ONLY
FOR HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS BUT
FOR PARENTS WITH TODDLERS AND
CHILDREN WITH SENIORS BEING
ABLE TO GO OUT INTO A PUBLIC
PLACE AND COUNT ON A BATHROOM
THAT IS NOT ONLY OPEN BUT THAT
IS. USABLE AND CLEAN IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE SEEING
LESS AND LESS OF PARTICULARLY
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AS WE KNOW
RETAIL HAS BEEN LIMITED MANY
MANY TIMES WE SEE BATHROOMS ARE
ONLY FOR CUSTOMERS WE SEE OUR
FAST FOOD PLACES ARE THAT HAVE
BEEN CLOSED- AND SO AS WE THINK
ABOUT IT. THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
QUESTIONS WALK IN SOMEONE
ELSE'S SHOES AND CERTAINLY
AROUND THE CAPITAL ALL WE HAVE
TO DO IS LOOK AROUND AND SEE
THAT BECAUSE THIS BUILDING HAS
BEEN CLOSED FOR WELL OVER. A
YEAR TO THE PUBLIC- WE SEE MANY
MANY INDIVIDUALS ON THE
OUTSKIRTS OF THIS BUILDING UP
WITH NO PLACE TO USE A PUBLIC
RESTAURANT ROOM SO THAT'S WHERE
THIS BILL. IS ORIGINATED OUT OF
THE IDEA THAT NOT JUST HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS BUT SENIORS AND
PARENTS. WE AS A PUBLIC SHOULD
BE ALLOWING PUBLIC RESTROOMS TO
BE OPEN AND THIS WILL CERTAINLY
ARE ASKED FOR AN INVENTORY OF
RESTROOMS- THAT ARE. IN CITIES
AND CHARTER CITIES AND COUNTIES
WE ELIMINATED THE STATE OF FROM
THIS THAT BUT TO WE ARE HOPING
THIS MESSAGE CAN BE SENT. TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT NOT
ONLY DO WE WANT TO KNOW. IF YOU
HAVE PUBLIC RESTROOMS BUT HOW
OFTEN ARE THEY OPEN BECAUSE
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE ONE BUT IF
IT'S LOCKED. NOT THAT HELPFUL
SO WITH THAT WE DO HAVE ONE
WITNESS HERE AND TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT THIS IS- LOS WATKINS.
HUMAN RIGHTS ORGANIZATION.
ORGANIZER FROM THE COALITION ON
HOMELESS FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY ONE
AT COURSE OF- IN AGAIN REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
AND I AND I THINK THE WAY THAT
YOU JUST PRESENTED ABOUT HOW WE
TAKE FOR GRANTED ALL THAT
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT- IN THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE FACED BY
THOSE HOMELESS. ON THE STREETS
EACH AND EVERY DAY SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH. SO LET'S GO TO MISTER
WATKINS REPRESENT A COALITION
HOMELESS MR WALKEN'S YOU WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE
YOU THIRTY SECOND PROMPT WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS MY NAME
IS CARLOS WATKINS- I'M COMING
UP WOMAN STATED I MEAN
RECOGNIZED WITH THE COALITION
ON HOMELESSNESS IN SAN
FRANCISCO- AND I'M CALLING IN
TODAY TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR A
BI. AND SEVENTEEN- IN TWENTY
TWELVE CALIFORNIA BECAME THE
FIRST DAY IN THE NATION TO
LEGALLY RECOGNIZE THE HUMAN
RIGHT TO WATER. WHEN GOVERNOR
BROWN SIGNED HIM THE BILL OF
SIX EIGHTY FIVE. OTHER RESULT
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT WATER CODE
SECTION ONE OF SIX POINT THREE.
THE STATE BANK CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZES THAT EVERY HUMAN
BEING RIGHT BASED. GREEN
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
WATER. ADEQUATE FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION COOKING INSANITARY
PURPOSES- YEAH AS THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
STABLE HOUSING HAD CONTINUED TO
INCREASE OF THE NINE YEARS AND-
FINING OF THAT BILL. I'M SO TOO
HAS THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WHO
FALL FAR BELOW THAT STANDARD OF
HAVING ACCESS. A CLEAN AND
AFFORDABLE WATER. SANITATION.
HYGIENE FACILITIES. IN SAN
FRANCISCO- I SEE FIRSTHAND
AMERICA THE COALITION ON. HOW
BE DEPRIVED OF THE BASIC. HUMAN
RIGHTS BACK TO ARREST A GREAT
HARMED IN. UNDER MAKE IN THEIR-
ARSENAL HEIDI AND HUMAN DIGNITY.
I JUST CITY WE'VE ALSO SEEN HOW
THE START OF THE GUY. THAT I
EVERY PER. COULD MILLION OF
TOURISTS OR TALIBAN. EVERY YEAR.
FIND THEMSELVES IN NEED OF THE
THESE ALL. A ST. AND INCOMPLETE.
IN THE IT AFFECT THAT THE- AND
THE LACK OF THE STREET. THIS
ISSUE WITH ALL OF US IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IT IS MCCARTY
EFFECTS BOB DONNAN THE OUR MOST
MARGINALIZED. INCLUDING ON HOW
SPOKE. OTHER LEE AND IS ABLE TO
VOTE- AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE THE
IMPACT THE COMEBACK AND BRONCO.
I QUIRK SILVA. ATTENTION FIRST
TO CAL. HONOR THE COMMITMENT
THAT I MADE ON THE DAY. AGO
IT'S RECOGNIZE EVERY HUMAN
BEING RIGHT AT THE- SO THE-
MEMBERS OF THE- ON AGREEMENT.
COMMITMENT AND THEY HAVE TO FOR
A AND- IN ORDER TO. HOW FAR WE
ARE THIS. I'M INTO IT EVERY CAL.
HAS TO BASIC YOU'RE EVER
RESTAURANT. WHAT STEPS WE NEED
TO. TRANSACTION IN THE- REALITY.
WE NEED A THOROUGH TRANSPARENT
THAT GONNA WORK OUT. STAND IN
TERMS OF REACHING THE TAX
STANDARD. AND AFTER THE
ASSEMBLY ABILITY. THANK YOU AND
I AM NOT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
GREAT FOR MISTER WALKEN'S
THINGS FOR CALLING IN. DANGER
YOUR AT. THEY AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE. AT WE DO NOT A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS. ON RECORD
HERE IN COMMITTEE. SO WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE GONNA
TURN IT RIGHT OVER TO ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO THANKED ME TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
SEVENTEEN. HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. TO PLEASE STAND
COME FOR THE PODIUM. SENIOR
ONCE. OUT WE'RE NOT TO BE GOING
TO OUR LIVES. LINE TO BE ABLE
TO CHECK IN WITH OUR MODERATOR
MADAME MODERATOR. CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
SEVENTEEN NOW. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN SEVENTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO ACTIVE
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TEN SEVENTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
SHOW NO ONE SUPPORTING THE
BILL- THANK ALSO DID HAVE ONE
BUT JUST YOU DON'T I'M SORRY
SIR ONE MOMENT PLEASE YOU'RE
GOOD BUT WITH AN OPERATOR. I
JUST WANNA REMIND FOLKS I IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY'S HEARING VIA
OUR TELECONFERENCE NINE. THAT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE EIGHT
NINE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE EIGHT NINE. NOT A
MODERATOR I'LL TURN IT BACK
OVER TO YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE LINE ONE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JAM PACKED
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER INTO COURT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH INTEREST YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY THAT'S A
CHECKING TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
OTHER INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT OF
AB TEN SEVENTEEN MATTER
MODERATOR. AND THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE WANTS SUPPORTER THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE MODERATOR AND
CHECKING TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB TEN
SEVENTEEN HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE IF THERE ARE
FOLKS IN OPPOSITION CAN YOU
PLEASE STAND. SEEN KNOWING
STAND WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO
THAT'S RIGHT TO MINIMUM MINIMUM
WRITER SO WE'RE GONNA GO CHECK
IN WITH MADAME MODERATOR AT A
MODERATOR THAT SEE IF THERE IS
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION AT MAYBE
TEN SEVENTEEN CAN YOU PLEASE.
QUEUE THEM UP NOW. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB CAN
SEVENTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TEN SEVENTEEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE OPPOSED IN THE BILL
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
BEEN A MODERATE WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE I
HAD QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
WE ALSO WILL WELCOME A MOTION.
SIR DRAWS SO MOVED AS
APPROPRIATE- I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR- I REMEMBER
BEING STOPPED IN A- IN THE
STORE BY SOMEONE WHO JUST. YOU
KNOW RIGHT I KNEW WERE SHE KNEW
ME. AN ELDERLY WOMAN. AND THAT
WAS THE SHE PLEADED. WITH ME
COULD WE DO SOMETHING ABOUT
HAVING RESTROOMS AND THAT THIS
WAS IN A COMMERCIAL AREA WITH
YOUR BOULEVARD IN EAST LA. AND
THAT'S ALL SHE COULD JUST TALK
ABOUT WAS THE- THEN HUMANITY OF
NOT BEING ABLE TO HAVE A
RESTROOM AVAILABLE WHEN YOU'RE
OUT SHOPPING. SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE AND- I AGREE WITH
YOU THIS IS A- I DON'T KNOW HOW
IT ENDS UP THAT THINGS LIKE
THIS STILL HURT THE MOST
VULNERABLE THE MOST. OUR
SENIORS OR DISABLED I MEAN WE
REALLY HAVE A LOT MORE TOWARD-
WORK TO DO AND SO I APPRECIATE
THIS AS THE NEXT STEP AND-
WOULD LOVE TO. SUPPORT YOU AND
THE NEXT STEPS OF WHICH IS TO
MAKE RESTROOMS MORE AVAILABLE
NOT JUST KNOW WHERE THEY ARE SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
CENTER DRAWS SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
DRIVE SO ON A. B. TEN SEVENTEEN
AND THIS CREEK SEVEN WOULD YOU
LIKE T CLOSE PLEASE. I WOULD
AND I WOULD JUST SAY AS THE
CHAIR OF THE ART ARTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT COMMITTEE AND
TOURISM THIS IS ALSO AN
IMPORTANT BILL FOR THAT
INDUSTRY AS WE WANT TO WELCOME
BACK. WELL TO OUR STATE TO
VISIT TO VACATION THEY ALSO
WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE. ACCESS
TO CLEAN UP BATHROOMS THAT ARE
OPEN IN OUR AREAS WHERE
TOURISM. SAN FRANCISCO LOS
ANGELES THE BEACH AREA SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MEMBER PERKS OF APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK ON THIS TRULY- WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
DURAZO. I MISTER NOW CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE MOTION AND THEN
CALL THE VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE- IS
SENATOR IELSEN. NIELSEN NO
SENATOR DORADO. JURADO A
SENATOR SKINNER. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THAT IS A CURRENTLY
TO ONE VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THAT THEY'LL OPEN IN THE WILL
GET FOLKS ADDED ON IS THE
COMING THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MEMBER IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
GRATEFUL ALL RIGHT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE'RE NOW MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM SIXTEEN THIS IS AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SIX FOCUSING
ON A PARK THE CITY MODESTO- AND
GALLO SO WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO DO IS TELL MR GREAT
THAT WE DO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON YOUR BILL- IN AB SO
WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR A TRUNCATED
VERSION OF YOUR STATEMENT SIR.
AND I JUST WANNA LET FOLKS KNOW
AS MR GRADY IS ABOUT TO
PROCEED- NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER SO WE'RE GONNA
GO MISTER GRAY MISTER WARD
MISTER FRAZIER MR GREAT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SIX ALLOWS THE
CITY OF MODESTO TO DISPOSE OF
BEARD BROOK PARK- TRANSFERRING
THE OWNERSHIP OF THAT LAND TO A
PRIVATE ENTITY IN EXCHANGE FOR
LAND OF EQUAL OR GREATER VALUE
I APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT- I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY LAURIE SMITH
DIRECTOR OF PARKS AND
RECREATION I THINK IN THE
INTEREST OF A TRUNCATED
PRESENTATION SHE'S AVAILABLE
FOR ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS OF
CENTERS MAY HAVE APPRECIATED BY
PERSON SPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I DON'T FIND IT I THINK
YOU SO MUCH AT MISTER GREAT P.
SHIRT YEAH YOU WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE IS WELL AND I KNOW MR
REYES ALSO BEEN WORKING WITH-
STATE PARK SO THERE'S BEEN. A
LOT OF MOVING PARTS OF THANK
YOU SO MUCH- MISTER GRAY FOR-
YOUR PERSISTENCE ON THIS ISSUE
SO MASON GENTLEMAN WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO THEN IS AT WORK I
GOING TO GO STRAIGHT TO THOSE
WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL- HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE WOULD ACTUALLY TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
SUPPORT. OF THE BILL HERE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
HEARING TINO ONE ROW. FOR NOW
GOING TO STAY. TEST IS. I A
MEMBER GRAY SAID WERE DISMISSED
JUST BEYOND FOR TECHNICAL. THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO STRAIGHT TO THE
PHONE LINES RIGHT NOW. TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SIX. NOT A MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE Q. THOSE UP- THOSE FOLKS
UP NOW. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF THE PART
OF AB- FOURTEEN SEVENTY SIX YOU
MAY PRESS. ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
INSURANCE SUPPORT AT THE CENTER
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
A MODERATOR WE'RE NOW GONNA
HAVE CHECKING TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL. IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE IF THERE IS
ANYONE OUT POSITION CAN YOU
PLEASE STAND AT THIS TIME. SEE
NO ONE IN OPPOSITION WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE TO BE A TO
CHECK IN WITH OUR MODERATOR
META MODERATOR. LET'S SEE DOES
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IT TO ITEM
SIXTEEN AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SIX. CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP
OPPOSITION NOW. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ACTIVE TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
THERE'S NO ONE OPPOSING THE
BILL REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M AT A
MODERATOR THAT'S THAT BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE DCP HAVE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR A MOTION.
THE DEVICE THANK YOU SO MUCH
ADVICE YOU'RE NIELSEN OF FOR
THE MOTION TO MOTIONS ON THE
FLOOR THAT'S GOING TO CENTER
DRAWS A FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. THANK YOU QUESTION
YES PLEASE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YES THANK YOU- AND I APPRECIATE
WHAT- WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS- HOW- WHAT
STANDS OUT THE MOST TO ME IS.
THATTHE CURRENT PARK. HAS A
BASEBALL FIELD PLAYGROUND AND
DOG PARK. RESTROOMS PARKING
LOTS- AND IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'VE
ALREADY OR MODESTO ALREADY
DECIDED. NOT TO. USE THE
REPLACEMENT PROPERTY TO
COMPLETE A RIVER WALK TRAIL. I
MEAN THOSE ARE VERY VERY
DIFFERENT- USES. AND I THINK
THOSE USING THE BASEBALL FIELD
IN THE PLAYGROUND AND THE DOG
PARK. VERY VERY. YOU KNOW I
FELT ORIENTED I'M NOT SAYING
LOT TRAIL ISN'T BUT- MUCH MORE
OF A PLAYFUL- AND VERY NEEDED-
I THINK IN MOST AREAS SO. I'M
CURIOUS IF YOU'VE ALREADY MADE
THE DECISION OR IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT STILL OPEN TO
THE COMMUNITY. PROCESS TO
DECIDE WHAT APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION I COULDN'T AGREE MORE
YOU SENATOR OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF HAVING THOSE FACILITIES
AVAILABLE FOR FAMILIES IS AN-
AVID PARTICIPANT THE
LEGISLATIVE- SOFTBALL GAME AND
AMONGST OTHER THINGS I
APPRECIATE THOSE TYPES AFTER
ACTIVITIES AND WE NEED THOSE
AVAILABLE FOR. CHILDREN IN THE
COMMUNITY BEARD BURKE. BEARD
BROOK PARK UNFORTUNATELY HAS
BEEN CLOSED SINCE- TWENTY
NINETEEN I BELIEVE FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS THE CITY
MADE THAT CHOICE SO IT'S NOT
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE- WE'RE
GOING TO EXCHANGE OUT THAT
PROPERTY OR PRIVATE PARTY AND-
OBVIOUSLY BENEFIT THE COMMUNITY
WITH THIS. RIVER ROCK BUT THERE
ARE MANY OTHER FACILITIES- IN
THE AREA OF- DOWNTOWN MODESTO
THAT DO HAVE THOSE TYPES OF
AMENITIES AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATE DRESS SO SHE TAX. THAT
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR BY THE
VICE CHAIR ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. HEARING SEEN NINE
THAT MR SOME WOMEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ALL RIGHT DOES IT MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY CENTER DRIVE SO MISTER
NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
MOTION AND THEN CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI MCGUIRE AYE SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN A SENATOR DO ALSO.
DURAZO A SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR SKINNER. THREE ZERO
THAT'S CURRENLY THREE ZERO
VOTE LAYS GERMAN KEEP THAT NOW
ON CALL THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER GREGORY SHOULD THAT BE
TO SEE SIR- AND WE WILL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU WE'RE ONNA
GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS CAN I
JUST CHECK IN REAL QUICK MISTER
WARD AT THIRTY SECOND RECESS
PLEASE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN I WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO. I JUST SAY A VERY. FEW
A FEW WORDS ON EIGHTY FIVE
HUNDRED INNOCENT NUMBER WARD
FIRST AND FOREMOST. I WANNA
TAKE A MOMENT TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY REWARD FOR-
HE'S TENACIOUS WORK ON ALL
ISSUES OF HOUSING. HE IS VERY
FOCUSED ON PROVIDING. AT
WORKING FAMILIES AND SENIORS
HOUSING WHO LIVES IN THE
COASTAL ZONE- THIS IS- INDIAN
DISHES BILL- IN ONE THAT SOME
OTHER MEMBERS MAY SHY AWAY
FROM. AS A MEMBER WARD HAS BEEN
A CHAMPION ON THIS AND I JUST
WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU SIR. FOR YOUR HARD
WORK IN YOUR LEADERSHIP. AT
WHAT IS JUST BEEN PASSED OUT TO
COMMITTEE. IS A TIME LINE THAT
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH MR WARD ON. AT MISTER WARD
AND I HAVE BEEN IN CONVERSATION
OVER. THE LAST WEEK AND A HALF.
I ON THIS ISSUE IN WHAT IS IN
FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
IS A STRIPPED DOWN VERSION OF
AB FIVE HUNDRED HI THIS IS A
PRACTICE THAT THIS COMMITTEE IS
DONE WE HAD A- SIMILAR BILL
SOME NUMBER COM LONGER EARLIER
THIS YEAR ON. THE LA HOUSING
COMMISSION BILL WE DID THIS TWO
YEARS AGO IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WITH THIS IN THE PER
CHU. WHO IS FOCUSING ON
ESTABLISHING A- SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA HOUSING AGENCY. AND
NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE A PROPOSED
VERY SIMILAR PRACTICE. AB FIVE
HUNDRED. REASON BEING A LOT OF
MOVING PARTS- AND CANDIDLY. WE
HAVE A SUMMER WORK CREATED
RIGHT IN FRONT OF US. WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH. SENATOR WIENER. FOR THE
CHAIR OF HOUSING. SENATE
PORTANTINO. THE CHAIR OF
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR STERN
THE CHAIR OF NAT RESOURCES
NATURAL RESOURCES- ALONG WITH
THIS IN THE REWARD TO BE TO
WORK THROUGH THE ISSUES. AND
HAVE THIS BILL. BACK IN FINAL
FORM IN FRONT OF COMMITTEE IN
THE MONTH OF AUGUST. IN WHAT
WE'VE PASSED OUT IS THAT- ON
JULY EIGHTH TODAY WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR THE BILL- WE RETURN.
FROM OUR SUMMER WORK PERIOD ON
AUGUST SIXTEENTH- IN THAT.
EITHER THE WEEK OF THE
SIXTEENTH. FOR THE WEEK OF THE
TWENTY THIRD. AB FIVE HUNDRED
WILL BE BACK IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. FOR DELIBERATION-
AND THEN IT WOULD GO TO THE
FULL SENATE- IN EITHER LATE
AUGUST EARLY SEPTEMBER. FOR A
FLOOR VOTE IN THE OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY. JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ALL ON THE
SAME PAGE- AND I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. HAD THIS DRAFT
TIMELINE IN FINALLY. SOME
REWARD THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH THE OTHER
COMMITTEES- AND I'M SINCERELY
MEANNESS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE THIS IS NOT AN EASY BILL.
IN APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THIS
ON. THE FLOOR AS YOUR STERN-
FEEL FREE IF YOU'D LIKE. TO BE
ABLE THAT RIFF ON ANYTHING I
HAD JUST SAID BEFORE YOU CAN
INSURE COMMITTEE STATEMENT. I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH IT AS WELL.
THANK YOU SIR I MISTER- CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND I KNOW NEED TO
WRAP UP THAT REALLY TO ALSO
SHARE. MY APPRECIATION FOR
WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH MY
STAFF WITH YOUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS TO BE ABLE TO GET
THIS RIGHT AS YOU NOTED THIS IS
A LITTLE BIT OF A WALKING A
LITTLE BIT OF A DANCE BILL THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF MOVING
PARTS. A LOT OF INTERCONNECTED
ISSUES BUT THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
TO DO HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
THINGS. ARE DONE RIGHT AND I AM
GRATEFUL FOR ON YOUR PROPOSAL
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN SPEND THE SUMMER PERIOD TO
BE ABLE TO WORK ON THE ISSUES.
BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT-
SUBSTANTIVE INTEREST OF THESE
RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES- THEY ARE
ALL WE ARE ALL INTERCONNECTED
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL OF OUR SENATORS ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH WHERE THIS IS
HEADED BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT.
WE'VE BEEN DOING SO MUCH WORK
IN THE LEGISLATURE. TO WORK ON
HOUSING QUESTIONS OVER RECENT
YEARS AND FOR THE SOME OF THE
STREAMLINING EFFORTS AT BOOM.
ON EVEN MODEST PROPOSALS EIGHTY
YEARS A 100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OTHER HOUSING TYPES. SOME OF
THOSE OF OR FIND A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BUT HAVE YET TO
ACTUALLY WORK ON. THE COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT PROCESS
WHICH IS THAT. UNDER THE
PURVIEW OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WHICH OF COURSE
LOOKS AT LAND USE AUTHORITIES
WITHIN THE COASTAL ZONE.
RELATED TO THAT AS YOU ALL
PROBABLY KNOW WHEN THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WAS ENACTED BY THE
VOTERS AND THROUGH THE COASTAL
ACT GIVEN THE POWERS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE GATE IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES. IT ACTUALLY
HAS PURVIEW OVER AFFORDABLE
HOUSING QUESTIONS AND WORK
REALLY HARD. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE PRESERVING EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK IN.
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES. IN SOME OF THOSE
VERY SAME COMMUNITIES AND THIS
IS IMPORTANT. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
HAVE MIXED INCOME COMMUNITIES
THAT CAN SUPPORT. OUR WORKFORCE
AND LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
ACROSS ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AND NOT HAVE EXCLUSIONARY AREAS
THAT ARE JUST. REALLY GETS HER
OR AVAILABLE FOR ONE SUBSET OF
THE CALIFORNIA POPULATION
THAT'S WHY WE LOOK AT THESE
KINDS OF QUESTIONS. ACROSS ALL
OF OUR JURISDICTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT BECAUSE- OF SOME
OF THE- TECHNICAL DETAILS THAT
WE FIND WITHIN THE COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT PROCESS IT'S
BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF A
CHALLENGE. WITHIN THE COASTAL
ZONE COMMUNITIES AREAS WHERE
PEOPLE COME TO WORK. TO BE ABLE
TO BE A PART OF. THOSE
COMMUNITIES. AT SOME OF THOSE
VISITORS SERVING ACCOMMODATIONS
BUT HAVE. SINCE THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES NOT BEEN ABLE TO
REALLY HAVE SOME OF THESE
INTEGRATED QUESTIONS AROUND
HOUSING. THROUGH SOME OF THE
COASTAL COMMISSION'S ALREADY
ESTABLISHED LAND USE THE WORD
EXCEL WE HAVE A LOT THAT'S
EMOTION THIS BILL HAS DEVELOPED
IT HAS ACTUALLY GOTTEN A LOT OF
PEOPLE TO THE TABLE. TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THIS IS ONE OF
AGREEMENT I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. OVER THE
COMING FOUR WEEKS AS WELL. TO
BE ABLE TO PUT SOME FINE.
TUNING ON TO THIS I REALLY WANT
TO THANK ON THE CHAIR SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS. AND ESPECIALLY
THANK ANTON SEVERINI SORE ABOUT
FOR ALL THAT HARD WORK OUT
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE. I'D
LIKE TO PRESENT A FEW WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SARAH
CHRISTIE THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION. AND BILL
PRINCE LUCKY THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. OF PEOPLE ORGANIZED.
FOR WESTSIDE RENEWAL. THANK YOU
SO MY JOB GRATEFUL I SIMPLY
MEMBER ALL RIGHT TO LAY. CHEN
OUT WE ARE GOING TO. TAKING
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE HUNDRED. WE WANT TO REMIND
FOLKS YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
WE'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT AS YOU'RE COMING UP ON
THAT TWO MINUTES. FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE'RE GOING TO BE
STARTING WITH THAT. DON'T
COUNTY RESIDENT SARAH CHRISTIE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION IS CHRISTY AS ALWAYS
WE WELCOME YOU COMMITTEE. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN
MORNING MEMBERS- AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I'M SURE CHRISTY WITH
ACOSTA COMMISSION WHICH HAS
VOTED UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORTED THE
CLUB FOR GROWTH. I WANT TO SAY
THE COMMISSION WORKING INTENDED
USING REAL TWENTY NINE TEN. TO
PROVIDE MORE TIME TO NEGOTIATE
CONSENSUS LANGUAGE THAT WILL
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE'S
CONCERNS WHILE STILL ACHIEVING
THE AUTHOR'S INTENT TO PROVIDE
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
CALLS ON. THE COMMISSION SHARES
THAT GOAL AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO A PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSION WITH
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE IT A
REALITY. I'D LIKE TO USE THE
BALANCE OF MY TIME TO
TERRIFYING ISSUE IN A COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS REGARDING THE
COMMISSION'S RECORD ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING LIKE. THAT
THE SEVEN TO NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE. AS STATED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN CULTIC MUST REPORT THE
COMMISSION APPROVED THE
CONSTRUCTION OF APPROXIMATELY
FIVE THOUSAND BEACH SECURE
PORTABLE UNIT. WITHIN THE
MARKET RATE DEVELOPMENT THAT
WAS APPROVING AT THAT TIME. AND
PRIVATE PREVENTED THE
DEMOLITION OF THE- ANOTHER
ELEVEN HUNDRED. PAPA COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS ALSO REFERS TO A
DIFFERENT STUDY THAT ESTIMATED
THE COMMISSION ONLY REQUIRED
THE CONSTRUCTION OF BETWEEN
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN AND FIFTEEN
SIXTY UNITS DURING THAT TIME.
THAT WAS IN NINETEEN NINETY
ACADEMIC ARTICLE BY ROBERT
JOHNSON SEE MORE SPORTS
PUBLISHED IN THE COASTAL
MANAGEMENT JOURNAL. WHICH WAS
ALSO CITED AND RELIED UPON IN
THE COMMISSION TWENTY FIFTEEN
REPORT. THE LOWER NUMBERS ONLY
CAPTURE THE ESTIMATED NUMBER OF
UNITS BUILT IN LA. ORANGE AND
SAN DIEGO COUNTY. THIS NUMBER
IS A SUBSET OF THE THREE
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN APPROVED
AFFORDABLE UNITS REQUIRED IS
BECAUSE THE PERMIT CONDITIONS
ENOUGH COUNTY. WHICH IS ALSO
MENTIONED IN THE JOHNSON
SCHWARTZ REPORT. THE STUDY'S
AUTHORS ESTIMATED THAT THIS
NUMBER REPRESENTS 63% OF THE
TOTAL. STATEWIDE WHICH MEANS IF
YOU DO THE MATH. THE CULTURE
COMMISSIONER CHOIR. FOUR
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
TWO UNIT. SEVENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
ONE. A STUDY AND- FOR FIFTEEN
OR- ALL REFERENCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE NOW FROM. SECOND
RECORD MARC FISHER. ONE EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR UNITS BEEN
APPROVED AT THE TIME OF ITS
RIGHT. THIRTY NOT A WORD THE
ACADEMIC STUDY TO THE COMMITTEE
CONFLICTING THE COST OF WHICH
IS NOT ACT CAN. THE APPROVAL OF
OUR PRODUCTS FIVE UNITS. THE
REASON THE NUMBER OF UNITS ON
THE GROUND IS LOWER THAN THE
NUMBER. PRINTED BECAUSE THE
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE NOW ACT IN
ADDITION TO AUTHORIZING THE
DEMOLITION OF COASTAL HOUSING
EXPERT IF YOU NEED OUT OF THE
CAUCUS ON. ALSO OPERATE
DEVELOPERS TO GET OUT FROM
UNDER DIFFERENT CONDITIONS
REQUIRING THEM TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
MARKET PROJECT. NOT BECAUSE OF
REQUIREMENTS RENDERED THEM
ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE. I BRING
THIS UP AT THE POINT OF
VERIFICATION AND TO PROVIDE
CONTEXT TO WHAT MIGHT SEEM LIKE
A DISCREPANCY BETWEEN THE TWO
REPORT. I'M HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
WITH MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A DEEPER DIVE INTO THE
ISSUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIS CHRISTY
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY
ALWAYS GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE
WERE NOT GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
BILL PRESIDENT. I APOLOGIZE I'M
GONNA BUTCHER YOUR NAME BELT
AND THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
CORRECT ME. AT BILL PRINCE
LUCKY. OUT FROM POWER BILL
PLEASE PROCEED. HI YES MY NAME
IS BILL COULD LIKELY- ON THE
BACK OF THE RECORD PEOPLE
ORGANIZED FOR WESTSIDE. I THANK
THEM VERY MUCH NOT THE TRAFFIC
NEAR. THE COMMITTEE YOU'VE GOT
THE NAME. CORRECT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT- I'M JUST
GONNA KEEP THERE ARE COMMENTS
VERY PRETTY- WE SUPPORT. OF THE
PROCEDURE TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH. THIS
COMMITTEE CHAIR- AND THE AUTHOR
WE SUPPORT THE INTENTION THE
INTENT OF THE BILL. DEGREE IN
PRISON AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THE COASTAL TOWN OUR MEMBERS.
LIVE IN THE COASTAL TOWN WE'VE
ORGANIZED WITH LOW INCOME.
RENTERS IN THE COASTAL TOWN-
AND WE ARE CONSTANTLY WORKING
TO KEEP DOING THE LAND IS
PROCESS TO CREATE AND PRESERVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR LOW
INCOME MEMBERS. IN VENICE I'M
MARINA DEL REY AND OTHER
COASTAL AREAS OF LOS ANGELES
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO.
ACHIEVING THE INTENT OF THE
BILL WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND- POP OUT THERE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY GRATEFUL
ALRIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TOWARD
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES AND-
AGAIN WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ADDITIONAL TIME TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE. ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION
OVER THE NEXT THIRTY OR SO
DAYS- THROUGH THE SUMMER WORK
PERIOD ON AB FIVE HUNDRED WE
LOOK FORWARD TO TALKING WITH
BOTH THOSE IN SUPPORT KNOWS IN
OPPOSITION. THAT START WITH R.
TO LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES
NOW FIRST AND FOREMOST WE'RE
GONNA GO TO DEBRA CARLTON FROM
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. THIS CARTOONIST
NUMBER CAN TURN OVER TO STEVE
CREWS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. THIS GROWTH AND
WELCOME THE COMMITTEE YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT AS YOU GET
CLOSER. TO TIME. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MISS CARLTON. THANK YOU
MISTER AND MAY. YEAH I WILL
EVEN TAKE THOSE TWO BECAUSE I
WANT TO THANK THE- COMMITTEE
AND I WANT TO THANK. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD FOR AGREEING TO
CONTINUE THE PROCESS IN THE
DISCUSSION- ALGEBRA. TO EIGHTY
FIVE HUNDRED ARE OBJECTION
DON'T SURROUND- YOU KNOW
NECESSARILY THE BILL ITSELF BY
WAY OF HOUSING PRODUCTION
BECAUSE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THAT WE HAVE.
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING IN THE
COASTAL ZONE. OUT WE JUST HAVE
A DISAGREEMENT ON HOW TO GET
THERE. SO THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION COMMITTED
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
FAMILY MEMBER WARD TO FIND A
BILL THAT WORKS FOR EVERYONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SO MUCH WAS CARLTON VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT OFFER AND P.
SHE'D BEEN COMMITTED TODAY
THAT'S TURN IT OVER TO MR CRUZ
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
MR CRUISE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS
THE INCREASE. BUT CREWS
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. IN OPPOSITION TO
THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL
AND- I KNOW THERE'S A LOT LATE
ACTIVITY. INTO THE EVENING
YESTERDAY BUT WE UNDERSTOOD
DURING THE INTERIM. THE BILL
WOULD TAKE THE FORM OF THE
STUDY. AND THEN THERE WILL BE A
PROCESS THAT YOU OUTLINED INTO
THE SUMMER- AS PART OF THAT
PROCESS AND THERE WAS A
FRAMEWORK. THAT WAS LAID OUT
THAT LOOK AT POTENTIAL FUTURE
AMENDMENTS AND THEY DID.
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN. THE
REINSTATEMENT OF THE WAY TO THE
COASTAL COMMISSION. OVER
PORTABLE HOUSING AND THAT WILL
REMAIN A CONCERN PRESS OUT. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WAS CLEAR. TO
THE COMMITTEE- A TO SUMMARIZE
VERY QUICKLY AS RELATE TO. THAT
AUTHORITY AS REFLECTED IN FIVE
HUNDRED- THEY ARE AS FOLLOWS
FIRST THE LEGISLATURE THREAT
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NOT THE
COASTAL COMMISSION. WHAT THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ACROSS THE DOWN SECOND.
AB FIVE HUNDRED DISREGARDS THE
HOUSING ELEMENT PROCESS AND WE
ALL KNOW THE CHALLENGES FOR
JURISDICTIONS IN MEETING. THOSE
AMBITIOUS GOALS NEEDED BUT
INVESTORS GOLDEN FINALLY- WILL
LEAVE AB FIVE HUNDRED BECAUSE
IT HAS THE OTHER. ADDED LAYER
OF COMPLICATION. ENGAGEMENT
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY GLAZER AND
DISCOURAGE INVESTMENT HOUSING
COSTS IS ON. AND WHAT WE KNOW
IT'S GOING TOWARD IS WELL
INTENDED- EXPERIENCES SHOWN.
THAT KNEW HOW THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY BE CONSTRAINED WITH
BELIEVE BUT ON THE STREETS OF
IT BECAUSE COMMISSION BEING
GRANTED THIS AUTHORITY AGAIN.
WHICH IS WHY I'M A CANNELLA
WITH CHILDREN EIGHTY ONE- IF
NOT FOR. THE OUTRIGHT DENIALS
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S- BEEN
LIBERTY TAKEN AN IMPOSING.
RESTRICTIONS ON ALL FORMS OF
HOUSING. ANY ANALYSIS THAT
ENDED A GOOD JOB OF POINTING
OUT. AT LEAST ONE EXAMPLE THAT
WHICH IS THE IMPOSITION OF-
REALLY STRICT INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING REQUIREMENTS IN FACT
WAS 25% ON NON RENTAL
RESIDENTIAL PROJECTS AND AS
MUCH AS THIRTY THREE PERCENT.
OR CONDO CONVERSION TO JUST TWO
MINUTES OR MORE. THIRTY SECOND
WE KNOW THAT THE- YESTERDAY YOU-
AND WE DO AT LEAST IT JUST
FIFTEEN- RESULT IN ELEVEN.
COSTING TO THE MY RATE YOU
NOTHING DEVELOPMENT. WHICH
ENTREES. TO NINETY DOLLAR. PER
UNIT PRODUCED MARC. YEAH MISTER
THAT FIFTEEN. SO THOSE ARE KIND-
YOU KNOW WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
BEING BALL THE ENGAGE AND
DISCUSS. OVER THE- IN AGAIN
YEAH. WE HAVE SOME CHUNKY ARE
AT THE FOREFRONT. IN NATURE BUT
WE THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE THIS BILL- CENTER-
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO STAYING
ENGAGED THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CHRIS IS ALWAYS THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO PAY FOR
CALLING IN VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT. THERE'S A GENTLEMAN WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO NOW IS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CHECK IN TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE HUNDRED IF
THERE ARE. CAN YOU PLEASE STAND
COME TO THE PODIUM. SEE NO ONE
WRITES WE'RE NOT ONLY GOING TO
OUR LIVE TELECONFERENCE LINE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING THE PHONE
NUMBERS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE EIGHT NINE
NOT A MODERATOR CAN YOU AND CAN
YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF
AB. FIVE HUNDRED CAN YOU PLEASE
DO SO NOW. FOR COMMENTS AND
FOR. OF A- FIVE HUNDRED PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE AND ZERO.
ENTER WE HAVE- TWO PEOPLE IN
QUEUE LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
ONE YEAR MIKE IS UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON- TURN OVER TO THE
COMMITTEE. SORRY NOT YOUR BODY
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL AND THE COURTS-
OF THE BILL BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
TRACKING DEVELOPMENT THE
PASSIONS OVER THE SUMMER RECESS
TO SEE THE FINAL LANGUAGE THANK
YOU SORRY ABOUT THAT AWKWARD
DANCE ON THE PHONE I APOLOGIZE
I THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY AND I DID NOT
MEAN TO STEP ON THE TOES TYPE I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS. AND
THAT'S GONNA NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND MISTER CHAIR THE OTHER
CALLER LEFT THE QUEUE ARE THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT THAT'S BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE WORKING TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE IF THERE IS
ANYONE OPPOSITION TO PLEASE
STAND NOW. THERE IS NOT A
STAMPEDE AS THEIR DRAWS- COMING
FORWARD SO WE'RE GONNA NOW GO
OVER. TO THE LIVE LINE THAT'S
CHECKING MISTER MODERATOR MR
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE- Q. OF
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FIVE HUNDRED NOW. THANK YOU
MEDICARE FOR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE HUNDRED
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. IN
LINE ONE HUNDRED FIFTEEN YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. MR SURE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JENNIFER STACK
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WE ARE
GOING TO CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY
BOTH THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND THE APARTMENT
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING HOW
NEGOTIATIONS WORK OUT OVER THE
SUMMER RECESS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MISSPELLED
SHOULD THE PHONE CALL LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE.
TWO HUNDRED FORTY. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JASON RILEY CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE WHERE THE BILL
MOVING WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
WE HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL
YOUR WE LOOK FOR THE
CONVERSATION HOWEVER MUCH LIKE
OUR FRIENDS IN THE BUILDING
COMMUNITY CITIES NEED CERTAINTY
AS WELL- AND WE KNOW WE EVER
CERTIFIED HOUSING ELEMENT TO
THE DEPARTMENT THANK YOU WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS GONNA
BE A CONFLICT WITH THE COST
COMMISSION THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH IS RYAN COULD HEAR
VOICES GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE IT. TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE. BARCLAYS BEGAN ON
BEHALF OF THE NINETY THOUSAND
STAKEHOLDERS WITH MARK
CALIFORNIA. EIGHT THOUSAND.
REALTORS IN STRONG OPPOSITION
OF EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY- WE ARE VERY FEW LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. IN
LIGHT ONE HUNDRED NINETY THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE START WITH MANY PUBLIC
POLICY GROUP REPRESENTING THE
CITY OF CARLSBAD IN OPPOSITION
AT EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE
CALL TODAY. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS THE
MODERATOR THAT'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS OF
POLICE CENTER DRAWS OF FLOORS
YOURS. THANK I'D LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL- AND ALSO JUST DONE
THANK THE AUTHOR- I USED TO
SERVE. YOU YEARS AGO ON THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
AND- THERE WAS ALWAYS OF AN
ATTEMPT WITH THAT WE HAD TO
FIGHT OFF OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN ABOUT. WHO HAD A
RIGHT. WHO HAD A RIGHT TO BE ON
THESE THESE BEACHES WERE RIGHT
TO BE IN THESE IN THIS. WHAT IS
NATURALLY BELONGS TO EVERYBODY.
AND DOT IT WAS QUITE DISTURBING
TO SEE THOSE TACTICS OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN. SO I'M
REALLY GLAD THAT THE ISSUE OF
HOUSING FOR. AFFORDABLE LOW
INCOME- FAMILIES AND RESIDENTS
AND OWNERS AS MUCH AS ANYBODY
ELSE- WOULD BE A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION IN THE NARRATIVE
WHEN IT CAME TO HOUSING SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER DRIVE SO ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS QUESTIONS
CONCERNS FROM COMMITTEE. WE DO
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
MOTION FOR BY CENTER DRIVE SO
THAT'S IN THE REWARD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE WITH THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH I OF
COURSE YOU KNOW MAINTAIN MY
COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH ALL. OF
OUR CALL LEGISLATORS AS WELL AS
ALL THE STAKEHOLDER INTERESTS
AS I'VE DONE EVERY STEP IN THE
PROCESS FOR THE MANY COMMITTEES
IN THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR- VERSIONS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HEAR
THIS BILL I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF WEEKS- L. TO STAY HERE FOR
THE RECORD OF COURSE YOU KNOW
WE ARE TRYING TO DESIGN
SOMETHING HERE THAT IS. NEITHER
DISRUPTIVE NOR DO TO LOOK IT UP
BUT RATHER IS COMPLEMENTARY IN
SUPPORTER FOR THE INTENDED
GOALS THAT WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO SEE- THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL
IT'S NOT JUST- YOU KNOW ACCESS
TO THE COAST WHICH IS A
CRITICAL IMPORTANT THING IS THE
REASON WHY WE HAVE A CAUSAL
COMMISSION. BUT THE COASTAL
ZONE CAN SOMETIMES EXTEND MILES
INLAND THEN WHEN YOU LOOK
PARTICULARLY SOME OF OUR URBAN
CAN ACT AT DISTRICTS LIKE MINE-
YOU'RE LOOKING AT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTIAL HOME
AREAS THERE THAT HOW THIS
ADDITIONAL BURDEN THIS
ADDITIONAL LAYER. IS THIS
OPPORTUNITY REALLY TO TRY TO
GET AFFORDABLE HOUSING
QUESTIONS RIGHT I. WILL LOOK
FOR THEM- HOPEFULLY REVISITING
THIS WEEK I WITH YOU ACT. IN
THE COMING WEEKS AMHERST.
REQUEST- I TODAY THANK YOU SO.
IN AS A MEMBER AND YOU'RE
TAKING. INTO JUST WANNA GET THE
ON. YES THE MEMO I WILL BE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IN- THESE.
WILL BE. IN COMMITTEE EITHER
THE WEEK OF THE SIXTEENTH. OR
THE WEEK OF THE TWENTY THIRD-
AND WE LOOK FOR OF AUGUST- AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONVERSATION HERE IN THE COMING
WEEKS. IT'S A NUMBER THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH FOR THE PARTNERSHIP
HERE. ALL RIGHT. CENTER DRIVE.
THANK YOU FOR THE MOTION THAT
TURNED OVER TO MR NOW IF YOU
CAN PLEASE CALL THE MOTION. AND
THEN CALL ABOUT. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED. BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO
SENATOR DORADO. DORADO- A
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
SKINNER. TWO ONE TWO ONE VOTE
LEAD HIM TO ONE GO THINK SO
MUCH THEN THE REWARD- AND WE
WILL SEE HIM BACK HERE IN
AUGUST LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
THAT WE HAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER WHO'S GONNA BE
PRESENTING NEVER GONNA TURN
OVER TO SOME THEIR MCCARTY. WHO
HAS A COUPLE BILLS IN FRONT OF
US TODAY THAT WE'RE NOW GOING
TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO US A
MEMBER FRAZIER MISTER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
HERE TODAY- I'M SORRY TO KEEP
YOU WAITING- THANK YOU SO MUCH
THOUGH- FOR STICKING WITH US-
YOU TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO YOU
ON AB EIGHT NINE OH THREE AND
CONFIRM. THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
TAKING HIM IN SIR. YES MISTER
TERRIO WE APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFUL MOMENTS AND WE DO
ACCEPT THEM THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR OF COMMITTEES
FOR ALL OF THEIR STAFF ON THIS
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF AB
EIGHT NINE OH THREE. THE
LAWSUIT. COMO OKAY. HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT IS A COMMUNITY BASED
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT AND
PITTSBURG BAY POINT. THE
PORTIONS OF CLYDE. CLAYTON IN
ANTIOCH. IT WAS FORMED IN
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT WITH THE
PURPOSE OF OPERATING THE LOS
MCDONALD'S COMMUNITY HOSPITAL.
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR THE
HOSPITAL CLOSED DUE TO
BANKRUPTCY AND IS NOW BEING
LEASED TO THE CONTRA COSTA.
COUNTY OP OPERATING AS A
PITTSBURG HEALTH CENTER. THE
DISTRICT HAS CEASED PROVIDING
DIRECT CARE TO ANY HOSPITAL
PHYSICIAN OR EMERGENCY
SERVICES. HOWEVER FROM
200-082-2000 NINETEEN THE
DISTRICTS STILL HAD AN AVERAGE.
SKEWS ME ANNUAL REVENUE OF
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN DOLLARS MOST OF WHICH
CAME THROUGH AN AD VALORUM
PROPERTY TAX. TUESDAY APRIL
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO CONTRA COSTA
GRAND JURY FILED A REPORT
RECOMMENDING THE CONTRA COSTA
LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION CUP
MISSION AS WE ALL KNOW IS
LASKO. DOES ALL THE DISTRICTS
CITING THE LACK OF DIRECT.
MEDICAL SERVICES AS WELL AS
VERY HIGH ADMINISTRATIVE
EXPENSES. AS NOTED THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THE ASSEMBLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
REVIEWED ALL OF THE EXISTING
HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS. AND TO
QUOTE FROM THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THESE DISTRICTS ARE
SOMETIMES ACCUSED OF BEING
HIGHLY COMPENSATED MIDDLEMAN
THAT INCUR UNNECESSARY
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND THAT
IS EXACTLY WHAT IS HAPPENING
HERE. TWENTY NINETEEN THE
DISTRICT SPENT ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF THIS ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION TOTAL REVENUE. I'M
FIGHTING THE DOES A LOOK THE
DISSOLUTION OF THIS DISTRICT.
OVER HALF ITS BUDGET IS BEING
SPENT ON ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
THAT'S THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS COULD HAVE
BEEN SPENT ON HEALTH SCREENINGS
SENIOR CITIZEN CARE GIVING
SUPPORT HOMELESS PREVENTION
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT THESE
COMMUNITIES. ABSOLUTELY
DESPERATELY NEED. HOWEVER THE
DISTRICT IS ONLY OPEN TWELVE
HOURS A WEEK. THERE WILL BE NO
DISRUPTION OF SERVICE THE
FUNDING WILL GO TO THE COUNTY
IN ORDER TO OPERATE THE LOS
MCDONALD'S AREA HEALTH PLAN
GRANT PROGRAM. AND SO FOR A
GRAND JURY REPORTS THE CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS CONTRA COSTA
LAUGHTER- AND THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION HAVE ALL SUPPORTED
AND RECOMMENDED THE DISSOLUTION
OF THIS DISTRICT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AT SO WE'VE GOT TO BE
ABLE TO GET INTO OUR BOTH OUR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. FIRST AND FOREMOST
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT WE'RE GONNA
START WAS SUPERVISOR FEDERAL
GLOVER FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. THEN WE'RE GONNA TURN
IT OVER TO ALLEN TIMER HE IS A
FORMER BOARD MEMBER FOR THE
LAST MADONNA'S COMMUNITY HEALTH
CARE DISTRICT. SO WE'RE GONNA
FIRST WELCOME SUPERVISOR GLOVER
TO THE COMMITTEE SUPERVISOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
WITH US YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
SIR- ANDY I'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPTED MR
SUPERVISOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS
PLEASE PROCEED. I GET AFTERNOON
CHAIR MCGUIRE AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. AND SUPERVISED
THE GLOVER AND I REPRESENT
DISTRICT FIVE WHICH IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY WHICH I'VE DONE
FOR THE PAST TWENTY YEARS. I'M
CALLING IT TODAY TO SUPPORT A.
B- NINE OH THREE AT THE MENDED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER ON
BEHALF OF CONTRAST COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS. THE LOS UNITED
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT HAS BEEN
THE SUBJECT OF NUMEROUS CALLS
FOR DEVOLUTION OF THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS INCLUDING FOR A
SEPARATE DURING JURY- THE MOST
RECENTLY A UNANIMOUS DECISION
BY THE CONTRA COSTALOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSION.
AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
FOLLOWING A PROPOSAL BY THE
POUND. CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AT
THE PRIMARY BRING HEALTHCARE
SERVICE THE MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS. THROUGH THE
OPERATION OF THE COUNTY
HOSPITAL AND THE OF THE LEOPARD
ABERTILLERY HERE QUINN. IN FACT
FOUND TO COST THE LARGEST
CLINIC FOR HEALTH CLINIC WAS AT
ONE TIME THE LOFT LOUNGE NEARLY
HALF THAT OF A FACILITY
OPERATED BY THE LAW BROWN'S
NEARLY HEALTHCARE DISASTER. IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR THE
DESPERATE BANKRUPT AND TO CLOSE
THE DOOR. I'M SURE THIS SERVICE
CONTINUE TO THE RESIDENT WITHIN
THE DESPERATE THE COUNTY
RENOVATED THE FORMER HOSPITAL
BUILDING OPENED HERTZBERG
HEALTH CLINIC IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. THAT ARE AROUND
ONE OF THEM THE OPEN FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. AND BUILDING
MOST IMPORTANTLY. BYE THE BY
THE RECHTERMAN HERE TO THE
RESIDENTS OF THE FACILITY. THE
STATE TO BE CLEAR THE DISTRICT
DOES NOT POSSESS A BY THE RACK
MEDICAL CARE RESIDENT IN FACT
PRIOR TO THE- COUNTY MAPCO
UNANIMOUS VOTE THE FALL OF THE-
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. THIRTY
SECOND DESPERATE. AT THE.
PUBLIC TO CONFIRM THAT WORK WAS
ISSUED BY THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
THE MISSION AT TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WOULD PREFER THOSE-
REPEATED CRITICISM OF THE
DISTRICT- THE HIGH OVERHEAD
CALLS SO THE DISTRICT HAS
CONTINUED TO STAND HERE AND THE
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN PUBLIC
FUNDS MOUNTING A LEGAL CAMPAIGN
AGAINST THE HOW TO PAY OFF THE
LAST BALL UNANIMOUS DECISION IS
ABOUT DISTRICT EXHAUST FIVE
THAT AND IT SHOULD BE. YOU FOR
HEALTH CARE SERVE ONE FIVE
RESIDENTS. THANK YOU SO VERY
YOUR BROKE OR FOR A BI- FINAL
THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
RESIDENTS SORRY I DID NOT MEAN
TO IN YEAH WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE EQUAL FOR YOU
SIDE IN REALLY PRE YOU TAKING
TIME IN YOUR BUSY SCHEDULE TO
BE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY I DID NOT MEAN TO STEP ON
YOUR TOES SIR SO. THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOUR TESTIMONY WE WILL
ALLOW AN ADDITIONAL MINUTE TO
OUR FIRST LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN JUST A FEW
MOMENTS. LEAD OPPOSITION WITHIN
SIX HUSING SO WE'RE GOING TO
ADD AN ADDITIONAL MINUTE TO THE
CLOCK FOR OUR FIRST LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS BUT WE HAVE
ONE MORE WITNESS WHO IS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THAT'S
ALLEN TYPE MORE HE'S A FORMER
BOARD MEMBER WITH THE LOS
MADONNA'S COMMITTEE HEALTHCARE
DISTRICT- ALLEN YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES HERE AND I'LL GIVE YOU.
A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MY NAME IS ALAN TO TOMER-
FORMER. L. M. C. H. D. BOARD
MEMBER- SERENE- NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT THROUGH TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE. I STRONGLY SUPPORT MR
FRAZIER'S AB NINE OH THREE. CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK. YOU'RE YOU'RE
COMING IN LETTING OTHERS ONLY
THEY CAN MUCH YES SIR OKAY GOOD.
ALL RIGHT SO JUST. CLAIMS TO
THE CONTRARY CURRENT AND
ONGOING ACTIVITIES OF THE L. M.
CHT BOARD. OFFER MINIMAL
BENEFIT TO CITIZENS IN THE
COUNTRY COSTA REGION. THAT
MOSTLY ARE SUPERFLUOUS AND HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH HEALTH CARE.
EXEMPLIFIED BY FUNDING SUPPORTS
PROGRAMS. A ROOF TOP POLITICAL
GALA NON HEALTHCARE COMMUNITY
FESTIVALS A BABY SHOWER PROGRAM
A READING PROGRAM FOOD PANTRY
LOCAL SWIM PROGRAMS A PARKS AND
RECREATION PROGRAMMER AND A
COMMUNITY GARDEN ON THE SAME
GROUNDS- AS THE CLINIC.
REMAINING PROGRAMS INCLUDE.
REDUNDANT SUCH AS THE ROTOR
CARE FUNDED THEY'VE SET UP
ADMINISTERED TO SAINT VINCENT
DEPAUL. CHILD'S VISION PROGRAM
WHICH IRONICALLY ONLY SERVED
EIGHTEEN PEOPLE THIS PAST YEAR
AND A WOMAN STRESS PROGRAM. ALL
OF THESE ARE OFFERED BY THE
CONTRA COSTA HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS- CONTRA COSTA
HEALTH PLANS. MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN SIPHONED OFF
TO FUND BOARD MEMBER STIPENDS
FULL AND PART TIME STAFF LEGAL
CONSULTANTS PUBLIC RELATION
LOBBYIST TRAVEL EQUIPMENT
TECHNOLOGY IPADS. PETER
MEETINGS- EVEN ABOUT HIRING A
BUS TO BRING CRITICS OF EIGHTY
NINE OH THREE TO A BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS MEETING PART OF A
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
EXPENDITURE TO FUND A
PROFESSIONAL LOBBYING EFFORT TO
JUSTIFY THE CONTINUED EXISTENCE
THIRTY SECONDS SO IN SUMMARY IN
SUMMARY THE LOC IT DOES NOT
OFFER THE CONTRA COSTA HEALTH
DEPARTMENT WHO OPERATE THE PITS
FOR CAL CENTER ONE DOLLAR FREE
RIDE BUT INSTEAD TURNED OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. AND A COLLECTED OVER
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN PAYMENTS
AND SAY TAKEN OCCUPANCY- MY
SUPPORT AB NINE OH THREE ONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO TALK TO
HER I APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TO DATE LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THAT WE HEARD FROM
SUPERVISOR CLEVER THEN FROM
MISTER TETRAMER. RIGHT NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR TO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS. OUR
FIRST LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
IS THE MARK THORPE.
REPRESENTING THE LOS MADONNA'S
COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE DISTRICT.
THE MARKET YOU ARE GONNA HAVE
AN ADDITIONAL MINUTE. AT TO BE
ABLE TO INSURE THAT WE HAVE
EQUAL TIME FOR BOTH SIDES-
SUPERVISOR GLOVER HAD THREE
MINUTES MR THORPE YOU WILL NOW
HAVE THREE MINUTES AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO ELIZABETH- KASIANO
WHO HAVE TWO MINUTES. SO MR
THORPE THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOUR
THREE MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU
A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU TO
ALL THE OTHER WITNESSES I'LL
JUST START BY SAYING I DON'T
KNOW MR TIMER- HE THERE FROM
NINETY EIGHT TO TWO THOUSAND
THREE IT IS TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
NOT TWO THOUSAND THREE I'M NOT
SURE I DON'T THINK HE'S
REFERRING TO- YEAH I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT CHARTERED BUSES I'VE BEEN
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR AT.
ALMOST TWO YEARS NOW. I AM IN
THAT TIME. I THINK THE MENTOR
HAD LEFT TO DO THE THINGS I
APPROVED- OR THE WORK THAT WE
DO HAVE A LOT NON COMMITTEE
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT. SO I'M NOT
SURE WHAT PLANET YOU'RE GONE
BUT HE'S NOT A PLANET EARTH-
THIS BILL. EVERY ASPECT OF BAD
GOVERNMENT- WHEN IT COMES TO-
FRANKLY. PEOPLE OF COLOR- WHEN
WE SAY- WE DON'T TRUST
GOVERNMENT THIS BILL IS EXACTLY
WHY WE DON'T TRUST GOVERNMENT-
BECAUSE IT IT. IT UNFORTUNATELY.
THREE EIGHT- VOTER TO FRENCH.
YEAH CENTER. I MUCH APPRECIATE
HER SHE- THE COMMUNITY THAT I
WAS GRAYSON EL SERENO IN LOS
ANGELES. AND AS A TEENAGER I
GREW UP THEIR ORGANIZING PULLED
AGAINST THE U. S. SEVEN TEN
EXTENSION BECAUSE IT WAS AND
NOT EQUITABLE IT DIDN'T HAVE
ARE VOID. OF LUCK PENAL IN THAT
PROCESS AND THIS IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. THIS IS A
MAJORITY PEOPLE OF COLOR
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT THIS IS A
MAJORITY LATINO HEALTHCARE
DISTRICT AND OUT OF THE SEVENTY
FOUR HEALTHCARE DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA. THE MAJORITY OF
THEM DO NOT OPERATE HOSPITALS
JUST LIKE LOCKED BUT DONALD
COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE DISTRICT.
AND SO I'M NOT A LOT. THAT'S
WHY WE'RE EVEN HERE- I KNOW WE
WOULD NOT BE TALKING ABOUT THIS
THAT THIS WOULD EVEN HEALTHCARE
DISTRICT AND I KNOW WE WOULD
NOT BE TALKING ABOUT THIS THAT
THIS WOULDN'T GET IF THAT'S
WHAT. THE- THIS WILL HELP YOUR
DOCTOR. THIS IS WRONG IT THE
FATE. OF A LAW THAT. THAT THAT
THAT THAT IS CALLED THE COURT.
NOT HERTZBERG ACT WHICH- CREATE
THE- THAT WORK IN RIGHT NOW.
WHICH IS WHERE AND DISSOLUTE
PROCESS AND PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT
TO VOTE- AND HOPEFULLY. YOU
THAT DOWN SO THAT PEOPLE DO
HAVE A RIGHT TO VOTE. IN THEIR
PROCESSING WHEN MAKING SURE
THAT THAT THEY GET TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT- THAT THE
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT TODAY. NOT
NECESSARILY JIM FRAZIER BY
HIMSELF. ARE WE DON'T THINK
IT'S RIGHT IN ITS WRONG- WE DO
OPERATE AYE GLASS BROKE BRANDON
WE DO PAPER PRESCRIPTION FOR-
FOR. INDIVIDUALS IN THE
PITTSBURG UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS WELL AS MOUNT
DIABLO. WE GET YEAH YES- WE OF
COURSE. UP ON THE BIG BACK
BASKETBALL PROGRAM BECAUSE
WE'RE IN THE INTEREST OF TRYING
TO REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE WHICH OF
PLEDGING THE- BURKE- WHEN WE-
STARTED OUT IN MODIFYING OUR
EFFORTS REAP REVOLVING OUT THE
COLBERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IT
WAS KIND OF PERMANENT SAY THAT
REACHED OUT TO US. TO ENTER
INTO A PARTNERSHIP THAT WE CAN
DO BOTH EXCUSE ME SO WE CAN DO-
RESIDENT OUTREACH SPECIFICALLY
AFRICAN AMERICANS BECAUSE- THAT
THE COUNTY COULDN'T HANDLE THE
LOAD AND THEY'RE NOT BUT
MEMBERS ARE DEMONSTRATING THAT.
51% OF YOU COUNTY RESIDENTS.
HAVEN'T OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICANS HAVE NOT BEEN
BACKDATED AND THAT BECAUSE OF
THE COUNTY FAILURE- I ALSO HAVE
TO BE THE MAYOR OF THE LARGEST
CITY- IN IN EASTERN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY. ELECTED MAYOR AND
I IN THE BACK IN LARGEST CITY
IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND OF
COURSE I DURING THE POLITICAL
ALONG WITH MIKE THE BIKE. THERE
MANIAC MONICA WILSON THIS BOARD
PRESIDENT OF ANTIOCH- ELLIE
HOUSEHOLDER AND MANY MEMBERS OF
THE PITTSBURG UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AS WELL. THIS IS NOT
FAIR TO THE RESIDENTS OF EASTER
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY THIS IS
WRONG- WE BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT. TO VOTE IN
THAT PROCESS AND THAT IT SHOULD
BE TAKEN TO BACK AWAY FROM AT
THIS VOTER DISENFRANCHISEMENT
NO DIFFERENT THAN WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN FLORIDA. AND IN
GEORGIA I ALSO WANT TO AT I
THOUGHT THE AMENDMENT TO THE
BILL- IF YOU CAN'T BOTH THIS.
AND YOU HAVE- IF YOU'RE TO NEED
AMENDMENT I. IN THE COMMITTEE
CAME WEAKENED. USING THE PHRASE
COURT AND THEY YOU COURT OF
APPEAL. AND REMOVE THE LAN BY
JUST. OF BECAUSE THAT IMPLIES
THANK IT WAS JUST THE ANOTHER
OR A WE'LL- I APPRECIATE SIR
AND NOW AT ALL TRYING STEP ON
YOUR- WE DO WANNA MAKE SURE. WE
HAVE EACH TIME FOR EQUAL SIGN
TO MR THORPE THING YOU SOME FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO ELIZABETH CUT-
KASIANO FROM THE LISTENERS
COMMITTEE HEALTHCARE DISTRICT.
THIS CASTELLANO YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO FLOOR IS YOURS AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR JOINING
US TODAY PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU GALLAGHER I AM A LITTLE
HELP. THIS LEGAL COUNSEL FOR
THE DISTRICT. THE COMMITTEE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL THANKS COMMITTEE
WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN SETTING UP
A PROCTOR TO THE DOCTOR SO
DISTRICTS LIKE THEM BOTH BUT ON
A COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT. BOB PROCTOR IN THE
COURT PAID NON HER. LOCAL REAL.
ACT OF TWO. CAMPAIGN A DETAILED
ORDERLY PROCESS FOR DEVELOPING
A DISTRICT. A PROCESS THAT HAS
BEEN DUTIFULLY FOLLOWED HERE.
THERE'S NO REASON TO FIGHT THAT
THE PROCESS OF AB NINE OH THREE
UNDERMINES THE PURPOSE AND
INTENT OF THE LAW. IS THIS WHAT
WE SHOULD EXPECT IN THE FUTURE
ONE ANOTHER COUNTY HASN'T
SUCCESSFUL DISSOLVED IN THE
DISTRICT USING ESTABLISHED.
WHAT WHAT PPL LEGISLATION. BE
INTRODUCED. OR WILL
DISTRIBUTION BY THE- ONLY HOW A
POOR UNDER RESEARCH REYES
DIVERSE HEALTH CARE TO AND
COMMUNITY. BY AND THEY. WORKING
ON A COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE IS
ABOUT HALF WITH KNOW IF IT
PERCENT. ONE OF MY RACIALLY
DIVERSE HOW CARE JUST THAT'S
NOT THE MOST OF YET WE ARE THE
ONES. BY THE SHELL THE BILL HAS
LIKE THE PRODUCT AND CHANGE THE
PROPER. DON'T CHANGE RULES IN
MIDDLE OF THE TO TARGET THE ONE
DIVERSE YES. WE HAVE REMARKABLE.
AMENDMENT IT HAS OF THIS WITH
MY IS ALLOW THE PROFIT THE PLAY
OUT. BEEN A GREAT TWENTY TWENTY
TWO DOES NOT YEAR. RATHER IT
ALLOWS THE COUNTY TO RUN OUT
THE CLOCK IN THE CASE. OF THAT
THE DISTRICT IS NOT GIPSON.
JUST OF THE- BY THE TIME THIRTY
FOR TWENTY TWO. I KNOW THIS. IS
A LEGAL OF ART AND IT WILL THAT
EVERY IN THE CASE. IS COMPLETED.
COUNTY ALASKA HAVE A RIGHT TO
PROTEST FOR WRIT. WITH THE-
COURT. BUT IF YOU WANT IF
NINETY MIGHT OCCUR BEFORE
DECEMBER THE FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO POLICE HAVE TO DRUM
THROUGH VERY THRIFTY. STEP JUST
TO CLOSE IT OUT GET THAT. POINT
DISPOSITION THIRTY SIX WE'RE-
PROBLEM BIZARRE. IT BECAUSE IT
WILL BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
OBTAIN A OF THIS BY THE- FIRST.
TWENTY IT'S- GOING BE A GREAT
BY. QUARTER MEANS THAT THEY
WILL. HERE THE CASE THAT YOU
COULD ALIVE THE VEHICLE. READ
FILED IN THE CASE ARGUE. BUT
EVEN IF WE THERE WE SAW LOSE
THE TOWN GET SOMEONE. FREESHEET
YOUR TESTIMONY AND AGAIN WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO KEEP EQUAL TIME.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION
IN THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT NOT
AT ALL TRYING TO STEP. ON
ANYONE'S TOES I KNOW
INTERRUPTED HIS SUPERVISOR AND
I KNOW I INTERRUPTED- MISTER
TOUCH MORE EACH OF THE
WITNESSES SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY. SO WHAT WE'D LIKE
TO BE TO DO NOW IS WE LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO TURN IT OVER. TO ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IF YOU-COULD PLEASE STAND COME TO THE
PODIUM LOOKING FOR SUPPORT IN
AB OF AB NINE OH THREE. NOW
SCENE NO ONE WRITES WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR PHONE
LINES. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE EIGHT NINE IS
A TOLL FREE NUMBER. LET'S CHECK
IN WITH MR MODERATOR. MISTER
MODERATOR. IF WE CAN POLICE
CHECKING TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE OH
THREE NOW. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINE OH THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE A
COUPLE PEOPLE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH LINE NUMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH AT 877-226-8189 IS
OUR NUMBER HERE TODAY THE FORTY
HEARING FROM FOLKS WHO'D LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO TALK ON THIS BILL
OR ANY OTHER BILL. TRYING TO
COMMITTEE MISTER MODERATOR WILL
TURN IT BACK OVER TO YOU SIR.
LINE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. THREE EIGHTY NINE
OH THREE YOU ARE IN COMMITTEE
ON AB NINE OH THREE SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER I HAVE MISTER MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE FIFTY
EIGHT. MY NAME IS EDWIN HAWKINS
ELEVEN PRINCIPLE- CALIFORNIA-
I'M HERE FOR SEVEN YEARS- I'M
STRONGLY AGAINST THAT BILL IT'S
WRONG INITIALLY THAT MEASURE
BROWN AT MY TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH AT WE WILL TAKE ANY
INDIVIDUAL IF WE MAY HEAR SOME
FOLKS WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION
DURING SUPPORT SOME FOLKS ARE
IN SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE BUT
AGAIN WE WELCOME ALL. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE A COMMON NINE EIGHTY
NINE OH THREE LET'SGO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE OH THREE. WHY HER
TWENTY TWO. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
HEARING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M LOU AND TEXEIRA
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF CONTRA
COSTA LASKO AND ON BEHALF OF
LASCO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
NINE OH THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR A PHONE
CALL HERE TODAY THAT'S GOING TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. END OF MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
MISTER MODERATOR WILL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU WE ARE NOW GOING
TO GO TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED TO AB NINE OH THREE.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE IF ANYONE
HERE ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
WOULD LIKE TO RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO A BEAT NINE OH
THREE. C. KNOWN RISE WE'RE NOT
GONNA GO BACK TO MISTER
MODERATOR AND CHECK IN ON OUR
PHONE LINES. MISTER MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
INDIVIDUAL. WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB NINE OH THREE
NOW. FOUR COMMENT IN OPPOSITION.
TO EIGHTY NINE OH THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
PEOPLE QUEUING UP FIFTY ONE
MOMENT WILL WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH LINE NUMBERS THAT'S
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MODERATE RECREATION EVERYONE'S
PATIENCE HERE TODAY- COMING UP
AFTER THIS A SIMILAR FRAZIER WE
HAVE TWO BILLS THAT WILL BE IN
FRONT OF US- ITEM NUMBER NINE
ITEM NUMBER TEN BOTH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY. MISTER
MODERATOR AT THE FLOOR IS YOURS
OR FOR OPPOSITION OF AB NINE OH
THREE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WELL NINE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
EMBARKING WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICT HERE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ASKING I NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE. SIXTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON- TO THE CHAMBERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
HI MY NAME IS JOBS THAT OFTEN I
AM AT THE POINT RENDON A MOTHER
Q. AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
NINE OF THREE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY VERY
GRATEFUL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED FIVE. I THANK YOU
COMMITTEE- THIS IS JONATHAN
YOUNG MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY
OF PITTSBURG CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE OH THREE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AWESOME. NEXT
TIME PLEASE. LINE. FORTY EIGHT.
I DON SIXTY THOUSAND WHO WANT
THIS ISSUE ON THE BALLOT WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB NINE THREE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
THAT'S GOVERNING SCHOLAR. WHY.
TWO HUNDRED SIXTEEN. HELLO THIS
IS ROSALYN HILL A COMMUNITY
MEMBER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE A.
B. NINE ZERO THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SALE
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE. TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU FOR LOW
CARB. BILLETE DISPUTE DOESN'T
REVEREND DAVID MATTINGLY
PASTORS DURING THE MORE YOU
CHARGE CONSPIRED AND LIFETIME
RESIDENT OF PITTSBURGH AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. NINE OH
THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH HAVE
BEEN PUSHY OR PHONE CALL TODAY
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. A LINE. EIGHT OKAY I
CALLED IN EARLIER I MADE A
MISTAKE WHEN I'M SHOWING UP
CLOSELY AB- IN AB NINE OLD
THREE THANK YOU IT'S ALL GOOD
SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT. TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO. MY NAME IS
BENICIA MRSH AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB NINE OH THREE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISS MARSH THAT'S
GOT OUR NEXT CALLER. AND MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A MODERATOR LADIES
IN GENERAL COMMITTEE WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
FROM COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME.
PLEASE CENTER DRESSEL THANK YOU
I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS.
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR. YES
MA'AM- OBVIOUSLY ON SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
UP BY- FOLKS CALLING MAN- ART
ARE TWO ISSUES ONE IS ABOUT THE
HEALTH CARE- AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON HEALTHCARE ISSUES.
OFF FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS SINCE I CAME HERE FOR THE
UNINSURED AND THE UNDERINSURED
SO THAT CONCERNS ME IF YOU
COULD. TALK A BIT ABOUT. THE
CARE THAT'S ALREADY THAT CARE
THAT IS BEING PROVIDED AND WHAT
THE IMPACT OF THIS BILL COULD
HAVE ON THAT CARE SO I'M
GREATLY CONCERNED ESPECIALLY-
BECAUSE I KNOW THIS IS A
COMMUNITY. THAT IS OF A LESS
RESOURCES AND UNDERSERVED SO IF
YOU COULD EXPLAIN THAT A LITTLE
BIT MORE- YOU KNOW WHAT COULD
WHAT COULD THIS BILL- DUE TO
THAT- CONTINUITY OF CARE OF OFF
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
BEING SERVED. THANK YOU THAT'S
A VERY GOOD QUESTION SO THE
CONTINUITY OF CARE IS THERE'S
ALREADY SERVICES PROVIDED BY
THE COUNTY. AND THEIR DUPLICITY
TOOK TO SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE INTENDED IN THE MISSION
STATEMENT OF THE DISTRICT. WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS THAT THE
TRANSITION IS AUTOMATIC THERE
ALREADY THERE THERE IN THE OLD
HOSPITAL. THEY'RE ALREADY
PROVIDING IS ALSO- SENATOR OF
THE CLINICAL LA RAZA IS IN
PITTSBURGH ALSO PROVIDING A
WONDERFUL OF. ARRAY OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES- THROUGH THEIR
WONDERFUL NETWORK. WE ALSO HAVE
VERY MANY SERVICE CLUBS THAT
ARE DOING THE FREE CLASS
CLASSES PROGRAMS AT ALL OF THE
THINGS BUT THE COUNTY IS
ALREADY AN ESTABLISHED ENTITY.
IN THE AREA WHAT WE'RE SAYING
IS WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE THESE RESOURCES THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE RESOURCES AND
REAPPLY ADD ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES OF HEALTH CARE. OF
THROUGH THIS THERE WILL BE A
ADVISORY COMMITTEE PUT IN PLACE
OF CITIZENS AND THE BOARD IS
MORE THAN WELCOME TO APPLY FOR
THAT POSITION OF AN ADVISORY.
BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT A LOT MORE
BEING DONE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
THIS COMMUNITY. FOR AND- THAT'S
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT I'VE BEEN
BROUGHT UP THAT- I KNOW THAT
THAT A LOT OF IT IS AT THE CORE
OF THIS. IS THE ISSUE OF
WHETHER OR NOT THEY SHOULD BE
RESOLVED LOCALLY. OR OR BY THE
STATE- AND SO I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT BACK. IF YOU
COULD. GET INTO THAT A LITTLE
BIT MORE BECAUSE- AGAIN THERE'S
A SYSTEM THERE IS A SYSTEM
THERE IS A PROCESS SET UP AND
WE'RE BASICALLY BEING ASKED OF
THE STATE. TO CHANGE THAT
SYSTEM WHILE IT'S STILL IN IN
IN THAT LITIGATION PROCESS
RIGHT NOW AND AS I UNDERSTAND.
AND IT IS AN APPEAL PROCESS
NOW. WHAT MIGHT MIGHT. ABSOLUTE
HOW I'M OFFENDED IS THAT
THEY'RE USING MONEY TO DEFEND
THIS PROCESS THAT SHOULD GO TO
THE PEOPLE. IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND THIS IS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS THAT HAVE
SPENT WHERE WE LOOK AT POST
PANDEMIC WE NEED MENTAL
BEHAVIORAL MENTAL HEALTH HELP
WE NEED ALL OF THESE THINGS TO
BE ABLE TO MULTIPLY OUR
EFFECTIVENESS IN THIS DISTRICT.
AND AS THIS PLAYS OUT AND TIME
AND TIME AND TIME THAT'S LESS
AND LESS MONEY THAT ARE GOING
TO THE INTENDED RECIPIENTS FOR
HEALTHCARE. AND THAT'S MY WHOLE
PURPOSE IS JUST TO MAKE SURE AT
THE ALL OF THESE ENTITIES FOR
GRAND JURIES. A REPORTS THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
UNANIMOUSLY LASKO UNANIMOUSLY
AND THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION ALL RECOMMENDING
THAT. THERE'S ALREADY ENERGY
THERE TO PROVIDE THIS AND WE
CAN MULTIPLY THE EFFECTIVENESS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
AND JUST QUIT SPENDING LEGAL
FEES. TO DEFEND SOMETHING THAT
REALLY ULTIMATELY WE CAN YOU
APPROACH AND A BUSINESS
APPROACH WE CAN GET MORE VALUE
FOR A BIGGER BANG. FOR OUR BUCK
FOR FOLKS. WELL I HAVE TO BE A
I FEEL BE IN THOSE KINDS OF
ISSUES- AS YOU CAN UNDERSTAND I
FELT REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE SORT
OF LIKE. HERE'S A LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND THEN WILL BE
ANNOUNCED BY THE STATE- TO
CHANGE JUST TO CHANGE THE
PROCESS ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S
STILL UNDER THE COURTS TO. I
WILL- I WILL SUPPORT TODAY
HOWEVER I REALLY. URGE YOU TO
LOOK AT THIS LANGUAGE YEAH. I
GUESS THAT WAS MENTIONED HERE
ABOUT- CHANGING COURT TO COURT
OF APPEALS AND- AND SEE IF IT
COULD BE RESOLVED BECAUSE- AT
THIS POINT AND I REALLY DON'T
WANT TO GET INTO THE FOR THE
WEEDS OF IT YEAH YEAH BUT IT
FEELS VERY MUCH LIKE THE-
WE'RE- BEING PITTED AGAINST A
LOCAL COMMUNITY. I AT THE STATE
LEVEL SO. THAT'S THAT'S WHERE I
STAND TODAY AND I REALLY URGE
YOU TO. GET DEEPER INTO THE
PROPOSED CHANGES THANK YOU AND
CENTER I AM A FORMER. RESIDENT
OF THE CITY OF PITTSBURGH WHEN
I FIRST GOT MARRIED I MOVED TO
PITTSBURGH AND LIVE THERE SO I
KNOW THE COMMUNITY WHILE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER DRIVE SO
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF YOU HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEN AND WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR DORADO- IS
SIMILAR FRAZIER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLUBS THEN WITH THE TEARS
INDULGENCE I'D LIKE MIKE PENCE
WILL CO AUTHOR IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND TO BE ABLE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS MISTER GRAYSON. SURE
MISTER GRACE WE'RE GONNA ADD TO
KEEP IT. TEN THIRTY SECONDS PER
YES. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE DISPOSITION OF THE
DISTRICT HAS BEEN A LONG TERM
QUESTION FOR CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY THIS BILL IS AN
EQUITABLE SOLUTION TO THE
HEALTH CARE CHALLENGES FACED BY
THE REGION SO THE COUNTY IS
MADE IT CLEAR THAT THE
DISSOLUTION OF THE DISTRICT
WILL REDUCE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS HAVE TO BE PUT BACK INTO
THE COMMUNITY AND MAKE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR
HEALTH PROGRAMS I RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONAUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER AND- AS
WELL AS IMMIGRATION OUR RIGHTS
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR-
BY- SAID SENATOR DORADO. MISTER
NOW AYE MISTER FISHER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE NO JUST REALLY
THANK YOU FOR THE WILLINGNESS
TO PARTICIPATE AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION WE HAD SOME GREAT
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT I DO
TAKE THE SENATORS- COMMENTS TO
HEART AND WILL. APPLY THAT. THE
OTHER THING IS WORKING AYE
BOTTLE MIKE MCGUIRE'S ENERGY.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MEMBER VERY GRATEFUL PLEASE
CHECK THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL
RIGHT MISTER GRINNELL- THAT'S-
CALL THE MOTION AND THEN CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE
SENATOR NIELSEN. SENATOR DORADO
DORADO HIS SENATOR HERTZBERG
SENATOR SKINNER. TWO ZERO EIGHT
CURRENTLY HAS A TWO IS YOU'RE
ABOUT TO HEAR BUT WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU SO
MUCH SO MUCH ALL RIGHT THANKS
EVERYBODY ALL RIGHT I LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE GONNA MISTER VICE
CHAIR IF IT WORKS TO THE VICE
CHAIR IS IT OKAY WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A THIRTY SECOND BREAK
WE'RE GONNA HAVE MISTER MCCARTY
AT PRESENT ON ITEM NUMBER NINE
IS WELL AS ITEM NUMBER TEN I
HAVE TO RUN INTO HOUSING
QUICKLY I'M GOING TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR IF
YOU CAN JUST GIVE US THIRTY
SECONDS AS A MEMBER THANK YOU
SO MUCH. FOR YOUR GUN. YEAH
OKAY. WE'VE GOT. A I WOULD JUST
TO A DOCTOR FRAZIER BUT GO HAVE
A.
FOR PROSECUTION OF CRIMINAL
AND CIVIL AND CONSUMER ELEMENTS
IN OUR IN OUR COUNTIES ARE
SHERIFF'S OF COURSE- PATROL
UNINCORPORATED AREAS-
ADMINISTER COUNTY ORDERS AS
WELL AS OVERSEE OUR COUNTY
JAILS ON A LARGE IMPACT ON THE
PEOPLE OF OUR GREAT STATE.
HOWEVER WHEN THEY ARE SELECTED
OR ELECTED IT'S USUALLY WHEN WE
HAVE THE FEWEST AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE PARTICIPATING AND
FRANKLY THE LEAST DIVERSE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE IN THE
ELECTORATE SO. YOU KNOW THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE NOTIONS ACROSS OUR
OUR STATE AND NATION-
ENGAGEMENT RACIAL
RECONCILIATION MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE OF HISTORICALLY WITHOUT
A VOICE HAVE A VOICE IN THESE.
IN THESE IMPORTANT ELECTIONS
HERE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND
ACROSS THE STATE WE'VE SEEN
STARK DIFFERENCES IN VOTER
TURNOUT BETWEEN THE
GUBERNATORIAL AND PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS. AND THIS WITH THAT
ENABLE US TO INCREASE
PARTICIPATION ON THESE ON THESE
KEY MATH ON THESE KEY POSITIONS
WITH IT WITHIN OUR COUNTIES I
WE DID AMEND THE BILL RECENT
ELECTIONS TO FOCUS TO TAKE OUT
THE ASSESSORS TO DEAL. STRICTLY
WITH THE- PUBLIC SAFETY
POSITIONS OF A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND SHERIFF. AND I
KNOW THERE ARE SOME POTENTIAL
QUESTIONS AND ISSUES ALL
THROUGH ENGAGE AT DURING THE Q.
AND A PIECE OF THE WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN WITH OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT WE HAVE- ONE
SPEAKER I BELIEVE- ON THE PHONE
LEGAL ADVISORS AS WELL AS ONE
WITNESS. I WITH US TODAY A
LOCAL GROUP HERE IN SACRAMENTO
ORGANIZED SACRAMENTO. THANK YOU
MR VICE CHAIR YOU HAVE A ANDREW
MUSE FISHER HAS THAT CORRECT.
YOU HAVE AN ANYBODY PAPER IN
THE ROOM. OKAY YEAH PLEASE
CONFIRM. FROM WHERE THEY COME.
JUST GO DOWN A FIGHT YOURSELF
AND THEN YOU CAN PROCEED WITH
YOUR AT TWO MINUTES ALL RIGHT
MY NAME IS MICHELLE PATTERSON
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
ORGANIZED SACRAMENTO AS A
SPONSOR OF EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY
NINE. THIS BILL PROMOTES
GREATER VOTER PARTICIPATION BY
MOVING THE ELECTION OF DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND SHERIFF TO THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION CYCLE.
RESEARCHERS FOUND THAT THERE IS
A GREATER GREATER VOTING
PARTICIPATION BY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR DURING THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION CYCLES- WE'VE HEARD
SOME CONCERNS AND I WANT TO
ADDRESS A FEW OF THEM HERE. I
YOU KNOW THE DATA IS VERY CLEAR
THAT IN AGGREGATE MORE PEOPLE
VOTE IN DOWN BALLOT RACES ON
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION BALLOTS
THAN UNDER TERM BALLOTS. AND
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR
PARTICIPATION ORGANIZED
SACRAMENTO- DOES A LOT OF WORK
AROUND- COMMUNITY PARTICIPATION
IN IN IN IN PUBLIC PROCESSES
LIKE. FOR EXAMPLE THE CENSUS OR
OR AND VOTER EDUCATION AND WE
FEEL THAT THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT MORE PEOPLE
SHOULD BE VOTING IDA INSURERS
RACES- THEN ARE CURRENTLY- YOU
KNOW WE'VE HEARD THE CONCERNS
THAT. COUNTY WHITE OFFICERS. ON
THE PRESIDENTIAL BALLOT WITH.
MIGHT I MIGHT- THE- STRUGGLE TO
PAY FOR THAT MEDIA MARKETING
THAT THEY HAVE TO DO- AND OUR
RESEARCH INDICATES THAT- THE
PRESENT IN THE PRESIDENTIAL
CYCLE ARE THERE ISN'T QUITE AS
MUCH COMPETITION FOR THAT MEDIA
MARKETING BECAUSE CALIFORNIA SO
RARELY CONTESTED- AND WHAT IT
IS THAT THE PRESIDENTIAL-
DELLINGER A CANDIDATES ARE
PURCHASING. ADD SPACE FROM VERY
LARGE- MEDIA OUTLETS. NOT
COMPETING IN THE SAME WAY IN
THE SMALLER MARKETS THE COUNTY
WHAT OFFICERS ARE. SO THIS BILL
IS ABOUT INCREASING VOTER
PARTICIPATION IN CRITICAL
ELECTIONS AND WE APPRECIATE
THE- THE COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE STAFF AND LOOK
FORWARD. TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
DO WE HAVE A SECOND PERSON HERE
IN THE ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. A BLACK BEAR I'M ON
THE PHONE I CAN HEAR ME PLEASE
GO AHEAD THEN. YOU MISTER MUSE
FRAZIER WHAT. THAT'S CORRECT GO
AHEAD YEAH HI THIS IS THE END
USER THANK YOU THE ENDING THE
SESSION WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
THANKS FOR HAVING ME TODAY
THAT'S FINE SUPPORT EASTERN.
NINE AND BEFORE ELEVEN I JUST
WAIT WOULD LIKE TO QUICKLY
EXPRESSED HER APPRECIATION.
THAT THAT THAT PRESERVES
COUNTRY UP TO THE TOP OF. A LOT
OF SYSTEMS. THAT THEY'RE NOT
REQUIRED TO HAVE SEPARATE
PRIMARY. AND GENERAL ELECTIONS.
BUT BELIEVE THAT DEMOCRACY IS.
WHEN REPRESENT ARE CHOSEN WILL
NO ACTION HI CHAIN BROWN A
PERSON ORDER. OUT IS WELL
ESTABLISHED FACT THAT PER.
ELECTION ATTRACTED. MORE VOTERS
BUT TERM GUBERNATORIAL
ELECTION. DOESN'T THAT
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS ATTRACT
MORE REPRESENTATIVE. VOTERS I
TO THE CENTER FOR TO. WHEN
COMPARING- THE NOVEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CORRECT ENTIRE L.
LECTION AND THE NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
TURNOUT OF ELIGIBLE ASIAN
AMERICAN VOTERS INCREASED BY
FIFTEEN PERCENT. I'M TURNOUT OF
ELIGIBLE LATINO VOTERS
INCREASED BY 18% A SIMILAR
TREND CAN BE SEEN IN YOU VOTER
TURNOUT WHICH INCREASED 21% FOR
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION. THE
DATA HERE IS CLEAR CANDIDATES
SELECTED HIGHLIGHTED DURING MID
TERM ELECTIONS ARE SUPPOSED TO
BUY SMALLER LESS REPRESENTATIVE
PROPORTION OF ELIGIBLE VOTERS
COMPARED TO THOSE LIKE TO
DURING PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
YEARS. AB SEVEN FIVE NINE WILL
ENCOURAGE MORE VOTERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN A SPECIFIC
COUNTY ELECTIONS ALLOW MORE
UNDERREPRESENTED VOTERS TO
PARTICIPATE MAKING CRUCIAL
LOCAL DECISION. HELLO THEREFORE
INCREASE THE LEGITIMACY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE FALCONS-
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICES. ENTER
THAT A LARGER AND MORE. ABOUT
ASKING VOTE FOR HIM. WHO WERE
FOR OUR VALUES CRITICAL TO
MAKING OUR DEMOCRACY WORK WHAT
ARE THE THREE BILLY NUMBER
HELLO. CHUNKS OF AB. ASSEMBLY
MCCARTY FOR LEADERSHIP THIS
ISSUE WE ARE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE'VE HAD OUR TO SUPPORT
WITNESSES NOW- MODERATOR LET'S
GO TO THE PHONES AND SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY CALL IN. TESTIMONY
IDENTIFY YOURSELF WHEN YOU CALL
IN AND THE STATE YOUR POSITION
ON THIS BILL. OR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN FIVE NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE THREE PEOPLE QUEUED UP
LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY THREE
YEAR MIKE IS UP. MONEYTORIA
ADAMS AND I'M PRESIDENT OF THE
EAST COUNTY BRANCH OF THE NAACP
AND I WAS ACTUALLY QUEUED UP
FOR. SB NINE OH THREE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION IN BATON FOR
WHATEVER REASON I WOULD NOT
CALL- BUT I DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT MY STATEMENT. IF
HEARD LOUDEST BODY. AND TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT THE VOTE. SHOULD
NOT BE CIRCUMVENTED THE RIGHT
OF THE COMMUNITY SHOULD BE
HONORED AND THAT THE DECISION
OF WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE LOCAL
HOSPITAL DISTRICT SHOULD BE
THAT OF THE COMMUNITY. IN THAT.
MOMENT FRAZIER STATES THAT HE
LIVED HERE IN THIS COMMUNITY IN
PITTSBURGH. AND NO CLICK BEST
FOR THE COMMUNITY BUT IF YOU
ASK COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO
SENATOR FRAZIER IF THE PUBLIC
COULD NOT EVEN TELL YOU BECAUSE
YOU'VE BEEN SO OUT OF TOUCH
WITH. THE LOCAL HERE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND I KNOW THIS
BECAUSE I AM ALSO A RESIDENT OF
THIS COMMUNITY THANK YOU SO
MUCH MA'AM BLACK EARTH. THAT
COULD NOT. THANK YOU MA'AM
WHERE WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL AND
DID DID NOT MEAN TO AB TO
INTERRUPT ME ON BUT- WE JUST.
TYPICALLY WHEN WE ARE- FOCUSING
ON TELECONFERENCE- COMMENTS ITS
FIRST AND LAST NAME ALONG WITH
YOUR AFFILIATION YOUR POSITION
THE BILL AND REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOUR ELOQUENT WORDS HERE TODAY
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL ON THAT
PREVIOUS BILL AB NINE OH THREE
THANK YOU AGAIN MA'AM. ALL
RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
THE MODERATOR AND AT FINISH UP
ON THOSE- CALLERS WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN FIVE NINE-
PLEASE AND IS A MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE PROCEED ON
SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE NINE.
LINE. TWO HUNDRED SIXTY TWO.
MISTER SHARON MEMBERS STILL GET
THE LEAST SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND DRUNK THE PARK THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH I AM VERY
GRATEFUL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. WHY. TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE. HELLO THIS IS THE LEAST
FOUNDER QUIT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
VERY GRATEFUL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND
MEDICARE THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH
YOU. SO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE WERE NOW GOING TO BE
GOING TO OUR TO LEAD SUPPORT.
TO LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES-
WE HAVE AT THE DEAN OF ALL
CALIFORNIA SISTER RECORDER- IN
CLERKS AT JOHN TUTOR WITH US-
HE IS THE ASSESSOR RECORDER IN
CLERK- IN THE COUNTY OF NAPA
ABOUT TO RUN FOR HIS TWELFTH
TERM LEASING GERMAN MY DAD- AND
THEN WE WILL- IT DIDN'T WILL
HAVE. COREY SAYS A LOW FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE ALWAYS
GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
DEAN- JOHN TUTOR IN COMMITTEE.
MISTER TUTORED THE FLOOR IS
YOURS ON AB SEVEN FIVE NINE YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES AND WE'LL GIVE
YOU A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT. I
GUESS I'M NOT INTERACTION HE'S
ARE ALSO GONE SILENT SO- THAT'S
ITS CHECK IN WITH MR TUTOR- IF
WE HAVE MISTER TUTOR ON THE
LINE. ALL RIGHT SO GUESS WHAT
WE'RE GONNA COME BACK TO MR
DUTERTE I'M- LAZY GERMAN IF YOU
THOUGHT THIS IS MOVE THE SILK
WATCH OUT ALL RIGHT SO NOW
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING. TO COREY
SAYS HELLO HI COREY IS BACK
WITH US- DOING HAT TRICK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION THIS TIME IN
OPPOSITION AND MAYBE SEVEN FIVE
NINE. SHE SAYS HELLO I THINK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE
SIR THE FLOOR IS YOURS IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN FIVE
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSE CHORUS ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION'S IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY NINE. WELL
PROPONENTS POINT TO THE NOTION
THAT MORE VOTERS ON AVERAGE MAY
VOTE IN PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS.
AS A REASON TO MOVE THESE
CONTESTS. THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO
GUARANTEE THAT VOTERS WILL
EXAMINE THEIR CHOICES MORE
CAREFULLY IN A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION YEAR. OR FRANKLY CAST
MORE VOTES IN ANY PARTICULAR.
CONTEST ESPECIALLY DOWN TICKET
RACES. IN FACT A LONGER
ELECTION BALLOT COULD RESULT IN
VOTER FATIGUE AND FEWER VOTES
CAST IN THOSE DOWN TICKET
RACES. TO BE SURE THERE IS NO
GUARANTEE THAT MOVING ONLY
CERTAIN ELECTIONS AS THE BILL
WAS RECENTLY AMENDED. WOULD
ENHANCE VOTER ENGAGEMENT IN
THOSE RACES AND IN FACT THERE'S
A STRONG LIKELIHOOD THAT VOTER
PARTICIPATION COULD DECREASE.
INSTEAD THE ONLY SURE OUTCOME
THE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN AND
COST OF ATTENDING THE CURRENT
ELECTION CALENDAR. ADDITIONALLY
DEPENDING ON A COUNTY JACKSON
THE BILL COULD RESULT IN COUNTY
OFFICERS ELECTED IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. SERVING EITHER A
TWO YEAR TERM OR SIX YEAR TERM.
IN IN THOSE CASES WHERE THERE
WAS A TWO YEAR TERM THOSE
OFFICERS THAT THEY WERE GOING
TO SEEK REELECTION WOULD HAVE
TO DO SO JUST TWO YEARS LATER
IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IST THIS
WILL REQUIRE AGAIN JOHNNY
RESOURCES. AND RESULT IN
CERTAIN OFFICERS NECESSARILY
SPENDING MORE TIME SEEKING
ELECTION- AND JUST FROM A LEGAL
PERSPECTIVE- THOUGH NOT AN
ATTORNEY IS LESS THAN CLEAR.
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ARE
EVEN ABLE TO CHANGE TERM LINKS.
AFTER THOSE OFFICERS HAD BEEN
ELECTED SO IN OTHER WORDS THE
FOLKS WHO ARE ELECTED IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. IF THE BOARD OF
pPROVIDED THAT THE MEASURE. TO
CREATE A TWO YEAR TERM TO
SWITCH THE CYCLES IF YOU WILL-
BUT THEY'D BE ABLE TO CHANGE
THE TERM LENGTH. OF THOSE
ELECTED OFFICERS SO FOR THOSE
REASONS YES THE FAMOUS
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB SEVEN
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH OF SUCCESS- APPRECIATE
THAT ALL RIGHT SO LAYS IN
GERMAN GIVE US. THIRTY SECONDS
WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN TO SEE IF
WE HAVE JOHN TURNER ON THE LINE
I GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS WE'LL
BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU. THANK
THEM ON THE LINE. I GOT THAT
AND WE HAVE. THE DEAN OF THE
CALIFORNIA. SISTER QUICKER AND
RECORDER SO SHE SHOULDN'T ALONG
WITH THE DEAN OF THE SENATE SO
BEFORE WE GET STARTED- MISTER
TUTOR OF PLEASE MR VICE CHAIR.
WELL I'M ANOTHER DAY IN THE
JOHN AND- WE'RE OLD FRIENDS AND
I JUST WANTED TO GIVE YOU MY
FONDEST REGARDS I MISS YOU AND-
GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE AGAIN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER TUTOR ARGUES TUTOR WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES SIR THE FLOOR
IS YOURS PLEASE PROCEED IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN FIVE
NINE. THANK YOU CHAIR HELLO SO
I'VE BEEN IN OFFICE AS A COUNTY
LIKE THIS WHICH INCLUDES. THREE
YEARS OF WHICH MORE THAN HALF
BIRDS REGISTRAR OF VOTERS. AND
I DO WANT TO SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE. THIS IS THE MOST
ALICE THROUGH THE LOOKING GLASS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. THAT I AM
WILLING TO. THE AUTHORS BEEN
CHAMPIONS TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
DO. ONE CUMBERLAND CHERUBS AND
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. WHERE THE
BLACK LADY THE OPPOSITE. WAY
THIS DISCUSSION ABOUT GREATER
TURNOUT IN THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION NORDERSTEDT FACT. THAT
35% OF THE TURN OUT. IN THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN ELECTION WAS SO
MANY PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR
PRESIDENT. THEY DID NOT TOUCH
THE REST OF THE BALLOT. THAT IS
NOT A GOOD THING. ASSEMBLY OF
COURSE YOU THAT THERE MORE
PEOPLE ARE. AND SO. ACROSS TELL
ME WHY LAW OFFICE IS. WHO'S
BEEN NEGLECTED IN SOME YEARS IN
SOMEWHAT BEING LEFT IN OTHER
YEARS. CURRENTLY THE COST OF
THIS BEST THE SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS LAW BECAUSE ADDING THE
TOO LONG OFFICE TO THE GROUND
BALLOT THE IS ALL COMPLEX YEAH
DIFFICULT AND CAUSES
FRUSTRATION BECAUSE VERY WELL.
AN ADDITIONAL BALLOT CAR WHICH
BECAUSE THIRTY DOLLARS A WHICH
ONE REQUIRE THAT TIME TWENTY
PLUS MILLION VOTERS IS BUT TO
SEVEN AND EIGHT MILLION.
THEREFORE I THINK THAT IT'S A
TO BECOME MEMBERS. THAT ONE
COME WILL DO BETTER IN THE
PRESIDENT ELECTION THEN THEY
WILL ILLUMINATE WILL. RECALL-
THE COMPLEXION OF THE DIFFERENT
OF RAISING AND SPENDING MORE
THAN ELECTION WILL PUT
CHALLENGER OF THE DAY AND- SO I
WOULD EXPECT SOMETHING MCCARTY
M. TO DO SOME ABOUT THE SHERIFF
CONTRACT COUNTY. YEAH IN
CERTAIN DAYS MARKETS COUNTY IT
YOU KNOW OF COURSE ALSO
SUPPORTS THAT THE PRIME PEOPLE
STATE. I ONLY EARN A NOTEBOOK
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A TWO P.
SHE OF CALL HERE TODAY I
APPRECIATE PATIENCE WITH US IS
WELL AND YOU CALLED BACK AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR WE ARE
NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO HEAR
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY WOULD
BE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE A RISE TO BE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SOUND. FIVE NINE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE DO SO NOW. SEE NO ONE
WRITES ARE NOT GONNA BACK OUR
PHONE LINE. ARE WERE GOING TO.
TRY TO BRING THE PHONE LINES
DOWN YA- IN THE A MINUTE IN. ME
MONTEREY MR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY IN. WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SEE. IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FIVE NINE. I THINK YOU LADIES
AND IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AT THIS TIME. IT IS NOT A
MODERATOR OPERATOR THAT IS A
MODERATOR THAT IS BACK I
APOLOGIZE MADAME MODERATOR. I
KNOW THAT AND MR MODERATOR IS
NOW NO LONGER ON SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND A MODERATOR. THANK
YOU WE CURRENTLY HAVE NO ONE
SHOWING OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT SO IT'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE AT REALLY
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'SPATIENCE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE
CHAIR FOR TAKING THE HELM. I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS PLEASE MISTER VICE
CHAIR. COMMENT MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I DIDN'T. KNOW MR COOPER WAS
GOING TO COME AND TESTIFY- IN
OPPOSITION I HAVEN'T TALKED TO
IN PROBABLY THIRTY YEARS BUT
HERE'S A VERY RESPECTED. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL. IN NAPA
COUNTY PUBLIC THE DEMOCRATS DO.
I JUST AT THE STATE FOR THE
RECORD THAT THERE'S AN AGENDA
HERE. THAT I VIGOROUSLY OPPOSE.
AND IT IS AS MR TO RESET THE
POLITICAL AGENDA. AND SUPPLIED
I KNOW THERE'S NO RESPECT FOR
THE DISRESPECT OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEN I HAVE HIGHEST REGARD. FOR
HIM AND I KNOW HE'S RESPONDING
TO A CONSTITUENCY THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO HELP. BUT THERE IS
A BLATANT POLITICAL AGENDA
HERE. AND WE JUST OUGHT NOT
BROKER CAPTAIN THAT'S THAT AND
I WILL VIGOROUSLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
COMMENTS FOR SERVICE YOU'RE AT
PLEASE SENATOR RAWSON FOR
SHORT. YEAH I AM I REMOVED THE
BILL I JUST DO WANT TO ASK THE
QUESTION- WHICH I THINK IS COME
UP. HE MIKE EVERY TIME WE AS
GET MOVING TO ALIGN. OUR
ELECTIONS AND MORE- AND THAT IS
THAT THE ISSUE OF. IN TOTAL
MORE PEOPLE MAY VOTE FOR SOME
BODY ON THE BALLOT BUT DOES
THAT EXTEND TO ALBIA POSITIONS
ON THE BALLOT AND IF ANYBODY
COULD HELP ANSWER THAT I WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE- BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT. JUSTIN COURAGE
WHERE PEOPLE COULD VOTE FOR THE
TOP. THE BALLOT AND THEN LEAVE
EVERYBODY ELSE OFF. SURE YEAH I
CAN ADDRESS AT THAT AND- OF THE
OTHER ISSUES AS WELL AS WE
HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION ALL
AT ONCE OR JUST THIS QUESTION
IF YOU WANTED TO STAND YEAH YES
JUST THAT QUESTION YES SIR
THERE'S MORE DROP OFF ON A
PRESIDENTIAL BUT EVEN IF YOU
LOOK AT THE DROP OFF IT'S STILL
WAY MORE PEOPLE VOTING AND THAT
THEN IT A GUBERNATORIAL WHICH
WE ALSO HAVE DROPPED OFF. AND
THE NOTION THAT PEOPLE BE
KICKING FEELS ON A LONG BALLOT
KEEP IN MIND ON THE
GUBERNATORIAL BALLOT THERE'S
MORE STUFF UP TOP WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT GOVERNOR LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR CONTROLLERS TREASURE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER I FORGOT
A BUNCH ON THERE'S A WHOLE
BUNCH SO THE RACKET YOU WOULD
SEE THIS BILL THIS MEASURE
SOONER ON YOUR BALLOT IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL THAN YOU WOULD
FROM A GUBERNATORIAL SELF YEAH
THERE'S ALWAYS DROP OFF THE
PRESIDENTIAL BUT YOU KNOW THERE
WOULD BE MORE PEOPLE. ENGAGING
ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE THAT
THAT HAS A HUGE IMPACT ON OUR
COMMUNITIES AND A PRESIDENCY I
THINK THAT'S CRYSTAL CLEAR
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR
DRUGS WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR LAYS INJURED THE MOTION
ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER DRIVE SO
ON AB SEVEN FIVE NINE LAST CALL
FOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE FROM
COMMITTEE CURRENCY NINE I
MISSED MCCARTY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE PLEASE YEAH I THINK
YOU I APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE
AND I THINK THAT THERE IS AN
AGENDA HERE MY AGENDA AND
ARGENTA IS WE SHOULD HAVE. MORE
PEOPLE VOTING ON KEY ISSUES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL WOULD
AGREE UPON I THINK SOME PEOPLE-
IT ENTRENCHED INTO ENTITIES WHO
LIKE TO BE ELECTED WHEN THERE'S
FEWER AMOUNT OF MINORITIES
VOTING WHEN THERE'S FEWER
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE THEY WENT YOU
KNOW THEY LIKED IT THEY THEY
WIN BECAUSE THERE'S FEWER
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WHO GET TO
CHOOSE THESE ISSUES AND I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S WRONG I THINK WE
SHOULD CHOOSE THESE IMPORTANT
POSITIONS WITH THE MAJORITY THE
MOST AMOUNT OF PEOPLE ARE
ENGAGING THE DIRECTION OF THEIR
COMMUNITY. IT'S NOT ABOUT
KNOCKING OFF INCUMBENTS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WE HAVE OPEN SEATS
IN THOSE TWO KEYS RESIDENTS AND
ALL. FAMILIES AND PEOPLE
RETIRE- LIKE THE GENTLEMAN FROM.
OF POTENTIAL RETIRED TWELVE-
THERE IS GOING TO BE ELECTIONS-
AND ARE GONNA COME YOU KNOW
THAT HE ONE ON THERE ARE SOME-
LINGERING PICKED LEGAL ISSUES
AND RIGHT NOW THEY JUST ARE
THAT POTENTIAL IF YOU LOOK AT
THE LETTER FROM THE DA'S
ASSOCIATION. IT SAYS MAY BE
PROBLEMATIC. IT'S UNCLEAR IF
IT'S AN ISSUE POTENTIALLY
POSSESS SO THESE ARE ALL
HYPOTHETICALS IF THERE IS A
CONCRETE PROBLEM AND WE NEED TO
ADDRESS WE'LL DO IT WE HAVE
OPTIONS THAT WE COULD CHOOSE
EITHER TWO OR SIX YEARS. FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OUT OF THE
GATE FOR THESE OFFICES AND WE
COULD TAKE A LOOK AT CHARTERS
ARE NON CHARTERS LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ALREADY DOES THIS AS WE
NOW ALSO THERE IS AN EXAMPLE
WHERE WE HAVE SOME
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICES IN THE-
GUBERNATORIAL LIKE L. A. COUNTY
HAS THE ASSESSOR AND OTHERS. IN
THE DA AND SHERIFF IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL SO AGAIN I THINK
THIS IS A GOOD A GOOD IDEA FOR
<c.blue>EMOCRACY. AND I RESPECTFULLY</c>
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIMMER UP WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY CENTER DRAWS A
MYSTERY NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE MOTIONS. AND CALL THEM A-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO SENATOR.
DORADO A SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR SKINNER. TWO ONE THAT'S
A TWO ONE VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU SO
MUCH- WE HAVE A DOUBLE HEADER
BY MR MCCARTY ADDED WE HAVE AB
NINE SEVENTY- THIS IS FOCUSING
ON ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS AND PERMIT PERMIT
APPLICATIONS- MISTER MCCARTY
YOU DO HAVE BY. USING DO WE
DON'T HAVE BY PRINCE PART OF
THIS ONE SO WE'RE GONNA BE
PLEASE PROCEED ON AT FULL
STATEMENT AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I AM GETTING
TO THESE BILLS TODAY MISS
MCCARTY THE FOR SHORT THANK YOU
THANK YOUNG DIVERSE COMMITTED A
DIFFERENT TOPICS HERE- THIS ONE
IS ABOUT. ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
CHARGING STATIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AND WANTED TO FOCUS
ON IMPROVING THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR THESE ACROSS CALIFORNIA WE
WANT TO ADDRESS OUR CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS AND GET MORE. E.
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD WE NEED
MORE CHARGING STATIONS- WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON HELPING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SPURRING MEN
INTO ACTION TO PERMIT THESE. I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THAT THE
GREAT COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS FROM
FROM YOU ALL THANK YOU FOR THE
SUGGESTIONS. FOCUS ON TWO
THINGS ONE THE TIME LINES FOR
LARGER PROJECTS AS WELL AS SOME
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS WAY TO
CHARTER. CITIES AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR WORK SELF SIX
YEARS AGO THIS LEADS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB TWELVE
THIRTY SIX. THE STREAMLINED THE
PERMITTING PROCESS FOR EASY
CHARGING SATIONS HOWEVER
BARRIERS CONTINUE TO PREVENT
THE RAPID CONSTRUCTION. A STORY
AFTER STORY HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED
FOR THE BUILD OUT OF THESE
CHARGING STATIONS TO SUPPORT
OUR EVEY ADOPTION IN OUR STATE.
TODAY ONLY. TODAY THREE
QUARTERS OF A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE NOT CREATED
STREAMLINED PERMITTING. AS WELL
AS- REQUIRED UNDER THE LAW SIX
YEARS AGO- THESE DELAYS LOW
PERM SLOW PERMITTING. AND HAVE
RESULTED IN SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER BUILDING COSTS AND FEWER
CHARGING STATIONS BEING BUILT
AT THIS BILL RESOLVES NON
COMPLIANCE- BY ESTABLISHING
CLEAR TIMELINES FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO REVIEW. OF
PERMIT APPLICATIONS AND IF NOT
THERE WOULD BE- SUBSEQUENTLY
ADOPTED- WITH ENACT ACTION-
WEEK WE AGAIN MUST TAKE MAJOR
STEPS IF YOU WANT TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE ABOUT MOBILE
SOURCES THAT'S ABOUT- CARS THAT
WE NEED TO GET UP THE ROAD THAT
OUR- INTERNAL COMBUSTION
ENGINES AND TRY TO GET. A
CLEANER OPTIONS AND THIS IS A
KEY PIECE OF THE PUZZLE I WITH
ME TODAY. ARE A. REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE MAYOR'S OFFICE OF LOS
YEAH. THE OFFICE OF FIFTY. AS
WELL AS SELECT. AMERICA THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH IS IN
THEM ALL RIGHT LADIES AND GENTS
WE ARE A TWO THE TO. WE NEED.
ON REC HERE THAT START WITH
JESSICA JANE SHE IS FROM THE
MAYOR'S OFFICE OF
SUSTAINABILITY IN THE GREAT
CITY OF LA SENATOR ALSO YOU
KNOW A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT-
YOU KNOW LIKE YEAH. IT'S GOOD
IT'S GOOD ALL RIGHT TO TURN IT
OVER TO MISS JANICE CHEN YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES- IN YOU I'LL
GIVE YOU A THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT- AS YOU GET CLOSE TO THE
IN THEIR OF YOUR STATEMENT
MISSION WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE. IN SUPPORT OF AB.
NINE SEVEN E. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
TERRY MCGUIRE AND VICE CHAIR
NIELSEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY. ON BEHALF OF MAYOR
CARCETTI AND THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. I AM A CLIMB ADVISER
IN THE MAYOR'S OFFICE OF
SUSTAINABILITY AND HAVE WORKED
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT I'M HE'D
BE READY NEXT FOR MUCH OF MY
CAREER. PERMITS REMINDING HAVE
REMAINED. HOT BARRIER TO
GETTING WIDESPREAD EACH HURTING
PATIENTS BOB. THIS IS WHY AB
NINE SEVENTY IS A CRITICAL
PIECE OF ADVANCING OUR
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION.
GOAL TRANSPORTATION REMAINS
LEADING. OF ADMISSION IN THE
STATE AND BACK PARTICULARLY
TRUE THAT. LIVING IN ANGELES
MOCKING HAD. OUR JUST A READ.
YEAH THIS IS NOTHING FROM TO
THE FRONT MY- AND OUR-
PARTICULARLY THOSE YOUR HIGH.
CENTER BEAR THE BIG BURDEN OF
AIR. AND CLIMATE. THE CITY OF
LA AND- A LEADER IN TRANSFERRED
ELECT. WE'VE HIT OUR LOCAL
TARGET OF INSTALLING TEN
THOUSAND COMMERCIAL LEVEL TWO
CHARGERS BY TWENTY TWENTY. TWO
YEARS EARLY AND WE'VE ALSO SET
A GOAL FOR THE YEAR- MISSION
BACK WEEK BY TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT. AND A REGIONAL TRANSIT
AGENCY LA METRO AND NOT FAR
BEHIND AT. THE MILLER GOAL BY
TWENTY THIRTY. AN ADMIN BARK
THE PUNK BAND ELECTRIFICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR TRANSIT
HEAVY AND MEDIUM DUTY VEHICLE
AND MORE. EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY
WILL HELP GUARANTEE THAT WE
MEET OUR GOAL WHILE ALSO
ENSURING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
LOCAL JOBS AND EASY.
INFRASTRUCTURE INSTALLATION AND
MAINTENANCE. WE CANNOT MEET
STATE CLIMATE ERICA GOALS
WITHOUT. LIKE THAT. WE ADDRESS
ARE READY AND EAGER TO. PURSUE
MORE HIGH. HURTING BECAUSE- AND
WE THAT YOU WILL HELP IN OUR
SELECT LOCAL AND STATE ELECTED.
AND CLIMATE CORE BY SUPPORTING
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH I
MISS YOU AND WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL WHEN I'M GOING TO GO
TO MATTHEW NELSON WITH
ELECTRIFY AMERICA. MISTER
NELSON YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES AND
I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT PLEASE PROCEED. YOU'RE
MCGUIRE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MATTHEW
NELSON AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AT ELECTRIFY
AMERICA. I RISE TO SPEAK AS A
SPONSOR OF AB NINE SEVENTY.
ELECTRIFY AMERICA IS THE
LARGEST AND FASTEST GROWING
NETWORK OF ULTRA FAST CHARGING
STATIONS IN THE UNITED STATES.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE'VE OPENED
NEW STATIONS AT A PACE OF
APPROXIMATELY FOUR PER WEEK. WE
HAVE MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTY STATIONS OPEN ACROSS
FORTY SIX STATES AND CALIFORNIA
IS BY FAR OUR LARGEST MARKET.
WE HAVE A HUNDRED NINETY ONE
STATIONS HEARING CALIFORNIA
OPERATIONAL TODAY. CALIFORNIA'S
EVEY CHARGING STATION
PERMITTING LAW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOOSE AB TWELVE THIRTY SIX. IS
THE STRONGEST EVEY PERMIT
EXPEDITING LIE IN THE NATION
ARE NOT. UNFORTUNATELY IT'S NOT
FOLLOWED AND IT'S NOT BEING
ENFORCED. AS MENTIONED BEFORE A
REVIEW BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
ADMINISTRATION HAS FOUND THAT
ONLY 24% OF CALIFORNIA
JURISDICTIONS COMPLY WITH AB
TWELVE THIRTY SIX. ELECTRIFY
AMERICA'S OWN EXPERIENCE OUR
PRIMARY BECAUSE OF DELAY IN
PERMITTING OUR EXTENDED DOWNING
REVIEW PARKING COUNT
REQUIREMENTS AND MULTIPLE
ROUNDS OF COMMENTS. ALL THREE
OF THESE ARE PROHIBITED BY AB
TWELVE THIRTY SIX. AS A RESULT
OF THESE DELAYS IN. IN THE
FIRST QUARTER OF THIS YEAR THE
AVERAGE TIME TO COMPLETE. A
PART CURRENT PROCESS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR DC FAST CHARGING
STATION WAS 30% LONGER THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE AND AS A
RESULT IT COSTS US 34% MORE-
STATION. TO BUILD TO DESIGN AND
BUILD STATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
WHEN COMPARED TO THE REST OF
THE NATION THESE ARE EXACTLY
THE SAME LAYOUTS EXACTLY THE
SAME STATIONS. BUT THEY COST
34% MORE. THIS HIGHER AVERAGE
COST PER STATION ULTIMATELY
MEANS THAT CALIFORNIA IS
GETTING FEWER STATIONS FOR THE
DOLLARS WE INVEST. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE DOLLARS THE
STATE AND OTHERS AND AFTER.
THIRTY SECONDS EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY. AB NINE SAID IMPLY
APPROVED PERMITS STREAMLINING
STRATEGY WELL KNOWN IN
CALIFORNIA THE PERMIT
STREAMLINING ACT USE DEEMED
COMPLETE AB FIFTY SEVEN
IMPLEMENTED DEEMED APPROVED. IN
THE TELECOM SPACE ON BEHALF OF
ELECTRIFY AMERICA I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE THE LEADERSHIP OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER Q. ON THIS
ISSUE I WANT TO THANK THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES FOR
RECOGNIZING THE PERMITTING IS
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE. AND I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
STAFF FOR THEIR GUIDANCE AND
ASSISTANCE IN MAKING SURE THAT
THIS IS THE BEST BILL POSSIBLE.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS YOU KNOW
SINCE PRECIADO MISTER NELSON-
AND MISS JAN IS A WELL ALRIGHT
LADIES IN GENERAL WE'RE GOING
TO SEE ANY IN PERSON COMMENTS.
IF YOU ARE WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
SEVEN HERE ROOM THIRTY ONE
ANYONE PLEASE COME FOR NOW.
SEEN NO ONE AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE CHECKING
WITH MADAME MODERATOR WHAT
MADAME MODERATOR OR BACK TO
YOU- CHECKING IN IF THERE IS
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB. NINE
SEVENTY CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
THEM UP NOW. CERTAINLY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF WISH TO SPEAK
SUPPORT OF AB NINE SEVENTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
APPETITE. AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE
EIGHTEEN Q. WE'LL START WITH
ONE ONE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
MEMBERS NOT YOUR NORMAL CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. TWO SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON JUSTIN
HIGHER WHICH IS OPEN BY
LEADERSHIP GROUP IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS NIKITA
KARATE WITH ENERGY IN SUPPORT
THANKS TO GET THIS GOOD OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH REST LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SHOPPERS WITH COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR CO SPONSORING
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR CALL TODAY
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO SEVENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KATHY WENT
REPRESENTING PLUG IN AMERICA
CONSUMER GROUP IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SURE MEMBERS DAN CHAU WITH
TESLA IN SUPPORT- WE PUT
HOWEVER NOTE THE WELL THE GREAT
WORK UPON THE AMENDMENTS WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE TWENTY
FIVE- THAT TREAT STATION-
THRESHOLD. WHICH MAY BE A BIT
ARBITRARY- BUT WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
THE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER. COURT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH. IT
COMMENTS AT LET'S CHECKIN ON A
NEXT LINE PLEASE. ONE THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
MICHELLE OR OCT ON BEHALF OF B.
P. AMERICA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND
BEFORE WE OPEN MY TO. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK AT THE PART OF
THE EIGHTY NINTH SEVENTY YOU
MAY PRESS ZERO AT THE TIME LINE
TO FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN-
BY GOOD AFTERNOON TOM
MCLAUGHLIN FORD MOTOR COMPANY
AT THE PORT. THANK YOU THANKS
THOMAS. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT NOT A MODERATOR WILL
BE BACK WITH YOU IN A SECOND
IT'S CHECKING TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE OPPOSED TO EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY FOR ASK YOU TO PLEASE
STAND AND I COME TOWARDS THE
PODIUM. SEE NO ONE KNOWS IN THE
REMAINS IS NOT COMING FORWARD
WE'RE GOING TO BE AT NOW ARE
COMING FORWARD AT TO TALK WITH
SOME CALLERS YA DRAWS OF DO YOU
WANT MORE COLORS YEAH YES MORE
CALLERS THERE WE GO. SO WE'RE
GOING TO CHECK IN- ON OUR
TELECONFERENCE WINE I DID BE
ABLE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION OF AB NINE
SEVENTY BETTER MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE GIVE THEM UP NOW.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE IN
CUBA START WITH LIKE ONE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHE
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
DAN CONKLIN WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES RESPECTIVELY
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEIGHMOND PRE SHEET THAT THAT'S
GOOD OUR NEXT CALLER. WHITE WON
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE
CAMERA WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU WE LOVE
OUR C. R. C. THAT'S GOT OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
BREEDER CAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS
JUST WANT TO MAKE A NOTE THAT
BE GOBIZ FORMATION OF OUR
KNOWLEDGE IS THAT THE TWENTY
DAY WINDOW THERE COULD BE A
VARIANCE BETWEN DC FAST
CHARGING AND OTHER ONES AND
THAT THEY SHOULD BE AWARE OF
THE LIFE SAFETY ISSUES.
IMPLICATED SO WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSING TO THE
BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY THIS
GOT OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY
NINETY SEVEN YEAR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KIANA
VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION ALSO REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SOMETIME
PRESHEAF DEBT THAT'S GOT OUR
NEXT CAR. AND THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE ON OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT
NOT A MODERATOR WILL BE BACK
WITH YOU HERE IN JUST A BIT
THAT'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
I WILL ALSO- BRING FORWARD
MOTION. WE GOT A MOTION RIGHT
THERE BY CENTER DRIVE SO LAST
CALL FOR DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
HERRN SEEN ON A SIMILAR MCCARTY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M I THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT THE BACK AND
FORTH DIALOGUE AND- WE THINK
THAT THIS- ADDRESSES THE KEY
ISSUES AND CONCERNS- I WE DID
TAKE YOUR AMENDMENT FOCUSING ON
THE LARGER PROJECTS AND- AND-
AS THE REPRESENT A FROM TESLA.
HAD ASKED. SOME LIKE THOSE
AREN'T A PRIORITIZE BUT THOSE
WILL BE AUTOMATICALLY.
STREAMLINED BECAUSE A LARGE
PROJECT MAYBE THERE ARE SOME
OTHER. BIG PLANNING ISSUES AND
THAT AND THE OTHER OPPONENT I
THINK TALKED ABOUT. SO THE LIFE
SAFETY LOGICAL ISSUES. THOSE
CAN STILL BE ADDRESS IT JUST
SAYS OF YOUR CITY AND YOU DO
NOTHING AND SIT ON IT FOR A-
FOR. A NUMBER OF WEEKS. THEN
THIS GOES FOR IT BUT IF YOU DO.
WANT TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE.
OTHER SIGNIFICANT ISSUES AND
YOU START YOU START WORKING ON
THE APPLICATION. AND THAT'S
KIND OF A NON ISSUE AND THAT
CAN BE- TAKING CARE LIKE A
NORMAL- PLANNING PROCESS FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE. WITH
THAT I ASK THE ARRIVAL TO HELP
US ADDRESS OUR- CLIMATE CHANGE
GOALS IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MR SOME OF THE MEN WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
CENTER DRIVE SO SHE IS A
DODGERS FAN THOUGH- AND- IN MY
RIGHT. HEY YEAH FIRST PLACE TO.
THE A PLACE. THE BEST RECORD
BEST IN BASEBALL HISTORY MEAN
YOU. LOOK AT. HEARING DRAWS A
CAREER WAS JUST ABOUT THE CHAIR
JANET RIGHT NOW YOU SEE THERE
YOU GO WATCH ALL RIGHT ALL
RIGHT SO WE GOT TO ON FLOOR
ALSO ON OCT YEARS- WE HAVE A
MOTION. THE FLOOR BY SENATOR A
MISTER NOW CAN YOU CALL THEM.
AND THE VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS A MAN. TO THE SENATE.
SENATE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE SENT
NEAL. MEALS NO SENATOR DO
DRAWS I SENATOR HEARD. SENATOR
SKINNER. TWO TO ONE AS TO ONE
OVER AGAIN I KEEP THAT OPEN
MCCARTY THANK YOU SO MUCH ALLOW.
THE MAJORITY LEADER AND
DISSENTERS SKINNER AT ANY IDEAS.
ALL RIGHT HEY THERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER MAYES
WE WELCOME USER I. SOME ROOM
AMAZES HERE THEN WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE IT SENT OVER CARILLO WE
APPRECIATE. SUMMER MEZA CENTER
CREUS PATIENTS TODAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH WITH HER A PACK DOCKET
AT WE HAVE AN IMPORTANT BILL
THAT'S IN FRONT OF US BY
SIMILAR MACE IS AB TEN TWENTY
ONE. AT FOCUS ON THE IMPERIAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT MR MAYS WE
APPRECIATE THE ONGOING DIALOGUE
ON THIS ISSUE NO THIS IS
IMPORTANT FOR YOU WE'VE ALSO
HAD THE OPPOSITE THEY
OPPORTUNITY TO SIT DOWN WITH
THEIR CATION DISTRICT- AND
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK SURE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS NOW THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR AND- A SENATORS.
SETS OF PLEASURE FOR ME TO BE
ABLE TO. SENT YOU A- TEND TO
ONE. A SIMPLE THIS BILL- AS
AMENDED WOULD ADD ONE NON
VOTING MEMBER TO THE- NATION
DISTRICT BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
AND ALSO COMMISSIONED A STUDY
TO HELP DETERMINE. YOUR GEISHA
DISTRICTS GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE.
WHILE ALSO ENSURING ELECTRICAL
SERVICE TO THE COACHELLA
VALLEY. AND NAY IN PERPETUITY
AND INSTEAD OF READING OF THE
SCRIPT I KNOW THIS A BILL VERY
WELL BEEN WORKING OUT FOR
SEVERAL YEARS- MISTER TEARS YOU
KNOW AND YOU'VE SPENT A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME ON THIS OUT AS
WELL. THAT DEMOCRACY- IS
FUNDAMENTAL- TO US IN THIS
COUNTRY- A DEMOCRACY- IS
SACRED. WE BELIEVE IN IN GOOD
GOVERNMENT WE BELIEVE IN. A ONE
PERSON ONE VOTE- AND WE BELIEVE
THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE
STRUCTURED- A BY THE PEOPLE-
AND REALLY THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL. IS IT IS ALL ABOUT WE CAN
GET INTO SOME OF THE DETAILS-
AS WE- AS WE WORK THROUGH IT
BUT- SIMPLY WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A- A LOCAL
PROCESS. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS. A PROPER
REPRESENTATION. ARE THAT
ULTIMATELY THERE IS
PROPORTIONAL REPRESENTATION FOR
THE ELECTRICAL SERVICES AREA
AND THAT'S WHAT. THIS BILL IS
ALL ABOUT LOOK FOR THE DIALOGUE
AND THE DISCUSSION- MISTER
TERRIBLE MOVE- TO- TO THE NEXT
STEP. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MEMBER KNOW THAT WE'LL HAVE.
SOME DISCUSSION HERE TODAY IN
COMMITTEE VERY GRATEFUL TO
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN. THAT WE
DO HAVE ONE LEAD. SUPPORT
WITNESS ON RECORD TODAY THAT'S
GOT WET SHE'S REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION.
OF ELECTRICAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA STATE PRIDE AT STAKE
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL. IN THE
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET
METAL WORKERS. MISTER WHICH WE
WELCOME YOU TO GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCER YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
WE'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT IN SUPPORT. OF AB. TEN
TWENTY ONE PLEASE PROCEED. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA DO A SECOND
CALL TO SEE IF WE HAD MISTER
WATCH ON THE LINE. LOOKING AT
ITSELF. NOPE ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA COME BACK WE WILL- MISTER
SOME WOMEN WILL HAVE MISTER
WHICH GET ON THE LINE AS SOON
AS HE JOINS US. SO WHAT WE LIKE
pTO BE ABLE TO DO IS THIS-
COMMITTEE IS THAT- WE WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO NOW GO TO
OUR LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WE NEED TO TAKE FOLKS OUT OF
ORDER. IF THAT'S APPROPRIATE
FOR THE SIMPLY MEMBER- IN SO
LET'S GO TO OUR LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS. AT FIRST AND FOREMOST
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM HENRY
MARTINEZ. HE IS THE IMPERIAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT GENERAL
MANAGER WITHIN CAN HEAR FROM
PAMELA MILLER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF. LEFT
COAST SO FIRST AND FOREMOST
MISTER MARTINEZ GENERAL MANAGER
OF THE DISTRICT YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT THE
FLOOR'S YOURS MISTER MARTINEZ.
WHAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HE
KNOWS THAT I AM THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE IMPERIAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT. AND OFFER
THE FOLLOWING TESTIMONY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB TEN
TWENTY ONE. IN SHORT THIS BILL
JEOPARDIZES OUR YOU'D IMPORTANT
BATTLE WATER RIGHTS. SECOND
DESTRUCTS THE ENERGY LEASE
PROVISIONS CAREFULLY CRAFTED IN
THE COMPROMISE AGREEMENT THAT
EXISTS TODAY BETWEEN IT AND THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT.
AND ALLOW SOME EX OFFICIAL
BOARD MEMBER WHO RESIDES
OUTSIDE THE DISTRICT'S WATER
BOUNDARIES TO PARTICIPATE IN
EXECUTIVE SSSIONS ON ALL LOOK
GOOD FOR A DISTRICT MATTERS
DESPITE IDEAS ONLY PROVIDING
ENERGY. SERVICES BURKE CHAU
VALLEY. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES
INTRODUCED SIMILAR LEGISLATION.
THAT'S RESULT IDEA MADE A
COMMITMENT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THAT WOULD INITIATE A DIALOGUE
WITH THE AUTHOR ANGELA VALUE
STAKEHOLDERS. RECEIVE
MEANINGFUL INPUT ADDRESS
CONCERNS AND DETERMINE THE
FUTURE OF THIS ENERGY SERVICE
IN THE COMMUNITY. I ALREADY HAS
KEPT COMMITMENTS ROLLED UP HIS
SLEEVES. AND PRODUCED A LOCAL
ALTERNATIVE TO A BABY TEN
TWENTY ONE. SINCE THE TABLE KEY
STAKEHOLDERS TO BEGIN
ADDRESSING THE TOUGH QUESTIONS
RELATED TO IDEAS CONTINUE
SERVICE AND GOVERNANCE. THAT IS
WHY WILL BE ON JUNE FIRST B. R.
A. D. BOARD OF DIRECTORS- THE
REST OF THE DAY ARE RESOLUTION
THE CREATION OF THE COACHELLA
VALLEY ENERGY COMMISSION.
ELEVATE THE VOICES THAT SHOW
ABOUT THE RATE PAYERS ON ENERGY
RELATED MATTERS. ALSO FOLLOW UP
ACTION THE IDEA BOARDS WILL BE
BOARDING NEXT TUESDAY IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY. TO ADOPT THE
BY LAWS OF THE NEW LOCALLY LED
COMMISSION. THE COMMISSION
PROVIDES NINE POINTS
REPRESENTATION OFFERED ME A A.
B. TEN TWENTY ONE. AM FOCUSES
SOLELY ON PATROL HIS ENERGY
SPECIFIC. REMOVING A THREAT OF
ID'S WATER RIGHTS THIRTY
SECONDS FURTHERMORE. WABCO
PROVIDES INFORMAL VOCAL PROCESS
TO ADDRESS QUESTIONS RELATED TO
DISTRICT BOUNDARIES ANNEXATIONS
OR EXTENSIONS OF SERVICE OR NOT
RELEVANT TOPICS TO BE
CONSIDERED WHEN LOOKING. AT THE
ARRANGEMENTS THAT EXIST TODAY
BETWEEN THE IDEA CHANNEL VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT. WE MUST USE THE
TOOLS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CREATED UNDER THE- JEEZ KNOCKS
FIRST WORK ACT THE BEST
ADDRESSES ISSUES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RATHER THAN
CIRCUMVENTING A PROCESS AS
OPPOSED BY AB TWENTY. TWENTY
ONE. THE BILL ALSO- OPPOSED BY
THOSE ALSO POSED BY MARCH
COALITION INCLUDING WATER
AGENCIES SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
PUBLIC POWER BOOKS REPRESENT
THEIR CULTURE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BY THE BUREAU
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
APPROVE COUNTY LAST GOLDEN VERY
CITIES WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU CAN
CLEAN CLOSING IDEAS LONGER
PAUSES MAYBE TEN TWENTY ONE.
BUT WILL REMAIN COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES ANQUETIL
ABOUT THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
CONTINUE MOVING THIS DIALOGUE
FORWARD AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF ALL
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MARTINEZ WE APPRECIATE
THAT IF. WE DO HAVE THIS OR
WHAT'S COMING- WE WENT ALMOST
ABOUT THREE MINUTES WILL GIVE
EQUAL TIME TO MISTER WHICH
WE'RE GONNA NOW TURN IT OVER
TO. MISS MILLER REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSION- ACTUALLY NOTICED
LASKO MISS MILLER WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE YOU. HAVE TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US. OUR AFTERNOON BY
COMMITTEE I AM HIM ON. SPEAKING
TODAY BEHALF THE COUNT
ASSOCIATION. A LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSION OTHERWISE
NON ITALIC. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL AND FOR
NOW NOT RESPECTFULLY RETAIN
THAT POSITION AND ALLOW ME TO
EXPLAIN WHY EACH OUR CONCERN
BEFORE THE JULY FIRST AMENDMENT
WHAT THE PRESIDENT SPENDING
NATURE OF MANDATING LASKO TO
CONDUCT CONDUCT THE STUDY
WITHOUT FUNDING. AND THE IMPACT
THAT WOULD HAVE- THAT PRESIDENT
WOULD HAVE ON ALL LASKO. I
UNDERSTAND THAT THROUGH A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL FUNDING HAS
BEEN APPROPRIATED AND WE WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER- MAYES.
FOR ALL OF ITS WORK IN MAKING
THAT A PRIORITY AND MAKING THAT
APPROPRIATIONS HAPPEN.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT THEY ONLY BE
TRYING AT TEN TWENTY ONE RIGHT
NOW THAT'S NOT CURRENTLY
ADDRESSED HOW AND WHEN THE
FUNDING WILL BE PROVIDED BY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. BUT BOTH THE
IMPERIAL AND RIVERSIDE LACK.
RECENTLY ADDED URGENCY CLASS
CUT THE FULL YEAR OFF THE
TIMELINE ALASKA CAN CONDUCT THE
STUDY AND WITHOUT AN EXPLICITLY
DEFINED ALLOCATION PROCESS AND
TIMELINE FOR DISTRIBUTION OF
THAT FUNDING. IT IN ESSENCE
STILL MANDATE THE STUDY WITHOUT
THE FUNDING IN HAND AND SO
ALTHOUGH THERE FUNDING IS
APPROPRIATED REQUIRING THE LACK
OF TO DO THE STUDY WITHOUT AN
IMPLANT. IS STILL A PRECEDENT.
SETTING MANDATE THAT IS OF
GREAT CONCERN TO CALICO. GIVEN
THE LIMITED BUDGET ALL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE EXPERIENCING
RIGHT NOW WITH THE JUST. THE
TIMELINE CLOCK FOR THE STUDY
START WHEN ALASKANS RECEIVE THE
FUNDING AND WANT TO ENSURE THE
TIME FRAME IS REASONABLE. WE
ARE HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF.
HAVE BEEN VERY WILLING TO WORK
WITH THAT SO FAR AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT ON LANGUAGE
DURING THE BREAK THAT'LL
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS MILLER
APPRECIATE THAT IN AS ALWAYS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
ALRIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE
ARE GOING TO SEE IF WE HAVE
MISTER WHAT JOHN NOT YET ALL
RIGHT. SO WE WILL STAND BY ON
ALL ISSUES- FOR MISTER WHICH SO
LET'S DO THIS LAYS IN GERMAN
WE'RE GOING TO FIRST GO TO
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE IS OUR- NEXT PROCESS
FOR TESTIMONY. IF YOU ARE
SUPPORT PLEASE RISE SIGNON
RISING ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE AT YOU CAN
DIAL. 877-226-8189 NINE IN THE
BILL TO BE ABLE TO TALK WITH
US. GIVE US YOUR OPINION WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
YOU AT NOT A MODERATOR THAT'S
QUEUE UP ALL FOLKS WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT IN SUPPORT OF. AB TEN
TO ONE NOW. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OF THE PORT OF EIGHTY TEN
TWENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO AT THE TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS. ONE ZERO
FOR EIGHTY TEN TWENTY ONE. AND
I SHOW NO ONE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND A MODERATOR
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO THOSE
WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION- WE
ARE GOING TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE WHO'D LIKE TO RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TEN TO ONE
PLEASE DO SO NOW. SEE NO ONE
RISE AT WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO
TO OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE
WE'RE GONNA SAY GOOD AFTERNOON
ONCE AGAIN TO MADAME MODERATOR
METAMASK MODERATOR. PLEASE
QUEUE UP ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAY BE IN OPPOSITION TO TEN TO
ONE. NOW LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN TWENTY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AT
THIS TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE A THREE INCH YOU WILL
START WITH WINE TWO EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
AND GOOD AFTERNOON- MISTER
CHAIR SENATORS MY NAME'S
ANTHONY TALENT ALONG WITH. THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION AND I ALSO HAVE
PORTFOLIO TODAY TO SPEAK FOR
THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION. AND WE
ARE ABOUT REMAINING IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH TEN HELP RESHAPE THAT
THANKS FOR CALLING IN THAT'S
GOT OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
TWO FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES THIS IS REBECCA
TRUSTED BAXTER AND ON BEHALF OF
THE IMPERIAL COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE ASK FOR A NO
VOTE ON AB TEN TWENTY TEN
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU REBEKAH
APPRECIATE THAT LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
JULIA HALL WITH THE PHYSICIAN
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
ONE TWO EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MARIO DIBERNARDO ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU MARIO NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
OPPOSING THE BILL ALL RIGHT TO
LAYS IN GERMAN I COULD BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MISTER
VICE CHAIR PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR. THANK YOU.
THURMOND COLLEGE. HAVE AN
REPRESENTED NINETEEN COUNTIES
OVER THE YEARS I THINK IT'S
SAFE TO SAY I REPRESENTED
MORTAR GUESSING DISTRICT RCTS
WE STARK CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
THAN ANYBODY. AND LOWER THEIR
FAR AWAY FROM ME I'M NOT
UNFAMILIAR WITH IMPERIAL COUNTY
UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES WITH WATER.
AND THEIR ID'S. AND I MUST TELL
YOU THIS IS VERY DANGEROUS A
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT. THE.
PERSON THAT THIS DESIRE SUPPORT
ON THE BOARD IS NOT A VOTING
MEMBER AT LEAST THAT'S SAVING
GRACE. BUT PUTTING THAT PERSON
INTO CLOSED SESSION HAS A HUGE
PROBLEM. ENDED SEPT EIGHT
STRAORDINARIO A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT. AND I'M NOT I'M
FAMILIAR WITH THAT HISTORIC
ISSUE THAT HAS KIND OF BECAUSE
THIS IS THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
IRRIGATION DISTRICT FOR EXAMPLE
THAT PROVIDE ENERGY. THEY HAVE.
OF GENERATORS AND- AND THEY
THEY PROVIDE ENERGY. BUT TO
INVOLVE OTHER PARTIES THERE'S A
MUCH BETTER WAY TO DO THIS THEN
IF YOU WILL PUT. THE PERSON WHO
COULD BE CONSTRUED AS A SPY
WITHIN THAT CLOSE SESSION. WAY
BACK IN THE MID EIGHTIES TO
DEAL WITH SOMETHING FAR GREATER
THAN THIS. THE WHOLE SACRAMENTO
RIVER. I AUTHORED LEGISLATION
CREATING WHAT BECAME THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER CONSERVATION
FOR. THAT WAS ALSO A PATTERN
FOR WHAT BECAME CALVET DEALING
WITH THE DEATH. BUT IT IS ALSO
SIMILAR TO WHAT IMPERIAL COUNTY
IRRIGATION DISTRICT HAS DONE TO
DEAL WITH GIVING OTHER INPUT.
ON THESE ISSUES THAT AFFECT
OTHER AREAS SUCH AS RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. THE GREAT SUCCESS OF
THAT LEGISLATION THAT
CONTRIBUTION FORM IS STILL
AROUND. AND IN FACT THE SECTOR
OF RESOURCES ACTUALLY CHAIRS
AND ATTEND THE MEETINGS ALL OF
THE TIME. AND WHAT IS THAT
ALLOWED YEARS AGO THE
CONVERSATION IN THE EMPLOY OF
THE VARIOUS TETRIS INCLUDING
ALL OF THE AGENCIES ARE STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THEY HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH. COMMUNICATING AND
COORDINATING AND EXCHANGING
INFORMATION. THAT KIND OF
LEGISLATION WOULD BE A GOOD
IDEA AND I WOULD SUGGEST AFTER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MASON I WOULD
HELP HIM OUT WITH THE YOU KNOW
HOW YOU DO THAT. THAT WOULD BE
WHAT I WOULD SUGGEST AS AN
ALTERNATIVE. MISTER ROGERS
THANK YOU MISTER VENTURE WOULD
IT BE APPROPRIATE WITH YOU- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WE HAVE
THE LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS. ON
THE LINE IN BECAUSE WE HEARD
FROM OUR TO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WOULD IT BE ALRIGHT
IF WE OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND THEN- MR MAYS IF YOU'D BE
ALRIGHT IS. WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
LEAD TO POOR WITNESS WHO GETS
TWO MINUTES AND FIFTY SECONDS
BASED OFF OF. WHAT I'M THE
GENERAL MANAGER MISTER MARTINEZ
RECEIVED JUST TWO IN EQUAL
TIME- IN IN ESTIMATES IF YOU
COULD IN ADDRESS A VICE CHAIRS-
CONCERNS ANY ADVANCE ALL RIGHT.
SO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE WE'RE GOING TO BRING
ON SCOTT WHICH SCOTT WHICH
AGAIN IS REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
ELECTRICAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
ST PATRICK'S COUNSEL IN THE
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL FOR
SHIPMENT WORKERS. MISTER WHICH
DO GET EQUAL TIME YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES AND FIFTY SECONDS THE
FLOOR IS YOURS AND WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE. IN SUPPORT OF
AB TEN TWENTY ONE. HELLO MISTER
HERE THANK YOU IN ADDITION TO
THOSE CLIENTS I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
REPRESENT THE EMPLOYEES OF THE-
GEISHA DISTRICT IT'S BEEN OUR
EXPERIENCE AND IDEALLY MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THAT THIS
IS A CLASSIC PROBABLY THE MOST
OUTRAGEOUS EXAMPLE OF.
ACTIVATION WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION WHEN YOU HAVE A
MAJORITY OF RATEPAYERS LIVING
IN A COUNTY. WHERE THEY HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO VOICE. WITH THE
BOARD DID IS DETERMINING THE
RATES OF THEY'RE GONNA PAY FOR
ELECTRICITY. MY MEMBERS ARE
INUNDATED WITH PHONE CALLS
CONSTANTLY. BY RATE PAYERS IN
RIVERSIDE WHO HAVE ISSUES WITH
THE UTILITY SERVICE AND YET
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE NO
RECOURSE BECAUSE THEY HAVE. NO
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES THAT
THEY CAN APPROACH. WE FEEL THAT
THE I. B. W. IN THE AND THE
WORKERS THAT WE REPRESENT ID
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
STATE GET THEIR ARMS AROUND
THIS INJUSTICE IS GOING ON. IN
THE KATELLA VALLEY. IN THAT- TO
THE POINT OF THE VICE CHAIR
WITH WITH ALL DUE RESPECT.
THERE'S MANY EXAMPLES IN STATE
GOVERNMENT. WE HAVE NON VOTING
MEMBERS WHO SIT. IN IN CLOSED
SESSION ALL THE TIME THERE'S
NONVOTING MEMBERS ON THE- ISSUE
BORDER TRUSTEES ON THE UC
REGENTS ON THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION. THIS IS NOT
AN UNCOMMON PRACTICE THERE'S
LEGAL RESPONSIBILITIES AND-
LIABILITIES THAT COME WITH
BEING ON A BOARD IN MAINTAINING
CONFIDENTIALITY. BUT IF THERE'S
OTHER PROTECTIONS THAT NEED TO
BE AMENDED INTO THIS BILL
SURELY WE CAN WORK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF TO DO THAT BUT
I WOULD JUST URGE THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO REALLY THINK ABOUT.
THE RATE PAYERS. WHO SIT THERE
AND ARE HAVING POLICIES IN IN
IN. MIKE REALLY SIGNIFICANT
DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
PAYING FOR ELECTRICITY IN THE
SERVICES THAT THEY RECEIVE
WITHOUT HAVING ANY
REPRESENTATION SO WE WERE JUST
URGE AND I VOTE TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD AND CONTINUE TO
WORK ON IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER WHICH
I MISTER WHICH BEGIN IN SUPPORT
OF AB TEN TO ONE TODAY ALL
RIGHT LASERJET COMMITTEE WERE
IN TURN OVER SOME REMAINS SOME
REMAINS IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF DANCE
FOR THE VICE CHAIR THANKS AS
WELL. MISTER VICE CHAIR AND
SENATOR A GOOD TO SEE YOU- I DO
NOT IN FACT I'D LOVE TO BE ABLE
TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU ON THIS
YEAR YOU'VE HAD- NOT YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE- IN IN STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAD DECADES OF
EXPERIENCE IN A IN STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT I AND YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW SOME OF
THESE THINGS THAT FOR OTHERS
LIKE WHAT'S THIS ALL ABOUT
WHAT'S THIS ALL ABOUT. WELL
WHAT THIS IS- IS ABOUT THIS
SITUATIO OF AN AGREEMENT THAT
WAS THAT WAS ADOPTED OVER
NINETY WELL ABOUT NINETY YEARS
AGO WHEN THINGS WERE MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN THEY ARE TODAY
WE NOW HAVE A SITUATION IN
WHICH AN IMPERIAL ARE THE OF
THE PILLAR GEISHA DISTRICT THIS
YEAR GEISHA DISTRICT ONE FOR
PROVIDING JUST WATER DID TO
PROVIDING WATER AND POWER IN
THIS ELECTRICAL SERVICES AREA.
THERE THE REVENUES THAT ARE
GENERATED- IN THAT NOT FOR
THAT- THAT DISTRICTS ARE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS OF ENERGY AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN WATER IT'S
ARGUABLE NOW THERE AND ENERGY
COMPANY AND WATER IS SECONDARY
I DON'T WANT TO SUGGEST YOU
THOUGH THAT WATER IS A
DECEPTIVE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
IT IS IN FACT IT IS A LIFE FOR
THE PEOPLE IMPERIAL COUNTY IF
THEY DON'T HAVE WATER AND THEY
DON'T GET THEIR ALLOCATION OF
WATER THAN THEY DON'T SURVIVE-
THAT THAT LANGUAGE I'M NOT
MAKING THAT UP THAT'S NOT- YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT EXAGGERATED IT IS
REAL AND I'VE TOLD THEM OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN. BUT I
WILL FIGHT WITH THEM TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE SECURED THEIR
WATER BUT THE OTHER SIDE OF
THIS THOUGH THE OTHER SIDE OF
THIS THOUGH IS THAT 60% OF THE
PEOPLE THERE IN THEIR
ELECTRICAL SERVICE. AREA DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT HAVE FOR
SOMEBODY. ON THEIR BORDER TO.
AND WE ALL GET THAT BECAUSE WE
ALL UNDERSTAND GOVERNMENT. THIS
IDEA THAT THEY MIGHT BY
MINORITY PART OF A GROUP GETS
THAT MAKE ALL THE DECISIONS
WITHOUT ANY INPUT. FROM THE
MAJORITY AND YOU ARE ALSO RIGHT
YOU ARE ALSO RIGHT. THAT ALL
THIS BILL DOES RIGHT NOW AS
IT'S CURRENTLY WRITTEN IS TO
PROVIDE A DELEGATE. TO THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO DEVOTE BUT WOULD BE
ABLE TO GET SOME INFORMATION.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH BECAUSE WE NEED
TO GET TOWARDS PROPORTIONAL
REPRESENTATION. BUT IT'S A STEP
IN THE RIGHT IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IF MISTER CHAIR IF I
CAN. I JUST SAY MAYBE REFERENCE
A COUPLE OF- OF THE OTHER.
FOLKS THAT ACCORDING TO MISTER
MARTINEZ THAT COLD. HOLDEN HE'S
BEEN WONDERFUL TO WORK WITH I
IN FACT. OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS- AS IT SITS TODAY HAS
ALSO BEEN WONDERFUL TO WORK
WITH AND I. WANT TO CONTINUE TO
KEEP WORKING WITH THEM IT IS A
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY. AND THEY
SERVE THE SAME PEOPLE THAT THAT
I SERVED AS A LOT MORE WORK TO
DO IN THIS SPACE. THIS IS JUST
ONE STEP. ALONG THE ROAD. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR GRATEFUL FOR
THAT I HAVE SOME VERY QUICK
COMMENTS BUT BEFORE I MAKE THEM
I WANNA CHECK IN WITH US IN OUR
DRESSING ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THERE IS A MOTION
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE DO HAVE
EMOTIONAL- BY SENATOR ALSO.
LOOK AT. I UNDERSTAND HOW
CHALLENGING IN. HISTORIES ALONG
WITH THIS ISSUE- AND I KNOW I'M
NOT A NEWCOMER IN- TO THIS
ISSUE- BUT- I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERN IN WHICH AS A MEMBER
MAYES IS BRINGING FORWARD. JUST
BEING CANDID- IF THIS WAS AN
AREA THAT I REPRESENT. AND 60%
OF THE BUSINESS. IS IN AN AREA
WHERE THERE IS NO VOICE TO
CONSTITUENTS I MEAN THAT'S JUST
NOT ACCEPTABLE RIGHT. I MEAN
TRULY IF- I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
DISTRICT IS WORKING ON THAT AND
VERY GRATEFUL- BUT THIS IS BEEN
A LONG STANDING CHALLENGE THAT
NEEDS TO BE FIXED. SO WHETHER
THAT IS ULTIMATELY HOME RULE.
WHERE DOES IN RIVERSIDE CONTROL
THEIR OWN DESTINY WHEN IT COMES
TO POWER THERE'S SOME TYPE OF
SHARED- POWER IN GOVERNANCE AT
BETWEEN RIVERSIDE IN IMPERIAL
COUNTY WHATEVER THAT MODEL MAY
BE- IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE GET
THERE AND WE GET THERE SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER. AND ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT RIVERSIDE YOU
SEEN INCREDIBLE GROWTH AT WHICH
IS WHY WE SEEN A SHIFT IN OUT
WHERE THE POWER LOAD HENCE THE
CONSTITUENTS ARE LOCATED. BUT
THERE THERE ARE VERY FEW AREAS
IN THE STATE. WHERE THERE IS
SUCH A GAP WHEN IT COMES TO
REPRESENTATION JUST BEING
CANDID ABOUT IT. NOT TRYING TO
THROW STONES BUT SIMPLY SAYING
WE HAVE TO FIX IT- AND KNOW
THAT THE DISTRICT IS WORKING ON
IT- AND AS A MEMBER MAYES HAS
BEEN A CHAMPION FOR IT. SO I
KNOW THAT THIS IS- I'LL SAY
THERE'S A LOT MORE TO COME. A
LOT MORE CONVERSATION AND
HOPEFULLY A LONG TERM SOLUTION
WE LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO YOU FOR A CLOSE. BY
ALMOST ONE- THAT MAKE THAT MY
CLOTHES BECAUSE I THINK YOU YOU
HAD A VERY WELL MISTER CHAIR
THE ONLY OTHER THING I WOULD
SUGGEST- IS TO- MRS MILLER WHO
I'VE WORKED WITH A LOT IN THE
PAST. WE DO HAVE EIGHT EIGHT A
LOCAL PROCESS THEIR ALLAFRICA
AGENCIES AND WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO IS HAVE THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY LAUGHED HILDA IMPERIAL
COUNTY EL AFTER WORK TOGETHER
WE HAVE FOUND SOME SOME FUNDING
FOR BUT YOU'VE YOU'VE GOT SOME
VERY GOOD SUGGESTIONS. OTHER
LIKE TO INCORPORATE SO WILL
WILL WORK WITH THOSE WHO ARE
OPPOSED. WILL OF COURSE
CONTINUE TO KEEP WORKING WE YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE.
AS WE ARE AT WE PER- AND WITH
THAT THE TO FOR TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH IN THERE
WE LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH ALL
SIDES YOURSELF TO DISTRICT. HI
AS THIS MOVES FORWARD OF COURSE
ALL RIGHT. SO LAYS IN GERMAN WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
CENTER DRIVE TO THINK SO MUCH
OR DRAWS SO. THAT WE ARE GOING
TO CALL FOR THE MOTION AND CALL
FOR THE VOTE BY MR NOW. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR MCGUIRE
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN KNOWS SENATOR
DORADO. DORADO A SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR SKINNER TWO
TO ONE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS YOU WANT BUT WE'RE KEEP
THAT BILL OPEN LAYS IN GERMAN
AND WE ALLOWED ALLOW FOLKS AT
ON. ALL RIGHT. LET'S BRING ON
AS A MEMBER CARILLO- I GUESS A
CENTER DRESSES IN THE
RECRUITERS ARE WORKING REALLY
HARD ON THIS ISSUE- IT ALL
STARTED WITH THE ISSUE OF
STRAWS AND NOW TRULY GETTING
DEEPER INTO THIS ISSUE WHEN IT
COMES TO. SINGLE USE HUNDRED
ACCESSORIES APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
CORREOS FOCUS ON THIS- IT'S
CRITICAL- ESPECIALLY AS WE COME
OUT OF THE PANDEMIC IS A MEMBER
RIGHT AS WE SEE AN INCREASE OF
I TAKE OUT ACROSS THE STATE IN
USE OF DISPOSABLE- A MEAL WHERE
SO WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
YOU AS A MEMBER THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AS A PROUD
DOCTORS FOUND. THE PROUD TO
PRESENT A FAMILY OF. TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX- A MEASURE THAT
WILL BUILD ON CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING EFFORTS TO COMBAT
SINGLE USE PLASTIC AN ITEM WAS
WASTE WHICH HAS BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE COLD IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND REDUCE
UNNECESSARY COSTS FOR
BUSINESSES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS GOVERNMENT EVERY
YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES AN
ESTIMATED FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO BILLION DISPOSABLE
FOOD WHERE ITEMS ARE USED
RESULTING IN A MASSIVE FOUR
POINT NINE MILLION TONS OF
WASTE UNUSED FOOD ACCESSORIES
INCLUDED PENCILS STRAWS
NAPKINS. KAHNEMAN PACKAGES THEY
CLOG OUR LANDFILL THEY
COMPLICATE RECYCLING AND
POLLUTES STREETS AND WATERWAYS
AND OUR COMMUNITIES AS WE HAVE
WITNESSED THE PANDEMIC HAS
INCREASED THE RELIANCE ON TAKE
OUT FOOD AND DELIVERY WHICH
RESTAURANTS HAVE RELIED UPON TO
STAY AFLOAT AS SUCH THE USE OF
SINGLE USE FOOD ACCESSORIES HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO AN APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED AND 523100%
INCREASE IN SINGLE USE PLASTIC
THAN A 30% INCREASE IN WASTE
TODAY MANY FOOD FACILITIES AND
FOOD DELIVERY SERVICES PROVIDE
SINGLE USE FOOD AND BEVERAGE
ACCESSORIES REGARDLESS. OF
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE NEEDED
MOST CONSUMERS DO NOT WANT THEM
AND ARE ALREADY AND ALREADY
HAVE A USABLE ITEMS AT HOME OR
IN THEIR WORKPLACE IN THE END
THE SUCCESSOR IN THESE
UNNECESSARY ACCESSORIES ARE
DISCARDED WITHOUT EVEN BEING
USED IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AB TEL SEVENTY SIX
EXPANDS THE PLASTIC STRAWS BY
REQUEST LAW TO INCLUDE OTHER
SINGLE USE WITH ACCESSORIES
MORE FOOD FACILITIES AND THIRD
PARTY DELIVERY PLATFORMS
INCLUDING FOOD THAT IS TAKING
AWAY DELIVERED OR SERVED ON
SITE. THIS IS A WASTE REDUCTION
MEASURE THAT REDUCES WASTE
UPSTREAM BEFORE IT'S EVEN
CREATED EXPERTS AGREE THAT THAT
SOURCE REDUCTION OF UNNECESSARY
SINGLE USE ITEMS IS BY FAR TE
MOST EFFICIENT AND COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO PROTECT
RESOURCES IN COMMUNITIES AND
HELP CALIFORNIA REACH IS A
WASTE REDUCTION AND CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS IT SAVES
BUSINESSES MONEY IT RELIEVES
RECYCLERS COMPOSTERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FROM THE
COMPLICATIONS AND COSTS THAT
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH IT
RESTAURANTS IN THE US SPEND
ROUGHLY NINETEEN BILLION
DOLLARS WITH. B. PURCHASING THE-
FOOD WHERE ITEMS IN CALIFORNIA
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SPENT OVER
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. AND
ONGOINGEFFORTS TO CLEAN UP AND
PREVENT LITTERING THE STREETS
STORM DRAINS PARKS AND
WATERWAYS MANY OF THESE FOOD
ACCESSORIES ARE MADE OF
PLASTIC. AND PLASTIC PRODUCTION
EMITS GREENHOUSE GASES AND
HARMS INDIVIDUALS AND
COMMUNITIES NEAR OLD REFINERIES
PLASTIC PRODUCTION FACILITIES.
AND LANDFILLS OR INCINERATORS.
BE INCREASING SURGE IN THE USE
OF THIS MATERIAL EXACERBATES
HEALTH PRESS PREDOMINATELY AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THIS CREDIT ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT I HAVE COME TO AN
AGREEMENT. WITH THE AMERICAN
FORCING PAPER ASSOCIATION AND
WILL BE INCLUSIVE A CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS AND THE NEXT
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE STAF THE SPONSORS
YOURSELF MISTER CHAIR FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. AVAILABLE
TO TESTIFY ARE WE TO KAMPALA
THE- ASSISTANT ABILITY PROGRAM
DIRECTOR WIH THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES THANK AND CLAUDIA BILL
THAT OPINION THE MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF THOUSAND OAKS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER CREE
ALL RIGHT SO HERE WE GO LET'S
GET TO OUR TWO LEAD TO- SUPPORT
WITNESSES WE'RE GONNA START
WITH THE MAYOR AND THOUSAND
OAKS. MAYOR BILL DE LA PENA IS
ON THE LINE THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND MADAM MAYOR FOR JOINING US
METAM THERE WHAT DO YOU LEAD A
SOFT TO MINUTES- IN WILL GIVE
YOU A THIRTY SECOND PROMPTED
YOU GET CLOSE TO THOSE TWO
MINUTES. THEN WE'RE GONNA GO TO
READ IT REPRESENT THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES MADAM MAYOR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. YOU'RE NOW IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
QUALITY OF BUILD AN OPINION OF
THE MAYOR OF THOUSAND OAKS. I
AM PLEASED TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX. AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX IS.
A VERY IMPORTANT STEP IN
REDUCING CLASS. IN OUR
LANDFILLS. IT WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA REACH ITS AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE GOAL BY ELIMINATING
AUTOMATIC SINGLE YOUR SERVICE
WHERE WITH FOOD ORDERS.
THOUSAND OAKS PRO ACTIVELY
PASSED A LAW LAST OCTOBER. TO
CUT SINGLE USE WASTE. OUR
ORDINANCE BAN ONE TIME USE OF
POLYSTYRENE UTENSIL. BRIDGET
AND EXPANDED POLYSTYRENE
CONTAINERS. M. IT RESTRICT THE
AUTOMATIC DISTRIBUTION OF
SINGLE USE STRAWS AND UTENSILS.
SHOULD WE ACT AT THE LAW AFTER
A- SIX MONTH STUDY OF BIG AND
SMALL RESTAURANTS BUSINESSES
WITH EMPLOYEE CAFETERIA. THE
LOCAL HOSPITAL LOCAL
UNIVERSITY. AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. THOUSAND OAKS OR IS
SIMILAR TO A TWELVE SEVENTY SIX
WITH LIKE DIFFERENCES THAT JAZZ
RESTAURANT MUST ASK IF
CUSTOMERS WANT SINGLE USE
UTENSILS. THIRD PARTY THROUGH
PLATFORMS ARE EXEMPTED BECAUSE
DELIVERY ORDERS ARE OFTEN
OUTSIDE CITY LIMITS AND MAJOR
INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS OUR
HOSPITAL LOCAL UNIVERSITY MUST
PARTICIPATE WE SUPPORT AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX BECAUSE IT
WOULD TAKE OUR OWN ORDINANCE
FURTHER BY UNIVERSALLY
EXPANDING THE UPON REQUEST
LONG. TO INCLUDE THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY PLATFORMS ADDITIONAL
SINGLE USE FOOD ACCESSORIES.
EXPANDING THE FOOD PROVIDERS
COVERED SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE
MEMBER CAREERS LEADERSHIP ON
THANK YOU BILL AND WE ASK YOU
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU MADAM MAYOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TAKING TIME OUT OF
YOUR BUSY SCHEDULE ON A
THURSDAY TO JOIN US HERE IN
COMMITTEE IT MEANS A LOT THANK
YOU SO MUCH- MADAM MAYOR FOR
THE CITY OF THOUSAND OAKS WERE
REALLY GRATEFUL WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE GOING TO READ A- THAT RITA
IS REPRESENTING- THIS COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES- THIS COME ALIVE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT. THANKS SO
MUCH AND GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
MCGUIRE AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ONCE AGAIN MY NAME IS READ A
COUPLE OF. THEM WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY TO
SUSTAINABILITY OFFICE. PROPERTY
BE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY. BOARD OF EIGHTY TWELVE
NINETY SIX. THE COUNTY OF LA
SPENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS MANAGING LITTER.
MUCH OF A CLASSIC WHICH IMPACT
OUR WATER WE'VE NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND ALSO PRESENTS A GROWING
CHALLENGE FOR RECYCLING. IN
LAST YEAR'S MINUTES BEEN
MENTIONED EARLIER THIS PROBLEM
IS ONLY INCREASED ABUSE OF THE
RESERVES HAVE GROWN DURING THE
PANDEMIC. BECAUSE OF THESE
ONGOING CHALLENGES THE COUNTY
OF LONG BEEN ENGAGED IN EFFORTS
TO REDUCE SINGLE USE PLASTIC
WHITE. MOST RECENTLY ON JUNE
EIGHT. THE BOARD OF UPERVISORS
ADOPTED AND ACCESSORIES ONE
REPUBLICAN AND- THAT APPLIES TO
THE UNINCORPORATED PORTIONS OF
L. A. COUNTY. AND WHICH WERE
PLEASED AS WELL ALIGNED WITH AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX. A FEW
CITIES IN THE COUNTY INCLUDING
THE CITY OF LA. ADOPTED OR ARE
CONSIDERING IF THE WAR WERE
NOT. WELL SO I'D LIKE TO SHARE
TWO COMMON THEMES THAT CAME UP
AS WE WERE TALKING TO
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT OUR ORDER.
THE FIRST WAS THAT THIS POLICY
IS A COMMON SENSE APPROACH THAT
REALLY WILL BENEFIT CUSTOMERS
AND RESTAURANT LIKE. THE OTHER
COMMON BE ME HEARD. WHAT THE
NEED AND DESIRE FOR CONSISTENCY
ACROSS HE REGION. AS MANY OF
YOU KOW OUR COUNTY CONSISTS OF
ET. IN ADDITION TO THE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS. IN THE
REGION CANNOT LOCATIONS IN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS. SERVE
CUSTOMERS FROM DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS THAT THEY'RE
LOCATED IN. AND SOMETIMES EVEN
BE UNSURE WHICH JURISDICTION
THERE IN. WHICH TO MAKE
COMPLIANCE CHALLENGING AND
CONFUSING. AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX WILL PROVIDE THIS
CONSISTENCY BY COVERING ALL THE
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY COVERED BY LOCAL
ORDINANCES. WHICH WILL AGAIN
HELP BUSINESSES. BUT ALSO HELP
US WITH ENORCEMENT. AND HELP
CUSTOMERS KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT.
WHEN THEY WANT KNOW THAT WE-
THE THAT. CURRENTLY THE BILL
WITH. TO AND OUR WORKING
ENFORCED IS DOING WE HANDLE BY
OUR- HEALTH AND PUBLIC. TO AND
DRAWS ON THE STRENGTH EXPERTS
OF EACH SO. DIFFERENT CLOTHING
A. COUNTY SUPPORT EIGHTY TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
IT WILL WORK. VERY WASTE. AND
SAVE BUSINESSES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MONEY THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR IPHONE
TODAY. THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE MISPRICED
HERE WE'RE GONNA HEAD TO OUR
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS- AND
HER NAME IS KATHY LYNCH MISS
LYNCH. REPRESENTS THE AMERICAN
FOREST AND PAPER ASSOCIATION.
MISS LYNCH WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE WE WELCOME YOUR TWO
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY IN WILL
GIVE YOU THIRTY SECONDS FROM
THE FLOOR IS YOURS MISS LYNCH
IN OPPOSITION. OF AB. TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA CHECK IN WITH MISS LYNCH
HERE AT MRS LYNCH MAY BE IN THE
SAME. PHONE OF MISTER WHICH.
ALL RIGHTS TO LETTERS IN GERMAN
WHAT DO WE DO THIS WE'RE GOING
TO COME BACK TO MISS LYNCH. IN
HERE MATE ALL RIGHT MISLINTAT
YOU DOING YOUR COMMITTEE HOW
YOU DOING. I GAVE MY SPEECH
ALREADY. HEY THERE YOU GO IT IS.
AFTERNOON TO MAKE YOU HAPPY AND
BE UNDER TWO MINUTES- THANK
YOU- RENDON REQUIRE MEMBERS TO
MANY I AM HAPPY WENT
REPRESENTING AMERICAN FOR YOUR
PAPER AT THAT THE INSURANCE BUT
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
STAFF IN THE SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH US TO TAKE AN
AMENDMENT- AND NEXT COMMITTEE
TO AMEND SECTION. FOUR TWO TWO
SEVEN ONE TO CLARIFY ON THE
SINGLE YOU ARE HEALTH SERVICE
NAPKIN DISPENSERS. FOR THE
MAJOR IN THE PAPER INDUSTRY. HI
RECOVERY. AND WE CONTENT. AND
WE DO SEE NOW. AS REALLY OF
PLANETARY ISSUE AND AS EVERYONE
SAID MENTIONING DURING THE
PANDEMIC. SO WITH THAT I WANTED
TO PUT ON THE RECORD ON THAT WE
ARE ONE ONLY REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION TODAY AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE VERY MUCH AND SENATOR
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALWAYS
BEING SO KIND OF PROFESSIONAL.
EVERYWHERE YOU ARE WONDERFUL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISS LYNCH WERE REALLY GRATEFUL
THAT YOU'RE WITH US TODAY
INDEED THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
ON THE GOOD NEWS AND CLEARLY
YOU AIMED AT THIS IN THE WOMAN
BEEN WORKING HARD TOGETHER SO.
VERY VERY GRATEFUL MISS LYNCH
IN SORRY ABOUT NOT BRINGING YOU
UP EARLIER SO WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ARE ALL RIGHT SO- LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN WE'RE GOING TO
BE- I THINK I PRAY I PRAY YOU
HAVE ANYTHING YOU WANT. TO SAY.
ALL RIGHT GREAT TO. THE PRAYER
JUST GIVE US A TO FINGER NOTED
THAT MEANS BUT- THERE WE GO-
WE'RE GOING TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO STEP FORWARD. IN
SUPPORT RESEARCH GOING TO START
WITH SUPPORT IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX INCREASED
INCOME FOR NOW. SEE NO ONE WE
ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES WERE GONNA CHECK IN
WITH- MADAME MODERATOR META
MODERATOR. THAT'S AT CHECK IN
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX IF SO. CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
THEM UP NOW. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE NINETEEN Q. WILL START
WITH MY NUMBER TWO SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS JENNIFER FEARING. THE
PRESSING MY LAUGHTER O EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX ON BEHALF OF THE OCEANIC
AND OCEAN CONSERVANCY I'VE ALSO
BEEN ASKED TO EXPRESS THE
SUPPORT OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THANK YOU WE ALWAYS
WELCOME IN MY RIGHT NOW MR AZAM
IS HEARING TO COMMITTEE. YEAH
ALL RIGHT I THINK MYSTERIANS
GIANTS FANS. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING AS
ALWAYS VERY GRATEFUL LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN TURN
MEMBERS NIKITA KARATE WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL CALLING ON TRUMP REPORT
THANK YOU THE KEY HAS BEEN WITH
US- ALL ATERNOON. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE VERY
GRATEFUL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. DR SPENT NINE TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN YOU. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN WHAT'S GOING ON TO KEEP.
THANK YOU. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
TURN MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER
FROM YELTSIN MARC MARON BEHALF
OF MARIN COUNTY BOARD THANK
YOUNG THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
THAN PRESHEAF PHONE CALL LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
REMEMBER I THOUGHT YOU TALK ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING CLIENT
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT DEALERSHIP
COUNCIL NATIONAL ACTION COUNCIL
DR LAKE. COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO
SALT LAKE THE THEATER IN NORTH
AMERICA LIKE THE PASSWORD I CAN
PARTNER WITH MANAGEMENT ALREADY
AND HE A BEVERLY HILLS ON THE
CORNER EIGHTY WELCOME TO DETECT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
APPRECIATE. YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE FORTY
SEVEN YEAR IS OPEN. AFTERNOON
MEMBERS NICOLE KOREAN ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
TO CALL APPRECIATE THAT NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE TO TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON LESLIE ON MALLEY
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF SANTA
CRUZ IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE. THANK YOU REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
TWO SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE JUDGE JUST MILAN
BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR OF THIS
MEASURE THE TEENS HE'S LOBBY
COALITION AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOSED. COLLATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
JUSTIN VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE TO THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS A LEASE
CONTRACT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANKS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AT LEAST SIX HOLLOW
PLEASE. MY TO SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CATHERINE I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE OF NURSES FOR HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU CATHARINE NEXT
LINE PLEASE. MY NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME'S
MAKAYLA JARI AND EXEMPTIONS LOS
ANGELES I AM A STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE CENTS BACK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MAKAYLA LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. GOING TO
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS YOUR LAYER IN THE
NONPROFIT CRITICAL TIME A
CRITICAL CLINCH CLOSE.
PROXIMITY WHICH WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA TO KIND OF CUT
THREE. RESTAURANTS. MONEY IN
PROTECTING OUR PLANET IN OCEAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CARE. LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CONFERENCE. NOT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT ALL RIGHT NOT A
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS THAT LAYS
IN GERMAN I CAN SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO GET A
RISE IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX CAN YOU PLEASE DO
SO NOW. C. KNOWN RISE. IN ORDER
TO DO. THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
MODERATOR AT PER AT CENTER
DRIVES SO I MET A MODERATOR
GONNA CHECK BCK WITH YOU TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE THEM UP NOW. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB ONE TWO SEVEN SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND THERE
WAS NO ONE OPPOSING THE BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH A MATTER
MODERATOR WE'LL SEE IN JUST A
SECOND AT THE THREE BACK TO
COMMITTEE WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS ON. THE
BILL WILL BE BUILT ALL RIGHT.
CUT RIGHT TO IT. GET IT WITH
THE NIGHT. RUBIO HIS LITTLE
PUNCH. I KNOW ALL RIGHT. BUT
EXCUSE ME. OKAY RIGHT OR THERE
WE GO ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR DORADO- IS IN
THEIR CAREER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES THANK YOU- AB TWELVE
TWENTY SIX AN IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP AT NO POINT ADDITIONAL
STEPS TO SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
WASTE TENTH FROM PLASTIC AND
OTHER SINGLE USE MATERIALS THAT
POLLUTE OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
ULTIMATELY AT THE END OF THE
DAY ALSO HELPS BUSINESSES
REDUCE THEIR COSTS AND- I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I'VE
UP THANK YOU SO MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
DRIVE. SO SHE IS READY TO PUT A
FORK IN IT. ALL. FOR CALLING-
YOUR DAUGHTER ALREADY TAKE THE
WORLD SERIES- YOU KNOW CARILLO.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE WE HAVE A MOST
BY DRAW. MISTER GRINNELL WHOSE
I WANTED I GO TO CALL FOR THIS
SO- WE'RE GONNA TURN OVER TO MR
NOW IT BE ABLE TO CALL THE
MOTION CALL VOTE. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI MCGUIRE AYE SENATOR NIELSEN
HI NIELSEN- A SENATOR DORADO.
DORADO A SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR SKINNER. THAT'S A THREE
ZERO VOTE BY PARTISAN THANK YOU
SO MUCH OF VERY GRATEFUL EYES
IN NUMBER FISHING. FAMILY TAKE
A STAB AT THIS- HE'S GONNA BE
HERE ALL NIGHT. THAT IS
FANTASTIC I WANT THANK YOU
MEMBER CAN WITH FORCES IN THIS
THIS LEGISLATION THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AND I APPRECIATE
ACCOMMODATIONS AND THE
AMENITIES. THAT IS FANTASTIC
SENATOR. EAGER LIVES WITH A
PUNCH. BIGELOW WITH THIS YOU
KNOW GOOD LEGISLATION TAKES
TIME AND IT TAKES FOLKS COMING
TO THE TABLE TO COME TO AN
AGREEMENT AS TO WHAT WORKS BEST
AND HOW CONSUMERS USE THAN WHAT
WE ACTUALLY NEED FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING THIS DONE THERE WE GO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NICE JOB I
LOVE THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL
RIGHT. IT ERIADOR JEEZ ALL
RIGHT SO LAYS IN GERMAN- WE
LOVE WORKING. WITH ALL RIGHT
NEXT AUTHOR- AND SHE IS CHAIR
OF. REVENUE TAX IN THE
ASSEMBLY. I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR
OUR PARTNERSHIP WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE. A CERTAIN NUMBER BURKE
PRESENT ON ALL ISSUES OF AB
TWELVE OH THREE SO WILL
HAVE YOU TAKE TO THE PODIUM
PLEASE AND WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP. A
QUICK. AB TWELVE OH THREE AS IT
IS- DISTRICT BILL SPONSORED BY
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES THAT
WILL ENABLE TAXPAYERS SHOULD
ISSUE PROPERTY ASSESSMENTS IN A
TIMELY MANNER IT WOULD SIMPLY
EXPAND THE POOL OF POTENTIAL
APPLICANTS FOR SERVICE ON AN
ASSESSMENT APPEALS BOARD IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ALSO PERMITTING
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO
REDUCE THE WAITING PERIOD THAT
A FORMER ASSESSOR EMPLOYEES
SUBJECT TO FOURTH FROM THREE
YEARS TO LESS THAN TO LESS THAN
ONE YEAR SHOULD THEY SEE FIT.
TO THE PANDEMIC ALL IN PERSON
APPEAL HEARINGS IN THE COUNTY
WERE HALTED FROM MARCH
TWENTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY AS A
RESULT THE NUMBER OF OPEN
APPEALS APPLICATIONS REQUIRING
A HEARING INCREASED 25404%
LATEST FIGURES FROM THE COUNTY
SO THAT THERE ARE CURRENTLY
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETY OPEN APPEALS
APPLICATIONS THAT NUMBER IS
EXPECTED TO KEEP TURNING UP
WITH MANY RETAILERS EXPECTING
TO FILE APPEALS AS A RESULT OF
THE PANDEMIC FEEL DECLINE. IN
PROPERTY VALUES SIMPLY PUT THIS
BACKGROUND MUST BE ADDRESSED
LAST YEAR WE PASSED LEGISLATION
TO REMOVE THE CAP ON THE NUMBER
APPEALS BOARD PERMITTED. THE
COUNTY. UNDER THE AUTHORITY OF
THAT LEGSLATION L. A. COUNTY
HAS CREATED ONE ADDITIONAL
BOARD AND HAS PLANS TO CREATE
AN ADDITIONAL BOARD IN THE NEAR
FUTURE. FLEXIBILITY TO EXPAND
THE UNIVERSE OF POTENTIAL
APPEAL BOARD MEMBERS TO
PROFESSIONALS FROM THE REAL
ESTATE FIELD WILL HELP THE
COUNTY MAXIMIZE THE USE OF
THOSE ADDITIONAL BOARD. CENTER
AB TWELVE OH THREE IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION TOWARDS
HELPING TAXPAYERS BY RESOLVING
THEIR APPEALS AN EFFICIENT AND
TIMELY MANNER WITH ME IN
SUPPORT OVER THE PHONE IS.
EDWARD YENICE ISN'T EXECUTIVE
OFFICER WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY EXECUTIVE OFFICE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I. AM
SURE IT'S GOOD TO SEE THINGS
MUCH AT FOR YOU WORK ON THIS.
AND MEDICARE I'M GONNA GO VOTE
IN HOUSING YEAH I'M GOING TO
TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO THE VICE
CHAIR- WE'RE GOING TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER FIRST- TO. A MYSTERY
IN AFRIN. LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES SIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING WITH US- AND
PLEASE PROCEED IN ADVENTURE BE
BACK WITH YOU MARK MONITOR. GO
AHEAD YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN A
MEMBER LET THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS EDWARD
YEAH AND I AM ASSISTANT
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. OUR OFFICE MANAGES
THE COUNTY'S ASSESSMENT DEALS
PROGRAM AND I'M SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE THREE. I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE FOR AUTHORING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AB TOTAL THREE
WOULD PROVIDE CRUCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE BOARD'S
EXECUTIVE OFFICE. TO APPOINT
BOARD MEMBERS TO HEAR TAXPAYER
APPEALS. UNDER EXISTING LAW
THERE ARE LIMITATIONS TO
RECRUITING CANDIDATES TO SERVE
ON THE ASSESSMENT BILLS FOR.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW LOS
ANGELES COUNTY TO IDENTIFY AND
EXPAND THE POOL OF QUALIFIED
CANDIDATES TO SERVE IN OUR
APPEALS PROGRAM. AB TWELVE
THREE WILL HELP BROADEN THE
QUALIFICATIONS THAT WILL ALLOW
US TO RECRUIT. PEOPLE THE REAL
ESTATE SECTOR WHO EVALUABLE
EXPERIENCES THAT WE CANNOT
REACH UNDER EXISTING LAW. BY
ALLOWING A PERSON WITH A
MINIMUM OF FIVE YEARS
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE IN THE
REAL ESTATE FIELD INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO BUSINESS
ACCOUNTING. AND TAXATION LAND
USE AND URBAN PLANNING REAL
ESTATE DEVELOPMENT OR
INVESTMENT ANALYSIS AND IN REAL
ESTATE BANKING OR FINANCING
WILL BROADEN THE POOL OF
CANDIDATES TO INCLUDE PEOPLE
WITH PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE.
RELATED TO PROPERTY APPRAISALS
AND NOT JUST LIMITED TO PEOPLE
WITH PROFESSIONAL DEGREES ARE
LICENSES FOR EXAMPLE WE MIGHT
FIND SOMEONE WITH TWENTY YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE IN EVALUATING
APPRAISALS FOR BANKS. OR
ANALYZING REAL ESTATE SALES
DATA AND TRENDS FOR PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT COMPANY BUT WITHOUT
A REAL ESTATE BROKERS LICENSE
LAW DEGREE OR PRISON LICENSE.
THAT PERSON IS UNAVAILABLE FOR
US TO EVEN CONSIDER FOR
POSITION ON THE ASSESSMENT
FIELD SPORT. LOS ANGELES COUNTY
HAS BY FAR THE MOST APPEAL
APPLICATIONS FILED IN THE STATE
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE
RECEIVED NEARLY AS MANY
APPLICATIONS AS THE NEXT FIVE
LARGEST COUNTIES COMBINED.
CONSEQUENTLY WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO CREATE MANY MORE
APPEALS COURTS TO COUNTER THESE
HEARINGS. SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
AB THIRTY THREE SEVENTY THREE
LAST YEAR. OUR COUNTY HAS
INCREASED THE NUMBER OF PORTS
FROM FIVE TO SIX WE ANTICIPATE
EXPANDING UP TO TEMPLE WHAT BY
NEXT YEAR. THUS DOUBLING OUR
CAPACITY TO STAFF SCHEDULE IN
HERE THE MORE THAN THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND APPEALS. APPLICATION
ARE CURRENTLY IN OUR SYSTEM. AS
WELL AS THOUSAND OF ANTI.
APPEALS THAT WILL BE THIS YEAR
DUE TO COVERT NINETEEN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR COMMITTEE
GIVE AB TOLD THREE ITS APPROVAL
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. VERY
GOOD AND WE HAVE A- MR PRAYER
YOU ALSO TESTIFYING. I'M NOT
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION AND
OPPOSITION OKAY. WE HAVE A
SECOND THEN. PROPONENT
TESTIFIED WE DO NOT ALL RIGHT
WHY DON'T WE THEN GO TO THE
MODERATOR FOR THE CALL IN.
SUPPORT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE OH THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN
CUBA START WITH MY NUMBER TWO
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MATTHEW CYBERLINK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANKS- NEXT. ONE ONE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON VANESSA CHAVEZ ON BOB
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS PART LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE. I THINK
THE AMERICAN DURING THANK YOU.
LIKE TO NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY TO NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CORRECT BOB
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF MY NAME
IS JEFFREY PRANG I AM THE
ASSESSOR OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE AS PRESENTED BY THE
OFFICE. THANK YOU AND I. AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
WANTS SUPPORT- GOOD. AND DO WE
HAVE OPPOSITION. WITH JUST THE
FRONT MR PRAYER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL-
AND MADAM CHAIR WHILE WE
DISAGREE ON THIS BILL I AGREE
WITH YOUR SELECTION OF YOUR NEW
LEDGE DIRECTOR- GOOD GUY- SHARE
MEMBERS MARKER PRAYER I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF.
TAXPAYER ADVOCATES NOTICED
KEITA IT IS A STATEWIDE TRADE
ASSOCIATION COMPRISED OF TAX
CONSULTANTS AND ATTORNEYS
REPRESENTING TAXPAYERS BEFORE
COUNTY ASSESSOR'S COUNTY
ASSESSMENT APPEALS BARDS AND
THE STATE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
ALSO HERE AND AUTHORIZED TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION AND THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION.
ON BEHALF OF THE MEMBERS OF
KEITA AND HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION AND-
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION ALMOST.
RESPECTFULLY CONTINUE TO OPPOSE
TWELVE OH THREE. BY REDUCING
THE COOLING OFF PERIOD FOR
FORMER ASSESSOR PERSONNEL.
SEEKING TO SERVE THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY APPEALS BOARD
ASSESSMENT APPEALS BOARD FROM
THREE YEARS TO ONE. AB TWELVE
THREE WE BELIEVE INVITES BIAS
FROM THE ASSESSMENT APPEALS
PROCESS AND UNDERMINES THE
PUBLIC'S CONFIDENCE IN THE
SYSTEM. HE ALWAYS PROPERTY TAX
RULES THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE
THREE E. THREE TWENTY FOUR AM
THREE ZERO TO SEE FIRST UPON
INDICATES THAT IN DECIDING AN
APPEALS CASE ASSESSMENT APPEALS
BOARD MEMBERS MUST RELY
EXCLUSIVELY. ON EVIDENCE
PRESENTED DURING THE HEARING
AND NOT RELY UPON OUTSIDE
KNOWLEDGE. REDUCING THE COOLING
OFF PERIOD ALLOWS FORMER
ASSESSOR PERSONNEL TO DECIDE
CASES RELATING TO MORE RECENT
ASSESSMENTS OF WHICH THEY MAY
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED OR LIKELY
HAVING A INTERMITTENTLY FILM
FAMILIAR IN THE PROCESS THE
PLAYERS. AND THE PROPERTY. THIS
IS PATENTLY UNFAIR AND VIOLATES
THE PROPERTY TAX RULES. IN AN
EFFORT TO ADDRESS THESE ARE
CONCERNS WE MET SEVERAL TIMES
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE WITH A
STAFF OF THE ASAP ASSEMBLY
REVENUE TAX COMMITTEE. AS WELL
AS LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE
PROPOSE SEVERAL ROUNDS OF
POSSIBLE AMENDMENTS DESIGNED TO
ALLEVIATE OUR CONCERNS. DESPITE
OUR BEST EFFORTS THESE
DISCUSSIONS WERE NOT
SUCCESSFUL. SO AS LONG AS
TWELVE OH THREE UNDERMINES THE
OBJECTIVITY OF ASSESSMENT
APPEALS BOARD MEMBERS WE MUST
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR PRAYER PRECIADO VERY
MUCH. OR IN THE WORLD OKAY YEAH.
GOT IT THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL
RIGHT I DO APOLOGIZE GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HANGING WITH US THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU CAN PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AN ORGANIZATION YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIR NUMBERS-
MY NAME'S LARISSA MERCADO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSESSORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWO OF
THE THREE. I WAS CHARLIE OSCAR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND TED MISTER PRATT-
IS WELL THANK YOU FOR HANGING
WITH US INTO LEAVING HERE FOR A
LONG TIME SO WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'VE- BEEN
SITTING THROUGH- ALL THE OTHER
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TO- THAT
TELEPHONE LINES TO BE ABLE TO
SEEK OPPOSITION. TO AB TWELVE
OH THREE SELF MADAME MODERATOR
WHY DON'T WE OPEN UP THE
TELEPHONE LINES IF YOU COULD
PLEASE. QUEUE UP ANY
INDIVIDUAL. WHO IS- IN
OPPOSITION AND MAYBE TWELVE OR
THREE NOW. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY TWELVE OH
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
TWELVE OH THREE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO. AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE OPPOSING THE BILL
ALL RIGHT THANKYOU SO MUCH
VERY GRATEFUL. AT SOLEIL'S
GERMAN AND BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE I TO BE ABLE TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS OR WILL ALSO
WELCOME A MOTION AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE
MAJORITY LEADER MAJORITY LEADER
HERTZBERG HAS A MOTION TO
APPROVE ON THE FLOOR- ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
KAREN C. NINE AT MADAM CHAIR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE
I THINK YOU I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE CONCERNS WITH THE
APPEALS A PROCESS AS A WHOLE
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES. NOT ADDRESS IS ALSO
FURTHER MORE AS MENTIONED IN
ANALYSIS CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS
MEMBERS OF OR HEARING OFFICERS
FROM KNOWING PARTICIPATING IN
ANY ASSESSMENT APPEALS
PROCEEDING. WHERE IN THE MEMBER
HAS AN INTEREST IN EITHER THE
SUBJECT MATTER OR PARTY TO THE
PRECEDING OF SUCH A NATURE THAT
IT COULD BE REASONABLY BE
IMPARTIALITY OF HIS JUDGMENTS
ON CURRENT LAW. OF THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED AND IT IS IN THE
ANALYSIS WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I ABOUT THANK YOU
SO MUCH VERY GRATEFUL- WE'RE AN
ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWELVE OH
THREE MOTION IS ON THE FLOOR BY
THE MAJORITY LEADER. MR RIGHT
NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
FORMAL MOTION IN BECAUSE OF A-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FOR. SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE
MCGUIRE AYE SENATOR NIELSEN.
SENATOR DORADO HI TORONTO I
SENATOR HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HIS
SENATOR SKINNER. SKINNER HI
THAT IS A FOUR ZERO VOTE AT
SENATOR AND VICE CHAIR NIELSEN
WILL NOT BE COMING BACK TO
COMMITTEE DUE TO ANOTHER
APPOINTMENT- IN MEETING SO
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLE
THAT IS CURRENTLY A FOUR ZERO
VOTE FOR YOUR VOTE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE THANK YOU SO MUCH TOO
FAST. HEY THERE YOU GO EXACTLY.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
OUR FINAL BILL- IN PRESENTING
ON BEHALF OF MISS FRIEDMAN. IS
GOING TO BE SENATOR DRAWS OFF
CENTER DRUGS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
DO THAT AT FROM YOUR DESK. YES
PLEASE MA'AM- PLEASE PROCEED
AND- WE DO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. ON THIS BILL SO OF THE
FLOOR IS YOURS AT CENTER DRAWS
ON BEHALF OF HIS IN THE FREE
MATH. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
UP SOME BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN I ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENT ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS. REGARDING THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FEE OF. FORTY- IN
FEBRUARY COULD CUT THIS DOWN-
IS FRIEDMAN'S OFFICE HAS HAD
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
REALTORS AND REPRESENTED FOR
SITTING COUNTIES TO RESOLVE THE
ISSUE OF COST RECOVERY FOR
DOING INSPECTIONS THE OBVIOUS
HOPEFUL THAT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT TAKEN TODAY RESOLVE
THOSE CONCERNS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT AND ABLE TO ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ARE SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE- FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
BRIAN A GUSTO FROM THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YEAH IT
CENTER DRUGS OF SCHOOL FIRST
YEAR FOR FROM ARE TO THE- FOUR
WITNESSES AND WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM OUR LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS. THAT START WITH MISS
CASTILLO REPRESENTING THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY THIS COULD STEAL YOU
HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES WE'LL
GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND PROMPT.
PLEASE PROCEED IN WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBER. BECAUSE THE- WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON MOM ALREADY
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT.
EIGHT WHICH WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR AT. EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT AM SHARE TENANTS ACROSS
THE STATE CAN REQUEST IN FACT
NUMBER HOME IN RESPONSE TO
DEFICIENCY WITHOUT HAVING
INAPPROPRIATE CONDITIONS PLACED
ON THE RIGHT THAT. ACTION AS
THE FIFTH LARGEST AND OLDEST
THE COURT BETTER WE HEAR FROM
LEGAL SERVICE PROVIDERS ACROSS
THE STATE REPRESENT LOW INCOME
RENTERS. SOMETIMES BIG BARRIERS
IN ASKING FOR AN INSPECTION TO
HABITABILITY COMPLAINT. I FIND
THE ARTICLE THAT BEFORE
INSPECTOR CAN COME AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE HOUSING ESTATE
THAT THEY MUST JUMP THROUGH
HOOPS. FOR THAT INFECTION
STEVEN OCCUR. CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY IMPOSES UNIFORM
OBLIGATIONS AND ALL LANDLORDS
MAINTAIN RENTAL PROPERTY THREE
FROM THE FACT THAT THAT
DANGEROUS MALLS. DEFECTIVE
WIRING AND THE LIGHT. ENSURING
PUBLICATION BERMAN IS THE
UNIVERSAL EXPECTATIONS EVERY
DAY BOTH TENANTS AND LANDLORDS
ACROSS THE STATE WORK TOGETHER
QUICKLY TO ADDRESS CONCERNS.
IT'S ALL THE LIFESPAN
OBLIGATIONS ARE LIABILITIES
THAT GOVERNMENT REMEMBER. IN
WINTER. THINGS THE THING
OBLIGATIONS AREN'T FOR. EIGHT
THREE PROVIDED UP THE WORK OF
THE WORK BY LEADERS AMONG.
CALIFORNIA IF THEY AND EVERY
LOCAL. HAS AN INTEREST INTO IN
ENSURING LANDLORDS NEED
UPDATION AND DO NOT ALLOW
PROPER. HERE EIGHT I BELIEVE
WORK WITHOUT ON GOING HOUSING.
AND I CURRENT HEALTH RIGHT.
EIGHTY EIGHT IN THE COMMON
SENSE L. THAT WILL ENSURE. ARE
PUTTING EQUAL RIGHTS AND-OF
OUR HEALTH SAFETY. FOR MISTER
HOUSING STOCK A PROTRACTED I
MEAN IN. AND FROM DANGER OR
UNHEALTHY CAN GET IN OUR HOUSE.
FOR ALL THE REASONS WE URGE YOU
YOU TO THE CORPORATE AND
FORGETTING ABOUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF FOR
YOUR TESTING THIS BECAUSE HERE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO THE
LEGENDARY BRYAN ACOSTA
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION MR CRESSY. ABOUT THE
TWO MINUTES THE FLOOR STORE SIR.
CHAIRMAN BRIAN I GOT DOWN THE
OF THE CAR. WILL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION- FOR OUR RURAL
CLIENTS WE HEAR ALL THE TIME
FROM OUR LEGAL SERVICES CALLING
IN THE FIELD- STORIES THAT
HAVE. TENANTS WHO ARE
DESPERATELY IN NEED OF AN
INSPECTION EITHER TO MAKE THEIR
HOUSING SAFER. FOR THEIR FAMILY
OR TO SUBSTANTIATE- WHAT THEY
HAVE BEEN. CALLING THE LANDLORD
ARE PROBLEMS AND THEN. FIND IT
AN INSPECTION. WON'T BE HAD FOR
A VARIETY OF REASONS- EITHER
BECAUSE THEY REFUSED TO
INSPECT- AND LET THE TENANT
MEET CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS OR
THEY BELIEVE THERE ARE SOME
ONGOING DISPUTE BETWEEN THE
LANDLORD AND TENANT. AND NOT
JUST IMPAIRS THE ABILITY OF. OF
OUR CLIENTS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND- IT ALLOWS- UNSCRUPULOUS
LANDLORDS TO AVOID. THE CARD
SECTION AT THE STATE AFFORDS.
TO TENANTS- I THINK A VERY
REASONABLE. MANDATE THAT EVERY
AND EVERY REQUEST FOR
INSPECTION RESULTS IN AN
INSPECTION. AND ASSESSMENT OF
THE CONDITIONS AND IN ORDER TO
FIX THEM IF THAT IS WHAT IT IS.
REQUIRED AND FOR THAT REASON
ARE WOULD ORGANIZED- WE'VE
BEEN. IN ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
AND SPORTS NOTED WITH THE
REALTOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OVER
THE QUESTION OF FEES I THINK WE-
HOPEFULLY REACHED A PLACE WHERE
EVERYONE IS HAPPY AND- PEOPLE
LEARN MORE HERE IN A MOMENT BUT
JOB WE WOULD URGE EVERYONE. TO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE YOU CAN
MOVE A CALIFORNIA CONTINUE.
THIS CONVERSATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER GRASSO
PRECIADO TED THAT LAYS IN
GENERAL COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE GOING TO OUR LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS WE HAVE ONE
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS ON
RECORD THAT'S KARIM TO RE SEE.
THAT WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER
TO I MISSED. TO KAREEM-
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WELCOME
TO COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE TODAY- AND
HANG IN WITH US ALL THE WAY
HERE TO THE AND THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
MUCH MISTER CHAIR- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CLEAN THREE C. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. AB EIGHT CREATE AS
AMENDED ON JUNE TWENTY THIRD.
WOULD HAVE SATISFIED CAIR'S
CONCERNS UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. BUT AT THE TIME
OF THOSE AMENDMENTS. IT WAS
MADE CLEAR TO US THAT THE
LANGUAGE IN QUESTION. IS
CONSIDERED A WORK IN PROGRESS
AND WE'RE GOING TO ALMOST
CERTAINLY BE CHANGED. DUE TO
ONGOING INPUT FROM VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS. AS A RESULT C. R.
MAINTAINED OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON AB EIGHT
CREATE AND CONTINUE TO
DILIGENTLY WORK WITH THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE THE SPONSORS.
AND IDENTIFYING LANGUAGE
AMENABLE TO A WIDER ARRAY OF
STAKEHOLDERS. NOW AS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE LANGUAGE
RELATED TO PROTECTING SMALL
HOUSING PROVIDERS WHO PLAY BY
THE RULES. HAS BEEN PERMANENTLY
FINALIZED WILL BE INCORPORATED
INTO THE BILL. BASED ON THIS
UNDERSTANDING IN OUR REVIEW OF
THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO S. C. A. R.'S
REMOVING IT OPPOSITION EIGHTY
EIGHT THREE EIGHT AS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED. WE WISH TO
SINCERELY THANK THE AUTHOR. THE
AUTHOR STAFF AND SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS AND WE ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR SINCERE
GRATITUDE TO THE CHAIR. THE
COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEE STATUS
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AGAIN FOR BEING WITH US
ALL THIS TIME AND- FOR YOU
BEING IDEAS HOLDING OUT FOR THE
AFTERNOON WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
ALL RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE
GOING NOW CHECKING HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT. OF
THE BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROCEED SEEN NO ONE STAND WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE GONNA
CHECK IN WITH BETTER MODERATOR.
AMANDA MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF. AB
EIGHT THREE EIGHT NOW. LADIES
CAN GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD
SPEAK OF THE- OF EIGHT. EIGHT
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN
CUBA OPEN MY TO NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER YOU'RE A
MEMBER RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IT'S HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER MARTIN
GOOD TO HEAR VOICES GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. MY TWO FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS JENNIFER POCKET THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND
AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE LIKE THE PORT THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR WILL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU WE'RE GOING TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION AB EIGHT THREE EIGHT
IF YOU COULD PLEASE RISE NOW.
SEEN KNOWN RISE ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE FOR THE LAST TIME
TODAY LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE
GONNA SAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
READING MODERATOR FOR YOUR WORK
IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF A
MARATHON WE APPRECIATE ALL OF
YOUR HARD WORK TODAY. NOT A
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO MAY
BE IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT
THREE EIGHT CAN YOU PLEASE DO
SO NOW. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU. WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY EIGHT TWO
THREE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB EIGHT THREE EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS WASN'T THE ROLE AT THE
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
OPPOSING THE DOCTOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH BETTER MODERATOR HAVE A
GREAT WEEKEND AT THE MAJORITY
LEADER HAS MOVED THE BILL WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MAJORITY LEADER. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. HEARING SEEN NINE-
CENTER DRUGS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN I RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER NOW CAN YOU- PLEASE CALL
THE MOTION AND CALL THEM THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE BY
BY SENATOR NIELSEN. SENATOR
DORADO DORADO I SENATOR
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG- A SENATOR
SKINNER HI SKINNER I FOR YOUR
VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE
CLOSE THE ROLE FOR YOUR VOTE.
THE BILL'S OUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT CAN YOU GIVE US
THIRTY SECONDS MEMBERS WHO WERE
GONNA GET OUR- COLLECTIVE STUFF
TOGETHER IN WILL CALL- ALL THE
ABSENT VOTES THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HEY HI OCTANE. THANKS FOR
EVERYTHING HAVE A WONDERFUL
WEEKEND.
ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GERMAN AND I FORGOT TO MENTION
WELCOME CENTER SKINNER MY
GOODNESS- FOR IT WHEN SHE'S
HELPING A ONE AND DONE HEARING.
SO VERY GRATEFUL AS THE BUDGET
YEAR IS QUITE BUSY THESE DAYS
SO LET'S OPEN UP OF THE ROLE
HERE. IN THAT START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ARE CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSISTS OF ITEMS
NUMBER ONE ITEM NUMBER THREE IN
ITEM NUMBER FOUR ONE THREE AND
FOUR ON THE KITCHEN COUNTER.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO
MISTER NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG AYE
SENATOR SKINNER SKINNER HI IT'S
A FIVE YEAR VOTE THAT BILL IS
THAT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TEN SEVENTEEN
CURRENT VOTE IS TO ONE MR NOW.
SENATOR HERTZBERG THIS IS A
COURT ALRIGHT HERTZBERG AYE
SENATOR SKINNER. SKINNER I FOR
ONE VOTE THE BILL IS THAT WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLE WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR GRAYSON.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO MR
CONNEL SENATOR HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE SENATOR SKINNER.
SKINNER HI FIVE ZERO VOTE FOR
CLOSING THE ROLE THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
TO. EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE
CURRENT VOTE IS TO ONE MR NOW
SENATOR HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
SENATOR SKINNER. SKINNER HI
FOUR ONE VOTE THE BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROVER NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
NUMBERS ON ITEM NUMBER SEVEN-
THIS BILL WAS AMENDED STRIPPED
DOWN AND- AS A MEMBER WORD WILL
BE BACK IN FRONT OF US IN
AUGUST. THERE IS GOING TO BE A
GROUP WITH HOUSING
APPROPRIATIONS ARE COMMITTEE
ALONG WITH THIS IN THE REWARD
TO BE ABLE TO. BRING THIS BILL
BACK SO- CURRENT VOTE EAST TWO
ONE MR CANAL SENATOR HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE AYES SENATOR
SKINNER. SKINNER HI. THE FINAL
VOTE IS FOR ONE THE BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KIRK WITH. CURRENT GOAL IS
THREE ZERO MISTER GRINNELL
SENATOR HERTZBERG. NUMBER EIGHT
AND NUMBER EIGHT SIR. HERTZBERG
AYE SENATOR SKINNER. SKINNER HI.
FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT
RECALLS IN THE WE'RE NOW MOVING
TO ITEM NUMBER NINE A. B. C.
FIVE NINE. CURRENT VOTE IS TO
ONE MR CONNEL SENATOR HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE SENATOR SKINNER.
SKINNER I FOR ONE VOTE THAT
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE ITEM NUMBER TEN MCCARTY AB
NINE SEVENTY CURRENT VOTE IS TO
ONE MR NOW SENATOR HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE SENATOR SKINNER
SKINNER I FOR ONE VOTE THAT
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTY
NINE OH THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER KERN VOTE IS TWO ZERO
MISTER NOW. SENATOR NIELSEN.
YES SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
SKINNER. I WILL CALL AFTER
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME SENATOR
NIELSEN. SENATOR HERTZBERG
SENATOR SKINNER ALL RIGHT THAT
IS EIGHT TWO ZERO VOTE TWO ZERO
VOTE THE BILL FAILS AND WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ACT REQUEST
RECONSIDERATION. WE HAVE A
UNANIMOUS VOTE ON
RECONSIDERATION OF ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE TWO ZERO FAILS WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM SIXTEEN THIS
IS CURRENTLY AT EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SIX KERN VOTE IS THREE
ZERO MR CONNEL. OF 13% MAYES
SIGN ME UP SORRY THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER MAJORITY LEADER I
HEADED BEHIND ITEM SIXTEEN
APOLOGIZED ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
AB TEN TWENTY ONE MAYES CURRENT
VOTE IS TO ONE MR CONNEL CENTER
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG FIVE
SENATORS SKINNER SKINNER HI
THERE IS A FOUR ONE VOTE FOR
ONE VOTE AT THAT BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE THAT
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
SIXTEEN. EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SIX GREAT CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE ZERO MR CONNEL SENATOR
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE SENATOR
SKINNER. SKINNER HI FOUR ZERO
VOTE THAT BILL IS THAT WE'RE
CLOSE TO THE ROLE WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB TWELVE OH THREE
WHICH WE HAVE DONE. IN
DISPENSED WITH WE'RE NOW GOING
TO MOVE ON CHIU LET'S SEE WHO
WE NEED TO ADD ON AND WE HAVE.
DO FIFTEEN WE'RE GOOD YES WE
HAD. GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS.
EDWARDS FROM. YEAH.THE GREAT
FALLS ACTUALLY. DO WE HAVE MORE
TO GO- AND THAT'S TO IS HAVE A
FOR YEAR VOTE ON ITEMS WE'RE
GONNA GO TO FINAL- TODAY ITEM
EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY CORE CURRENT
VOTE IS THREE EASY MISTER OUT
CENTER HURTS HERTZBERG HIS
SENATORS. SKINNER- A FIVE YEAR
THAT BILL IS THAT WERE A LITTLE
TO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO I
TO MISTER NOW THE GOT FIGHT WE
WILL BE BACK IN ACTION IN
AUGUST WITH OUR TAX LEVY
HEARING ALONG WITH HEARING AB
FIVE HUNDRED AT MR MAJORITY
LEADER IS ALWAYS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. SOONER SKINNER THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US TODAY IT WILL
SEE EVERYONE BACK HERE IN A IN
AUGUST THIS MEANS THAT YOUR.